Intro/Outro
An der Klimaanlage Mensch hat ja noch keiner was vom Klimawandel erzählt.
Deswegen muss ich die Klimaanlage anmachen denn ich weiß selbstverständlich dass das ökologisch nicht so ganz wunderbar ist allerdings muss ich sagen dass ich ja sonst doch sehr sehr verträglich bin was das Klima anbelangt denn ich reise ja nicht.
Nicht nur weil corona ist sondern ich reise ja generell nie.
Meine letzte Flugreise liegt zehn Jahre zurück und ich wundere mich aber auch über diese Reise Wut nicht darüber dass jetzt Leute mit der Familie mal ein bisschen raus wollen.
Aber dass man jetzt überlegt man muss unbedingt mal nach Thailand nach Lissabon.
Noch weiß ich nicht wohin jetzt fliegen. Das wundert mich schon sehr dass man jetzt auch mit Freunden durch Norditalien läuft.
Mir scheint es irgendwie ein bisschen so als hätten wir jetzt das Virus gehabt und jetzt ist wieder gut.
Und ich wundere mich dann auch über diese Menge.
Wir haben uns schon mal darüber gesprochen. Ich wundere mich darüber dass es immer so etwas gibt was man gerade verteufelt. Und das ist dann auch wenn vier Jugendliche im Park rumstehen dann ist das schon hochproblematisch Mai gewesen im Juni dann nicht mehr.
Jetzt ist es irgendwie vollkommen klar dass man noch reisen kann jetzt wird ernsthaft darüber diskutiert ob man dann überhaupt Tests machen muss. Jetzt werden sie gemacht.
Wer zahlt die. Dann denke ich ja der der sie braucht.
Das wäre jetzt meine überlegung Wer sich eine Reise leistet muss eben auch damit zusammen kommen.
Wenn ich jetzt nach Nordafrika oder oder nach Brasilien fliege dann würde ich mich auch vielleicht impfen lassen gegen verschiedene Dinge da komme ich ja dann auch auf. Es gibt ja kein Menschenrecht auf Reisen.
Wer jetzt nach Brasilien fliegt dem würde ich auch mal untersuchen und zwar nicht nur auf Coruna.
Aber die Frage Wer finanziert die Tests für die Rückkehrer das sind ja 40 Euro ist gar nicht so viel.
Ist eine prinzipielle Frage und ich habe mich da auch gefragt Warum gibt es jetzt wieder so ein Fuchur das die das privat bezahlen sollen,
unabhängig davon dass es ganz schön schwer zu organisieren ist die Leute im Flughafen so zu leiten dass sie dann nicht durchrutschen weil sie denken,
nur weil ihr hier klar gesagt habe Die soll das mal machen möchte sie jetzt nicht sondern Leute nehmen ja für Reisen und das ist ja dieses westliche Privileg das Privileg der reichen Länder.
Man nimmt ja fürs Reisen unglaublich viele allgemein Güter in Anspruch die Querfinanzierung sind.
Niemand bezahlt das Flugzeug selbst niemand bezahlt die Straße auf der er fährt selbst das ist alles aus allgemeinen Töpfen bezahlt.
Und bei der Frage die uns alle am meisten betrifft nämlich Coruña Abwehr kommt plötzlich die Idee auf das solle man privat finanzieren.
Das wäre keine allgemeine Aufgabe. Und das habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden.
Okay wenn du das jetzt in diesen größeren Dimensionen denkst dann stimmt das selbstverständlich dann kann man das immer sagen aber wir verwenden ständig Dinge die uns nicht in dem Sinne gehören oder die wir mit Steuergeldern bezahlt haben. Ich finde es nur in diesem Fall.
Da ist mir glaub ich noch so ein prinzipieller Denkfehler also insgesamt.
Warum muss man jetzt gerade reisen. Ich begreife das einfach nicht wir sind ja jetzt nicht 30 Jahre eingesperrt gewesen hinter einer Mauer,
und das Einzige was wir hatten war höchstens mal Balaton sondern wir können ja jetzt auch sagen Es ist jetzt dieses Jahr ein bisschen ungünstig mit dem Fliegen lassen wir das doch einfach mal.
Beim Fliegen bin ich einverstanden beim Reisen nicht ganz denn morgen oder gestern Abend hat Marcel Fratzscher Eine neue Studie veröffentlicht in der noch nochmal das Schicksal der Familien in Crooner dargestellt wurde.
Einfach.
Da kam nämlich auch für die ist ja der Start einfach ausgefallen man saß da mit den Kindern zu Hause und musste gleichzeitig noch Erwerbsarbeit machen.
Zu Hause und muss.
Und die brauchen jetzt alle Urlaub und ich gönne jeder Familie ihren Sommerurlaub mit vollem Herzen weil ich auch morgen dann in den Urlaub.
Den Familien und möchte nicht mißverstanden werden und es gibt ja auch Mittel und Wege dass man eben nicht jetzt diesen Massentourismus sofort wieder entfacht sondern es gibt Campingplätze Es gibt kleinere Hotelanlagen oder Ferienwohnungen.
Man kann sie in der Region bleiben oder vielleicht auch mal in die Niederlande oder so.
Aber nicht jetzt eben diese große Reise Wahnsinn und mir fällt es auf.
Doch als eifriger Twitter-User wie sehr viele Leute die Maske auf posteten jetzt überall unterwegs sind sich permanent dort fotografieren.
Also nicht diese Scham besitzen wie der Bischof der natürlich heimlich ins Bordell geht sondern auch das Ausstellen Wir sind wieder wer wir können wieder raus.
Und da muss ich sagen Da sehe ich auch schwarz perspektivisch auf den Klimawandel geblickt.
Also wenn man so wenig Disziplin hat und dann schon wieder sagen wir jetzt muss ich aber mal.
Dann sind das auch in der Regel nicht Leute die so arg gelitten haben in Coruna Zeiten das sind in der Regel Leute die mal eine Kolumne oder die gehen mal ins Fernsehen und sagen ein paar Dinge aber das sind jetzt nicht die hart arbeitenden mit fünf Kindern.
Stimmt dieser Juli zeigt was wir im April noch nicht zu fürchten wagten nämlich dass wir das die ganze Idee von dem Klima müssen was machen wir mit Corona.
Dass wir das die ganze Idee mit dem Klima nur machen wie mit Kohle.
Nicht lange hält ein kurzer Schockmoment. Historisch gesehen ist es schon wieder vorbei.
Ich werde natürlich was die Disziplin angeht morgen in die Niederlande fahren dort gibt's keine Massenflucht beim Einkaufen weshalb ich das dort mal ordentlich durchsetzen werde.
Während ich da. Ich werde Ihnen zeigen dass ich vernünftig bin dann natürlich auch wenn ich dann der einzige bin.
Ich kenne ja das Gefühl noch nicht wenn ich zu meinem Supermarkt gehe. Sie haben ja alle Masken auf.
Ich achte auch sehr darauf Ich habe es einmal gesehen habe ich gedacht. Von dem halte ich mich fern.
Ansonsten sehr diszipliniert. Mal gucken ob ich dann was ich feststelle.
Apropos Urlaub hat ja auch ein bisschen mit,
Exil zu tun. Es bestand ja jetzt die Möglichkeit via Fernsehen ins Exil zu gehen und zwar eine Reise zurück zu machen in den Gründungs Moment Amerikas wurde ein Musical verfilmt 2016 hergestellt.
Acht Jahre vorher fand es nicht so gut. Wir reden hier von Hamilton.
Ich finde es schön um mich zu ärgern. Nein ich fand es nicht so gut ich fand es weder als Musical musikalisch gut noch fand ich das so revolutionär was da gemacht wird Man muss vielleicht dazu sagen.
Das Besondere daran ist dass diese ganze,
Besetzung nicht weiß ist und dass man so auch Leute wie Jefferson oder so sieht gespielt von lateinamerikanischen Schauspielern afroamerikanischen Schauspielern. Wenn man so möchte.
Im
nochmal.
Was mich jetzt erst einmal als Opernsänger nicht verwundert weil es da in der Regel nicht so ist das italienische Opern von Italienern gesungen werden sondern da sind ja sehr viele Asiaten die ganzen Deutschen Chöre,
Stadttheatern sind in der Regel sehr stark asiatisch besetzt.
Auch die Spitzen Sänger in den Spitzen Rollen sind extrem international das heißt man,
betreibt ja eigentlich keine Identitätspolitik wenngleich es nochmal etwas anderes ist sicherlich wenn wir uns jetzt hier am Broadway befinden der ohnehin etwas konservativer ist und,
mit historischen Persönlichkeiten zu tun haben die wir in irgendeiner Weise kennen von dem wir ein Bild haben und da immer gerne diesen Gedanken der ähnlichkeit haben wollen dass wir sagen Okay sieht aber auch wirklich so aus.
Aber ich fand es dann musikalisch doch sehr an Musik erinnernd als an.
Also es gibt auch gute Filme. Gehört nicht dazu sage ich ausdrücklich aber es gibt auch gute Jugendwehr.
Es gibt sowieso immer mehr Musik in Filmen. Da stellt man ja auch fest bei Disney wird ja auch ein bisschen mehr noch gesungen als in den Filmen früher.
Ich will zur Hamlet nur kurz was sagen weil es allen die uns hier zuhören unbedingt empfehlen möchte sich dann doch mal anzuschauen.
Es ist ja auch gar nicht so teuer im Vergleich zu das Musical Erlebnis selbst.
Es ist für 96 die man gleich wieder kündigen kann bei Disney dann doch mal machbar.
Ich will es unbedingt empfehlen und meine Herangehensweise ist natürlich immer eine ganz andere das betrifft auch Michael Bay und die ganzen Disney Kinderfilme und so weiter.
Und bei Hamilton habe ich so erlebt was der tickte Schockmoment nochmal ausmacht.
Man schaltet das so ein und dann drei Stunden später stellt man fest Ich habe ja gar keine Ausschalter Impuls gehabt ich bin ja dran geblieben.
Und ich bin jetzt auch kein großer Musiker Kenner oder Freund Opa bin ich ganz weit entfernt aber dieses Hamilton Stück das nun mal hauptsächlich aus Schauspiel besteht.
Das ist ja anders als beim Film ist es ja nun wirklich nur Schauspiel eigentlich gerade doch da kein Bühnenbild also einfach nur eine die man am Anfang kurz sieht und dann wird's halt unterschiedlich beleuchtet aber die Variation kommt komplett über das Schauspiel und die Musik.
Und nach allem was ich mir auch mal angelesen habe zum Thema Wie gestaltet man eigentlich Musical.
Ich finde es ja wirklich zehn von zehn Punkten würde ich dafür geben mit diesem Drama Entwicklungen Protagonisten der Moment des Todes muss abgehandelt werden die Ballade fällt also irgendwann und bis zum Finale dann ja bis zum letzten Ton.
So fand ich das wirklich großartig und ich habe es jetzt hier auf diesem Fernseher der hier bei uns hängt,
eigentlich jeden Tag zur angehabt immer so wie immer laufen hat in seinem New Yorker Studio da hatte ich hier immer Hamilton an weil ich dann sozusagen im Rücken wenn ich am Schreibtisch sitze so Hamilton höre und dann auch.
Entsprechend höre wann ich mich umdrehen kann um dann doch mal so eine Szene zu sehen auch weil sie noch einmal sehen will.
Es ist ein wirkliches grandioses Ich hätte gleich auf die Kritiken damals auch gesehen und es war so klar.
Kritik kann man jetzt lesen das Ding bleibt einem verschlossen man wird es niemals sehen so weil man da nicht hin.
Jetzt ist es plötzlich da und alle diffusen Vorstellungen die ich mich erinnern konnte die ich damals so hatte als ich darüber las haben sich erfüllt.
Es ist wirklich ein grandioses müßige dass es da nur farbige Schauspieler gibt habe ich am Anfang komplett ausgeblendet das spielte gar keine Rolle.
Es war ein müßige aus New York Die kann so aussehen.
Es fällt da natürlich ein bisschen auf wenn man dann doch mal den Stoff so ein bisschen rein expliziert in die Gedankenjahr Worum geht's da werden die Personen,
dann hat auch einen gewissen Humor an der Stelle und ich finde es einfach grandios geschrieben und so wenig wie mir die Schauspieler von ihrer ethnischen Herkunft ausfielen war mir auch total egal ob das jetzt Hip-Hop ist oder nicht.
Ich fand es einfach nur eine absolut passende Musik die auch mal so richtig von Anfang bis Ende durchgezogen ist ohne große überraschung also wirklich sehr.
Wie soll man sagen So eine sehr formale Disziplin.
Einfach so was jetzt so geht gar nicht so große Kunst mehr solides Handwerk.
Elektro Schlagzeug halt mit.
Ja aber es ist ja gar nicht nur so Elektro. Man hört ja den Bruch wenn man dann nach zwei Stunden 40 das Orchester die Orchestergraben Musik gehört hat und dann kommt der Abspann mit tatsächlich elektronischem Hip-Hop dann fällt einem plötzlich auf dass sollte Hip-Hop sein.
Nein es.
Nicht.
Man muss bei den modernen Musikproduktionen ist es so dass man die nicht mehr komplett live spielen lässt sondern man hat eben sehr viel vorproduziert was von Band kommt.
Und dann gibt es immer noch eine kleine Band im Graben.
Die spielt dann da drüber um auch dann ein Live Effekt zu haben und selbstverständlich klingt jetzt auch ein Instrument live gespielt anders als einfach nur von Band.
Und es gibt immer so eine hybride Mischung bei Musicals heute was sicherlich auch daran liegt dass es ziemlich teuer ist wenn man mit einem großen Orchester da immer agieren würde.
Ich finde es musikalisch wenig interessant Ich muss auch sagen dass wenig hängen geblieben ist während ich jetzt von vielen amerikanischen Musicals die ich bestimmt acht Jahre nicht mehr gesehen habe sofort was singen könnte aus Hello Dolly oder My Fair Lady.
Und da würde ich sagen ist die amerikanische Kulturindustrie schon einmal auf einer anderen Höhe gewesen.
Ich finde es nicht so erstaunlich was ich wirklich paradox fand war das Lied das mir am besten gefiel war das von dem britischen König denn das ist so eine Elton John Parodie.
Und da hat man auch noch ein Cembalo dabei um zu zeigen dass es die alte Welt war eigentlich ein ganz schöner Gedanke.
Und sonst fand ich diese Rezitative das sind es ja vor allem diese Hip-Hopper Rezitative zum Teil sehr sehr gleichförmig und ich habe das nicht so umgehauen.
Aber ich muss sagen es ist dann doch zu sehen wie gut man mit wenig auskommen kann und wirklich schauspielerische große Momente herstellen kann das schaffen die da schon.
Das schafft nämlich heute kaum ein Disney-Film mehr weil die so fixiert sind dass es alles so mal geglättet dass eigentlich irgendeine Lebendigkeit die noch in älteren Disney-Film zu finden ist heute verloren gegangen ist.
Also eigentlich sollte sich jetzt Disney wenn Sie sich mal ein bisschen erfrischen wollen wenn sie sich mal ein bisschen erneuern wollen an der Bühne wieder mal orientieren.
Die scheint mir fast filmischer zu sein als der Film.
Ja das ist mir auch aufgefallen obwohl visuell so wenig los ist. Es ist so intensiv durch.
Dadurch dass die Kamera noch mal auf der Bühne steht ein Musical muss man unterscheiden hat man es aus der letzten Reihe gesehen oder saß man mal näher. Es macht einen großen Unterschied.
Ich finde aber trotzdem dieser kleine Bogen schlug am Anfang von ZS weit über die Story auf zur Wakefield grandios.
Es ist ein ganz ganz grandioses Ding wo ich noch immer hier die Na+ hin und herspringen so ein bisschen verfluche weil man nicht so schön wie bei das Boot die Playlist einfach zurückspringen kann,
und die Ballade zum Tod von dem von dem Sohn quite abtauen auch wirklich grandios.
Einfach ein grandioses Stück. Und dann das Finale natürlich live Suda des Hotels The Story und da will ich nochmal kurz darauf Wert legen weil jetzt immer alle Hamilton gucken und so auf die Diversität der Schauspieler und so weiter. Man kann auch mal auf die Rolle der Frau achten.
Gerade unter der Maxime dass damals eigentlich die Frauen keine große Rolle spielten aber in dem Musical die dann doch alles dominiert bis zum letzten Paukenschlag sozusagen.
Und dann auch die Funktion der Story.
Die gehen ja als Figuren sehr explizit damit um dass sie gerade Geschichte schreiben und sich überlegen wie das später mal erzählt wird.
Und gleichzeitig hat man die Schauspieler von denen man weiß dass der Malanda das selbst geschrieben hat und so weiter und auch das Ensemble zusammengestellt hat und so implizit haben Sie diesen.
Wir haben ja gerade Spaß an unserem Schauspiel so wie wir die Geschichte erzählen.
Und wie soll man sagen Dieses explizite der Figuren und das implizite der Schauspieler fand ich da ganz ganz grandios.
Das kann aber auch dann wirklich an der Aufnahme liegen die man gerade hat wenn die nur weniger Spaß haben durch Routine oder dem einen geht es nicht so gut an dem Tag hat man schon eine Vorstellung wo das nicht mehr so deutlich wird.
Drei Aufnahmen gemacht sind drei zusammengebastelt aber man kann sagen beim Musical Darstellern.
Man muss sich das auch mal vergegenwärtigen Es ist ganz anders als in der Oper in der Oper hat man zwar auch Stücke die spielt man mal und man hat auch ein entsprechend enges Rollen Fach.
Man singt ja nicht 80 verschiedene Partien. Es gab auch Opernsänger die haben sich nachher auf sieben acht Partien verständigt das konnten sie am allerbesten und dann haben Sie die immer gesungen Elisabeth Schwarzkopf oder hat ein relativ kleines Repertoire.
Aber sie treten immer wieder in anderen Inszenierungen auf und da können Sie natürlich variieren.
Beim Musical ist es so Wenn du da der Star bist wenn du die Elisabeth bist oder wenn du weiß ich nicht wer bist du dann bist du das vielleicht drei vier Jahre lang und das bist du jeden Tag.
Und du spielst exakt dasselbe und das Musical darstellt dass man sich manchmal irgendwelche Marotten noch hinzu angewöhnt dass man versucht irgendwie die Figur noch zu verstärken jetzt auch noch an den Nägeln kauen oder noch da lachen und machen.
Und dann muss man sich eigentlich immer wieder selbst beschneiden. Dass man.
Bei diesem Ausgangspunkt auch bleibt weil man sonst immer diesen Antrieb immer weiter auszugestalten Man merkt dass ein bisschen vielleicht als Vergleich bei Superstars die ihre Hits eigentlich nicht mehr singen wollen und die ihre Hits schon tausendmal gesungen haben.
Die versuchen dann immer neu das irgendwie zu variieren und versuchen irgendwas noch zu verstärken und irgendwann ist es so schrecklich dass man denkt geht doch mal wieder zum Ursprung zurück.
Das wird aber dann auch von solchen Regieassistenten und inspizierten überwacht dass eben das Musical eigentlich jeden Abend gleich stattfindet.
Ja das ist mir dann auch aufgefallen so als letzten Gedanken. Diese Aufnahme von 2016 ist halt irgendwie Hemmerden.
Ich würde mir zum Beispiel keine Karte kaufen um den aktuellen Kurs zu sehen weil ich glaube ich wäre enttäuscht weil das wäre dann ein rausreißen.
Man kennt eigentlich diese Schauspieler mittlerweile und will die dann sehen und dann sieht man nur das Stück und bleibt dann noch leben übrig wenn man nicht die,
persönliche Erwartung an das was man da sieht sieht in der Hinsicht finde ich das einfach beeindruckend und in der Version wie es jetzt bei Disney plus zur Verfügung steht finde ich sollte man sich mal angeschaut haben.
Ich meine das jetzt gerade besagt dass wir das jetzt nicht ansehen würden es vielleicht mit aktuellen schauspielern.
Erinnert mich daran dass Harald Schmidt mal erzählte er bekommt ja dann immer wieder Anfragen ob er nicht im Sommertheater so und so in My Fair Lady mitspielen will und der antwortet dann noch gern ja Guckt euch doch die DVD mit der Verfilmung mit Rex. Doch.
Im Grunde ist ich muss es leider sagen Ja ich bin ja auch so ein bisschen Banause was das angeht.
Das Musical lässt eben nicht so viele Varianten zu.
Man muss dann auch so spielen wie es ist oder man kauft ja dann auch von der Stage,
Stage vertreibt ja ganz viele dieser Musicals und wenn man Andrew Lloyd Webber macht kann man auch nicht einfach machen was man will Das ist selbstverständlich komplett anders wenn ich sage Ich mache eine Verdi-Oper wenn ich sage die singen jetzt alle nackt und außerdem spielt das in Gütersloh. Dann ist das okay.
Apropos Die Wagner-Festspiele haben auch entsprechende Coruna Turbulenzen.
Ja
Zwischendurch aber jetzt haben wir einen Termin für Deutschland.
Zwischendurch keine.
Und es wird Kinogeschichte schreiben weil wir haben das erste Mal einen Termin für einen Hollywood-Film der in Deutschland ins Kino kommt bevor Amerika ins Kino kommt und bevor es überhaupt ein Datum für den amerikanischen Staat gibt.
Geschichte schreiben weil wir das erste Mal,
in Deutschland ins Kino kommen.
Genau das ist schon mal ein Tag vorher war das kann schon mal passieren das liegt an den Tagen an den Filmstadt.
Aber das hat es so noch nicht gegeben. Ich bin sehr gespannt ob das dann noch so stattfinden wird.
Wenn dann sehen wir uns ja und haben ihn schon gesehen. Ich habe ihn dann zumindest schon gesehen. Du wirst ja auch dann ins Kino gehen.
Am 7. August also am 7. August kommt das hier August.
Ja dann werden wir mal gucken.
Dann muss dann natürlich geschaut werden. Ich habe ein witziges Video bei Youtube gefunden weil es mal mitbringt. Ich hab mich wirklich totgelacht.
Ich habe,
ein witziges Video bei Youtube gefunden.
Christopher Nolan erklärt.
Christopher Nolan erklärt das Ende von Tennet oder erklärt Tenet allgemein ist irgendwie so ein bisschen Der Film ist da nicht mal da. Was hat es mit seinem Youtube-Video auf sich.
Das Video und man darf aber jetzt schon sagen wer Angst vor Spoilern hat kann ruhig weiter hören.
Sagen wir mal so Es gibt keine Spur. Es gibt nur eine Pointe Es gibt nur eine vereinter aber die fand ich wirklich grandios.
Wir hören Christopher Nolan auf einer Bühne er wird auf Französisch von irgendeinem Typen irgendwas gefragt das Wir des Französischen nicht mächtig sind.
Zumindest ist für diesen Fall total egal.
Denn die Antwort von Christopher Nolan spricht für sich.
Oh
Ja.
Also einfach rückwärts,
zu diesem Kinostar geschrieben. Auf Twitter Watching Tom Hanks New Juwi Apple,
Watch Decode Netflix Kabel Krad Experience really hard to Image Movie.
Eva Turning tut der Prey covert,
leistet für denjenigen der nicht kennt ist ein großer YouTube Filmemacher sagen wir mal so der sich eine grandiose Karriere aufgebaut hat mit Mini Filmchen beispielsweise täglichen Phlox,
und großer Filmliebhaber wie schon gesagt hat in seinem Studio immer.
Ums Laufen haben und er erwartet jetzt gar nicht mehr das Kino noch im Kinosaal stattfindet sondern er sitzt zu Hause in seinem Ding und guckt da einfach die Filme und ich frage mich auch,
wenn man Tennet jetzt aus irgendwelchen Gründen nochmal verschieben müsste oder James Bond dann im November wenn die Welle sozusagen gerade erwartet wird aus Klima gründen könnte man nicht einfach vermuten dass sich Sony sagt und was zu Hause.
Gut möglich und es zeigt sich ja gerade was wäre Disney jetzt da so war es ja eigentlich geplant hingegangen und hatte gesagt Gut nächstes Jahr veröffentlichen wir dieses Musical dann kann man das im Kino sehen.
Dann hätten das in Deutschland vielleicht optimistisch geschätzt 60 70 000 Leute gesehen. Mehr nicht.
Jetzt kann man davon ausgehen dass man bestimmt schon bei über eine halbe Million oder bei einer Million wahrscheinlich ist die dieses Musical sich angesehen haben via Stream und bei Tennet wäre sicherlich auch das ganz wichtig wenngleich es,
ganz dramatisch für die Kinos ist wenn die,
Studios jetzt immer weiter dazu übergehen dann zu sagen Wir veröffentlichen so bei Disney plus gibts ja auch jetzt den einen oder anderen Film schon zu sehen der eigentlich im Kino starten sollte jetzt hat man auch nochmal einiges verschoben wie Mulan,
und da kann man natürlich auch denken Wie lange werden die das noch verschieben und wann werden Sie das dann in anderer Form anbieten.
Also ich halte das für durchaus denkbar. Für mich ist das noch keine ausgemachte Sache dass wir Ende August diesen Film sehen.
Ich habe zumindest noch keine Einladung für eine Pressevorführung bekommen. Mal sehen. Ja wir sind gespannt.
Wir sind gespannt sind wir ja sowieso. Und notfalls dreimal die Zeit dann hin und her um zu passen. Gut der Juli wie fangen wir an.
Gut der Juli lief.
Ich hatte zum Einstieg zwei kleine Juli Ideen die vorgetragen wurden die man gar nicht groß ausbreiten muss da sie eh nicht kommen aber sie wurden zumindest im Juli mal thematisiert.
Das wär doch ganz schön groß. Muss ich nicht kommen.
Thematisiert hat die Viertagewoche vorgeschlagen mit einer Höchstarbeitszeit von 30-Stunden-Woche denn das macht die Beschäftigten glücklicher gesünder und produktiver alle gesund sein.
Katja Kipping hat die Viertagewoche vorgeschlagen mit einer Höchstarbeitszeit von 30 Stunden die Woche denn das macht die Beschäftigten glücklicher gesünder und produktiver.
Wir wollen ja alle gesund sein. Also eigentlich ein zugkräftiges Argument.
Im ersten Jahr soll der Staat die Unternehmen damit Anschub finanzieren also Aufstocker Aufstocker oder Kurzarbeiter Zuschüsse oder wie auch immer.
Und dieses Jahr soll dann genutzt werden für Tarifverträge oder Betriebsvereinbarungen sodass man dann ein Jahr später 2000 sagen wir 22 eine Viertagewoche in Deutschland hätte fände ich ja grandios. Ehrlich gesagt.
Und man kann hier auch sehen von wem Katja Kipping geprägt ist.
Eine feministische marxistische Theoretiker die sehr viele bedeutende Sachen in den 70er 80er Jahren geschrieben hat.
So ein Modell und dort zeigt sie muss eigentlich bei Arbeitskämpfen um Arbeitszeitverkürzung gehen und,
gleichzeitig muss aber auch die andere Arbeit Erziehungsarbeit über die wir ja jetzt auch mehr geredet haben durch die Krise als Arbeit anerkannt werden und das ist ein Vorschlag der aus dieser Richtung kommt und Kipping,
sehr wie sie immer wieder mal in Interviews betont Ich finde den Vorschlag sehr gut und den könnte man auch viel stärker noch popularisieren und politisieren.
Aber da kommt ja dann leider nicht viel sonst das man sagt dass es sich nochmal Grüne und SPD zusammenschließen können nochmal überlegen denn hier kann man ja auch,
mal ganz zionistisch darüber nachdenken wie es umsetzbar oder auch in einer größeren politischen Dimension.
Was bedeutet das sind wir dann weniger produktiv wäre das gut für den Klimawandel wäre das schlecht aber für spp.
Solche Fragen lassen sich ja daran wunderbar erörtern. Aber ich habe doch eher mitbekommen dass die Diskussion dann sehr schnell einfach so polemisch wurde.
Wir müssen immer mehr arbeiten und sonst versandet das.
Versandete Ja ich finde auch als Diskussionsgrundlage ist es eigentlich grandios gerade für eine neue Zusammenarbeit der Opposition ausgeschlossene AfD.
Weil die sehen ja jetzt Krohne hatten Coruna hat schon so viel Problembewußtsein herbeigeführt dass die Antwortmöglichkeiten die die CDU auf Coruna gab doppelt so viel Wahlstimmen versprach.
Ich finde auch da sollte man als Opposition mal daneben stehen und überlegen Wie könnten wir denn auch was von dem Kuchen abbekommen.
Jetzt so viele nach Antworten auf Conakry suchen warum bieten wir eigentlich keine.
Dann könnte man nämlich wirklich sagen Ja gut die CDU die ist gerade im Amt.
Also ich muss sagen dass akuter und wir denken jetzt mal weiter wenn da so viel Bewegung plötzlich möglich ist dass man dann wirklich zu Ideen kommt grundsätzlich auch mal zu fragen.
Angenommen wir machen das jetzt 30 Stunden die Woche. Welche Einbußen materiell bedeuten das eigentlich.
Und bei wem können wir uns das eigentlich gesellschaftlich gar nicht leisten.
Müllabfuhr z.B. Ja und dann müsste man über diese Berufe auch mal neu nachdenken und fragen und das ist vielleicht auch so eine.
Grundsätzliche Idee dass man sich Erwerbsarbeit nochmal anschaut und nicht so sehr den Lohn Aspekts den Gehalt des Entgeld sondern mehr die Entschädigung in den Mittelpunkt stellt weil wenn man beispielsweise 30 Stunden die Woche ist ein Menschenrecht.
Dann werden ja Entschädigungszahlungen fällig für diejenigen die darüber sind und dann könnte man diskutieren aus welchen Töpfen wird das Bezahlen an wen und was könnte man auch verzichten.
Also wo ist denn eigentlich Entschädigung gar nicht so notwendig weil wir haben ja durchaus jetzt die Erfahrung gemacht dass sehr viele Leute ins Homeoffice gehen,
vermeintlich sind aber nur die gewesen die viel Zeit haben darüber zu jammern weil am Ende waren es irgendwie 17 Prozent der Männer und 23 Prozent der Frauen im Homeoffice gearbeitet haben die anderen 80 Prozent der Gesellschaft mussten natürlich weiter vor Ort arbeiten.
Da kann man ja wirklich mal drüber nachdenken wie man das mal so neu sortiert nicht nur politisch sondern auch so einem gesellschaftlichen Gespräch irgendwie aber.
Katja Kipping Vielleicht auch einfach nicht hat sich nicht genug etabliert für so eine Rolle gebracht.
Wenn wir jetzt Sahra Wagenknecht als Linken-Chefin gehabt hätten wäre das vielleicht anders gekommen.
Zweite Idee die im Juli aufkam ist Marcel Fratzscher als Wiederholungstäter eigentlich schreibt er immer so.
Im November Dezember soll ein Text über ein Erbe für alle das wär doch schön,
dass jeder nach der Berufsausbildung nur mit abgeschlossener Berufsausbildung plötzlich 30 000 Euro bekommt die ihm zur Verfügung gestellt werden als Lebenschance Erbe ausgezahlt vom Staat um so ein bisschen Gleichheit herzustellen.
Und diesmal hat er den Text vorgezogen ganz in den Juli weil irgendwie dachte die Zeit ist reif und bei zeit.de schreibt er dann der wichtigste Grund für die große Ungleichheit in Deutschland sind Erbschaften die Studien macht er ja auch immer alle,
über die Hälfte dieser ererbten Vermögen.
Und dann hat es ja nochmal aufgedröselt 41 Prozent der Erben,
sind Vermögen aus Immobilien und 43 Prozent aus Betriebsvermögen,
das sind einfach das geht nicht auf Lohnarbeit zurück angehäufte Lohnarbeit Entgelte sondern es ist einfach sich selbst vermehrter Mehrwert also marxistisch oder einfach mal,
von jemand anderem erwirtschaftet und dann abgeschöpft aber eben nicht vom Staat sondern privat abgeschöpft und es braucht eine radikale Reform der Erbschaftssteuer schreibt. Und vielleicht ein Erbe für jeden.
Aber das ist auch wieder so eine Idee die man nur einmal im Jahr durchbringen kann. Vielleicht kommt der im November dann turnusgemäß wieder darauf zurück in seiner Zeit Kolumne.
Aber das wäre jetzt auch wieder das Ding für Parteien das man positiv beschreibt Ich komme mit den Erbschaften ist das immer noch in breiten Teilen der Bevölkerung nicht angekommen.
Was eigentlich damit gemeint ist wenn Erbschaftssteuer erhoben werden soll dann wird sofort wenn man dann so Straßenumfrage erlebt habe dass er am Aufwachen Podcast oft genug gehabt von irgendwelchen Leuten das Mikrofon unter die Nase gehalten die sagen,
Ich will ja mein Haus behalten und das sollte mal mein Sohn erben oder so..
Und sie verstehen ja nicht diese eigentlichen Dimensionen die bei Erbschaften anstehen.
Das heißt man müsste erst mal da nochmal ganz anders um diesen Begriff zu verwenden.
Ich glaube aber auch man müsste es mit einer positiven Utopie verknüpfen deswegen sind diese 30.000 Erben,
Erbschaft für jeden eigentlich eine ganz gute Idee um zu zeigen jetzt kann jeder was haben Es geht jetzt nicht darum dass jetzt mal wieder etwas weggenommen wird sondern jeder würde auch davon profitieren.
Man bekommt etwas und man könnte das auch nochmal ökologisch aufladen Es wird ja immer gesagt Na ja ich mache das ja alles Ich hab das hier alles erwirtschaftet.
Für meine Kinder für meine Enkel das ist ja alles gut und schön aber zugleich könnte man ja sagen Ja aber man kann ja mit.
Einer Erbschaftssteuer mit der man etwas einnimmt kann man ja auch sagen Die wird für ökologische Projekte ausgegeben.
Das heißt Das geht an die Kinder an die Enkel da durch diese Welt dann eine gesündere wird eine klimatisch bessere wird.
Und dann kann man diese Argumentation auch mal sehr schön aushebeln dass es vielleicht nicht darum geht dass man 24 Eigentumswohnungen vererbt sondern vielleicht einen Planeten auf dem man leben kann.
Erbe für alle da kommt das Allgemeinwohl Gemeinwohl Erbe aus.
Was auch immer in Deutschland sozusagen von denjenigen die dagegen sind vor allem aus Süddeutschland.
Was auch immer in Deutschland dagegen sind vor allem aus Süddeutschland.
Es gibt ja so einen westdeutschen Streifen von Erbschaften der zieht sich so von Bayern Baden-Württemberg Rheinland-Pfalz aber nur so die westliche Seite im Osten kommt davon gar nichts an.
Es gibt ja so ein westdeutsches Streifen von Erbschaften entzieht sich Bayern Baden-Württemberg Rheinland-Pfalz aber nur die westliche Seite kommt aber gar nicht an bis rauf nach Blankenese.
Und es gibt dann nochmal in NRW ein bisschen Löcher Warum geht's wieder los und da gibts ja so eine Argumentation zu sagen Nee das sind ja alles firmeneigene.
Und wenn man jetzt von der Firma etwas abschneidet dann müsste man ja an die Firma ran und es ging ja dann diesem Unternehmen nicht gut.
Das ist aber eine ganz falsche Argumentation also hört man vor allem von Söder immer wieder weil diese Betriebsvermögen sind ja tatsächlich lebloser Aktienanleihen meistens gerade diese Vermögen ab 20 Millionen die vererbt werden.
Die kommen dann auf 2 Prozent Erbschaftssteuer nominal da drunter dann wirklich im zweistelligen Bereich bezahlt wird also da wo dann wirklich das eigene Haus vererbt wird oder sowas.
Und diese großen Vermögen gehen zurück auf diese Clans und dieser Begriff den hat Julia Friedrichs geprägt für diese Argumentation. Wir Erben dieses Buch.
Da redet man nicht von Familien und die haben so ein paar Anteile sondern da redet man von Clans die,
in Größenordnungen von 800 Unternehmen Beteiligungen halten weil die einfach das Fonds-Manager gegeben haben das dann irgendwie diversifiziert und so weiter und dessen diese Beteiligung an die man eigentlich ran müsste das würde.
Ja und die müssen nicht die Maschinen abbauen wenn da dann genau niemand den Schaden und das liegt auch schon verbrieft vor das Vermögen es müsste man einfach nur einsammeln.
Genau das würde genau niemandem schaden und das liegt auch schon verbrieft vor das Vermögen es müsste man einfach nur einsammeln.
Ja da kann man ob ich nochmal dieses marxistische Argument machen zu sagen Hier wurde ein Mehrwert erarbeitet der nie materielle Ausprägung hat.
Und da kann man glaube ich wirklich nochmal dieses marxistische Argument machen zu sagen Hier wurde ein Mehrwert erarbeitet der nie materielle Ausprägungen hatte.
Man besitzt ja nicht den Parkplatz eines Unternehmens oder sowas sondern es ist verbrieftes Vermögen das man einfach wie Geld aufteilen und abgeben kann.
Da müsste man eigentlich ran. Also so wie es eine kleine Erbschaftssteuer unter 400000 Euro gibt so ein Freibetrag müsste man auch ab und das gibts nur in Amerika ab 20 Millionen einfach.
Da müsste man eigentlich sowieso keine Erbschaftssteuer unter 400 000 Euro gibt also ein Freibetrag müsste man auch ab Amerika ab 20 Millionen grundsätzlich 90 Prozent versteuern.
Grundsätzlich mit 90 Prozent versteuern oder sowas gibts überhaupt gar kein Argument dagegen.
Wenn dagegen 835 Millionen Euro.
Warum wird jemand 835 Millionen Euro erben muss mit 18 Jahren das ist einfach völlig Banane.
Es würde im übrigen auch der Wirtschaft guttun wenn man mal ganz wirtschaftlich volkswirtschaftlich denkt.
Wenn Leute wissen dass sie das Geld besser auch mal ausgeben statt es nur aufzuhelfen um damit macht aufzuhelfen kann das auch nicht schaden.
In Deutschland führt es dann zu diesen komischen ulkigen Momenten dass der Bundestag darüber debattiert wie viel Kurzarbeitergeld bezahlt man BMW und am selben Tag dieser Entscheidung werden 768 Millionen an eine einzelne Person ausgezahlt als Dividenden.
In Deutschland wird es komisch dass der Bundestag darüber debattiert Kurzarbeitergeld bezahlt.
BMW am selben Tag diese Entscheidung 60 Millionen an eine einzelne Person ausgezahlt.
Das ist ein Durchlauferhitzer von Geld den braucht niemand das ist einfach komplett asozial zu hundert Prozent senken sollte man da mal ran.
Das ist ein Durchlauferhitzer. Das ist einfach komplett Assoziationen Prozent sinken sollte man mal aber gut Masse Francia redet sich den Mund fusselig und mal gucken.
Aber gut Marcel Fratzscher redet sich den Mund fusselig und mal gucken.
Irgendwann muss ja so ein Knoten dann auch mal platzen.
Irgendwann muss ja nur Klotener.
Dann nochmal ein Thema ein.
Führungstor.
In ein Thema und zwar kommt jetzt ein großes Thema aber ich finde wir müssen als Podcast der jetzt zehn Jahre in den Blick nehmen will darüber sprechen und zwar um Krieg und Frieden.
Und dabei geht es selbstverständlich darum Wie ist es denn mit dem Verhältnis zwischen USA und China.
Welche Rolle spielt Europa eigentlich dabei aber was passiert so auch an der Peripherie.
Das soll jetzt erst mal so ein erster Aufschlag sein und wir fangen jetzt mal,
ganz simpel an mit einem kurzen Ausschnitt aus dem heute journal einen Bericht über,
China und USA und kommt auch ganz kurz noch Sebastian Heilmann zu Wort den hatten wir schon mal im Salon einen Politikwissenschaftler aus Trier und China-Experte einfach mal so rein.
Was da gerade passiert das vom 15.
Präsident schee hat eine historische Botschaft an die Welt er wolle Chinas Größe zurückerobern.
China ist anders als seine Vorgänger. Er will Weltmacht sein.
Grundsätzlich ist klar dass in Peking wirklich diesen Platz an der Sonne für die kommende Supermacht China wirklich vorbereiten will.
Er glaubt dass der Westen China ausgenutzt habe.
Hier herrscht uneingeschränkt seinem Kommando folgen die Massen. Er ist ein Vollstrecker.
Hongkong war erst der Anfang. Er wird die Macht weiter ausbauen.
Chinas Militärflugzeuge drängen immer häufiger in Taiwans Luftraum ein SCI provoziert weil er glaubt niemand wagt ihn zu stoppen.
Wenn du stark genug wirst bestimmt du die Regeln. Niemand kritisiert dich daran glaubt China.
China rüstet auf. Es glaubt an das Argument der Waffen der Militärhaushalt steigt um knapp sieben Prozent. Trotz Wirtschaftskrise.
Chinas Militär soll stark genug sein um die USA vor einer Intervention in der Region abzuschrecken.
China hält den Westen für schwach. Trumps Unberechenbarkeit hilft. Der US-Präsident spaltet das westliche Bündnis.
Die Kanzlerin dazwischen die deutsche Wirtschaft abhängig vom chinesischen Markt rechnet deshalb nicht mit massiven Widerstand.
Da ist jetzt sehr viel drin aber eigentlich können wir es gar nicht so richtig sortieren was die da eigentlich sagen.
Das liegt vielleicht schon einmal zunächst daran dass immer von präsent gesprochen wird.
Es gab einen Vortrag von Mareike Kohlberg die hat zusammen mit.
Hat sie ein Buch geschrieben über die stille Invasion wie China sich immer weiter ausbreitet.
Die lautlose Eroberung so heißt das Buch und sie hat einen Vortrag gehalten unter anderem. Sie hat mehrere gehalten.
Aber sie hat bei der VHS Bamberg und das wurde ja alles schön gestreamt.
Da konnte man das nachvollziehen wie sie erst mal darauf hin dass in der,
Berichterstattung in Deutschland das üblich dass man immer vom Präsidenten spricht und dann sagt sie Das sei aber eigentlich nicht so erheblich dass der Präsident sie ist sondern er ist der Vorsitzende der Kommunistischen Partei und wir haben auch keine Armee,
des Staates sondern wir haben eine Armee der Partei und wir haben auch Medien der Partei.
Sie sagten Wir können China nur verstehen wenn wir aus diesem Gedanken heraus das Ganze erklären und nicht so tun als sei das die Kanzlerin Merkel Präsident.
Ja genau. Wir haben sowieso in den Medien das war übrigens Ulf Röller dem wir gerade gehört haben der auch der Meinung ist dass das Hochwasser in Wuhan weiter bis nach Japan fließt hat er sich sehr lächerlich gemacht jetzt und,
diese ganze mediale Herangehensweise an Länder die man nicht so mag die werden immer zusammengeschnürt auf den Staatschef Putin hat Erdoğan und natürlich Tee.
Während in Amerika ist es irgendwie Amerika und so ist es aber in Kanada so wie da Kanada und nicht alles Trudeau.
Diese Zuordnung die ist immer lustig.
Wir waren ja zusammen bei diesem Vortrag von Kai Strittmatter über China und er hat es ja auch nochmal in seinem Buch kommt es ja auch ganz deutlich als meinungsstark Bewertungs Urteils hafte Abhandlung dieses Gefüge in China.
Man hat die Kommunistische Partei die sich immer mal wieder bedroht sieht in ihrem Führungsanspruch aber die alles sich unterordnet und,
die nicht nur glaubt oder das es formal so dass die Armee der Partei gehört sondern auch das ganze Land so und dann hat man,
dieses Bild einer.
Parent These heißt es einer historischen Lücke 18 des 19.
Jahrhundert. Eigentlich ist man als Chinese oder als China der Herrscher der Welt nur jetzt gerade kapselt eine dreieinhalbjährige Delle die uns die wir uns irgendwie so Hamilton angucken.
Für uns sind diese 300 Jahre alles so einfach alles auch im eurozentrischen in China ist es ja ganz anders.
In China haben wir ja ein Archiv Wesen mit dem die ohne Probleme 800 1500 2000 Jahre zurückgehen um nochmal in einzelnen Dörfern anzuschauen wem gehörte denn welche Bäckerei und so.
Das kann man sich hier gar nicht vorstellen in Deutschland wie das dazu geht es hat sowieso ein anderes Bild drauf haben.
Also es gibt sozusagen historisch und also zeitlich und sachlich ein völlig anderes Bild von China in der Selbstbeschreibung als wenn wir das von hier aus immer so beobachten.
Deswegen sind solche journalistischen Stücke die das dann so auf THI Zusammenschnitt erzählen irgendwie schon immer auch ein bisschen heimlichen Humor in sich tragen.
In der Tat.
Wenn man so große Probleme und plötzlich behandelt.
Was ist eigentlich mit Deutschland.
Es gibt das ganz große Problem dass China eine extreme macht als soft power ausübt z.B.
China Institute durch dann aber auch verschiedene wirtschaftliche Verzweigungen oder dass man Konferenzen hat und wie geht man eigentlich so damit um wenn von China aus ein gewisser Druck ausgeübt wird z.B.
Auf ein einzelnes Land und da sagt Mareike Kolberg wie eigentlich Europa da vorzugehen hätte.
Heißt auf allen Ebenen in China Kompetenz investieren in Studiengängen wo man Konfuzius Institute ersetzt durch von Deutschland finanzierte Programme.
Das heißt man kann nicht einfach sagen Wir machen alle Konfuzius Institute zu. Man muss dann schon eine Alternative bieten das muss man aber letztlich langfristig tun weil es wichtig ist dass unsere China Kompetenz tatsächlich unabhängig finanziert ist.
Man sollte man muss Verhaltenskodex.
Das hatte ich schon angesprochen für den Umgang mit offiziellen chinesischen Partnern entwickeln heißt unsere roten Linien wie weit gehen wir nicht weiter.
Das heißt auch Man muss festlegen. Wir brauchen insgesamt mehr Solidarität weil letztlich einzelne Parteien einzelne Gruppen einzelner Länder gegeneinander ausspielen.
Und wenn man zum Beispiel in Europa sieht dass die chinesische Regierung stark gegen Schweden wettert und gegen Schweden vorgeht dann ist die Reaktion nicht erst einmal Oh das könnten als nächstes wir sein sondern die zu erst einmal.
Zum Glück sind wir das nicht Wir machen bestimmt nicht den Fehler das wird uns nicht passieren.
Aber dass man da sich klar zum Beispiel dem Fall mit Schweden solidarisiert und sagt neben einem europäischen Land anlegt euch mit allen an,
dieses Umdenken muss passieren und das auf allen Ebenen auf Länderebene aber auch bei Universitäten einzelne Forscher ausgeschlossen werden.
Eine Delegation nach China fährt eine Person. Ausgeschlossen sagt die Delegation dann fahren wir halt nicht.
Und dann ist es häufig nicht immer so aber manchmal so dass die ganze Delegation am Ende doch rein darf.
Aber diese Solidarität muss erst mal das Bewusstsein dafür geschaffen werden.
Ein kluger Ansatz. Das ist etwas was sich in den Geisteswissenschaften schon sehr stark beobachtet habe. Aus China kam hat man sich da doch gerne auch mal ein Auge zugedrückt.
Hauptsache es fließen auch Gelder und Kooperation wenngleich man sagen muss dass es.
Konfuzius Institute die Goethe-Institute haben ja auch ein bisschen mehr als,
Schriftsteller über Wasser zu halten. Man kann sagen diese soft power gibt es selbstverständlich von allen großen Ländern aus das haben wir ja in den USA auch. Da muss man dann eben auch aufpassen welche Doppelstandards man da sieht.
Nochmal zu dem was sie ansprach. Diese Sensibilität für A zum Glück trifft jetzt erst mal Schweden der Zorn von China und nicht uns.
Rudolf Stichwaffe ist eigentlich so ein Soziologe so Luhmann Schüler durch und durch völlig aufgefallen.
Was ich der Soziologie der Universität und der Profession immer so ganz theoretisch und,
eurozentrischen und er hat irgendwann so ein Wandel mitgemacht wo er plötzlich ganz häufig über China sprach und auch die formale normativ freie Strenge von Sona Luhmann Theorie verließ um dann doch noch einmal die Demokratie auch,
als eigenen Wert in seinen soziologischen Diskurs einzubringen.
Und da habe ich mich immer gewundert wie das kam und irgendwann hat es dann mal,
sozusagen mehr politisiert in seiner Soziologie und meinte dann das Problem mit China ist tatsächlich dieses rein schleichen,
das man in seinem Hörsaal mit 300 Leuten die sich irgendwie Erstsemester Soziologie irgendwas Veranstaltung anhören,
dass da plötzlich so Drei Chinesen auftauchen als Studenten was ja sehr wünschenswert ist und so weiter,
und dass man dann aber schon feststellt dass die Angst davor haben sich in den deutschen Hörsaal zu äußern weil sie nicht genau wissen was davon nach China zurückgemeldet wird und an wen und,
welche Fragen da an die Familie gestellt werden.
Menschen die aus China in jungen Jahren kommen so als Austauschstudenten sind nicht irgendwie wie aus Amerika das sie hier erst mal Halligalli machen und Party und so.
Sondern Da gibts dieses autokratische Moment wirkt sich da mittlerweile wirklich bis in jede einzelne Biografie aus.
Selbst bei jungen Studenten kann man nicht mehr sicher sein.
Erstens ist bedroht gerade wenn er in meiner Sprechstunde sitzt als Professor oder ist er vielleicht sogar einer der von einer Partei entsandt wurde um mal zu gucken,
was an der Uni Zürich oder wo auch immer Luzern so vor sich geht mit denen Chinesen die da sind.
Das ist wie soll man sagen Da fehlt tatsächlich so eine Sensibilität für ein ganz grundsätzliches Problem einfach so wie sie es hier beschreibt,
nicht nur auf der politischen Ebene sondern im Grunde bei jedem Einzelnen was weiss ich Mechatronik Professor ja auch seine chinesische Studenten hat.
Da müsste man eigentlich so langsam auch mal Fortbildungen für die Lehrkräfte machen.
Genau das bislang noch nicht. Aber es gibt eben jetzt vermehrt dieses Bewusstsein dafür.
Man kann es auch erleben in einem Vortrag den die FDP Stiftung die Friedrich-Naumann-Stiftung der FDP na.
Der Vortrag ist ganz interessant weil er eine Position einbringt die ich dann später konterkarieren will spricht der Politikwissenschaftler Stefan Kießling der sagt,
wir jetzt alle so stark Angst haben was jetzt in den letzten Monaten Jahren debattiert wird. Thukydides falle.
Es gab eine Schule der liberal der Institutionen listen die sagten Das ist doch fantastisch für den Planeten.
Durch den Eintritt Chinas in die Weltwirtschaft werden wir alle reicher die Interdependenzen die gegenseitigen wechselseitigen Abhängigkeiten wachsen.
Und China wird davon profitieren aber damit auch sehen dass sie im Grunde ein Anteilseigner dieses Systems dieser liberalen westlichen Regel basierten Ordnung bleiben werden.
Warum diese Ordnung hat Sie reich gemacht die Chinesen.
Diese Ordnung hat ihnen ermöglicht im späten 20. frühen 21. Jahrhundert aufzusteigen.
Diese sehr optimistische Sichtweise wurde vertreten natürlich von der Exportwirtschaft die sich erwartete den chinesischen Markt zu erobern.
Aber auch alle westlichen Regierungen fast jeder Couleur haben sich in den Neunziger und in den Nullerjahren und auch darüber hinaus noch voll hinter diese Sichtweise Chinas gestellt.
Aber es gab auch immer eine zweite Schule die realistische Schule.
Und die sagte Ja China wird zu lange in diesem System das vom Westen mehr oder weniger etabliert worden ist dem System der ja des Freihandels der.
Währungsstabilität und so weiter bleiben wie es Vorteile hat.
Sobald China stark genug ist die riegelt zu verändern und selbst Regeln setzen zu können wird China aus diesem System ausbrechen und machtpolitisch expansiv agieren.
Das war z.B. die Sichtweise des US-Militärs.
Das ist dann auch der Kern der Thukydides fãlle die Thukydides falle besagt dass eine aufsteigende Macht in dem Fall und es geht jetzt zurück aufs fünfte Jahrhundert vor Christus Sparta,
den traditionellen machtpolitischen Hegemon in Athen herausfordert.
Und das wird zu Konflikt und Krieg führen.
Das ist die große Frage Erleben wir möglicherweise in den nächsten zehn 15 Jahren den großen Krieg zwischen China und USA.
Schnappt diese Falle zu. Oder wird es so sein wie im Kalten Krieg.
Diese Rivalität hat sich dann auf andere Weise gelöst.
Wandel durch Annäherung dieses erste Modell wird es nicht sein.
Wandel durch Annäherung. Dieses erste Modell wird es nicht sein. Nein.
Die Frage ist natürlich auch deswegen ist diese Novemberwoche entscheidend.
Die Frage ist natürlich auch möglich. Deswegen ist diese nun bereit zu entscheiden.
Kriegt Amerika noch einmal die Chance sich vier Jahre mit einem völlig Kopf abgeschlagen Amerika herumzuschlagen.
Kriegt Amerika noch einmal die Chance sich vier Jahre mit einem völlig Kopf abgeschlagen Amerika zu schlagen.
Und im Grunde reden wir über Hongkong Ja ja tatsächlich schon.
Und im Grunde. Wir reden hier über Hongkong hat man ja tatsächlich schon im Moment erlebt da wo man nicht mal gegen Russland wusste was sollte man jetzt eigentlich machen.
Im Moment da wo man nicht mal gegen Russland wusste was soll man jetzt eigentlich machen. Diese besetzen ist Nebensache.
Diese besetzen jetzt eine Insel und dann steht man daneben kommentiert das und fühlt sich aber nicht in der Lage sozusagen auf gleicher Ebene nämlich auch militärisch irgendwie dagegen vorzugehen.
Ohnehin steht man daneben kommentiert das und fühlt sich aber nicht in der Lage sozusagen auf gleicher Ebene nämlich auch militärisch dagegen vorzugehen.
Und warum nicht wenn er das so als Aussicht stellt.
Warum nicht. Wenn er das so als Aussicht stellt.
Die Vorgänge im Südchinesischen Meer das ja nun Südchinesische Meer ist ja schon eine politische Aussage.
Der Name des taiwanesischen Gewässer.
Werden übrigens auch dann Forschung nicht gefördert in Deutschland die in Kooperation mit China stattfinden wenn in den entsprechenden Anträgen nicht auch solche Formulierungen drin stehen die man gerne sieht.
Der kommunistischen Partei Du hast jetzt gerade schon die Präsidentschaftswahl angesprochen kommt ganz kurz auf Joe Biden zu sprechen zu sprechen Stefan wir hier nochmal rein.
Thukydides war sozusagen der erste der über diese machtpolitische Konstellation diese Rivalität geschrieben hat.
Und deshalb ist diese Falles sozusagen mit seinem Namen versehen worden.
Und diese Falle wurde zu einem Forschungsprogramm ganz moderner internationaler Politik Graham Ellison College der Harvard University,
hat eine große Studie mit vielen Co-Autoren angefertigt indem er die Frage stellt und sie sehen siehe oben kurz eingeblendet,
Marica Escape.
Thukydides und er sagt Nein.
Es wird also zu einer Konflikt kräftigen vielleicht sogar militärischen kriegerischen Auseinandersetzung kommen und hier sehen Sie dass Joe Biden sogar,
der nächste Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten hier ein paar Sätze dazu geschrieben hat um dieses Buch zu empfehlen.
Optimistisch. Naja welche beiden gewinnt.
Naja wenn Joe Biden gewinnt dann wissen wir ist der komplette Apparat der die letzten 20 Jahre die China-Politik Amerikas gemacht hat wieder installiert.
Dann wissen wir ist der komplette Apparat der die letzten 20 Jahre die China-Politik Amerikas gemacht hat wieder installiert. Von heute auf morgen.
Von heute auf morgen und dann wird's dann sind es einfach andere Szenarien die da plötzlich aufgebaut wenn man die Frage Wenn die zum Krieg führen.
Und dann wird es mir einfach andere Szenarien wie der plötzlich aufgequollen sondern auch die Frage Wenn die zum Krieg führen so empfindet es ein richtiger Vernichtungskrieg von denen viele Angst haben.
Ist ein richtiger Vernichtungskrieg von dem viele Angst haben. Der scheint ja ein bisschen ausgeschlossen weil Selbstzerstörung nun erkennbar.
Der scheint ja ein bisschen ausgeschlossen weil Selbstzerstörung nun erkennbar.
Beide Lãnder sind nicht auf Rache aus das sind jetzt keine Rache Kulturen wie die islamischen. Wenn man die Türkei sich anschaut wie Erdogan da handelte das würde ich so ein bisschen ausschließen allerdings muss man sich wirklich fragen wieso ein künftiger Krieg aussehen kann.
Beide Lãnder sind nicht auf Rache aus das Netz keine So erdachte Kulturen wie die islamischen.
Wenn man die Türkei sich anschaut wie Erdogan der handelte das würde ich so ein bisschen ausschließen allerdings muss man sich wirklich fragen wieso ein künftiger Krieg aussehen kann.
Es gibt ja auch wieder territoriale Streitigkeiten zwischen China und Indien.
Hat mir in diesem Monat genau diesen Monat eine Schlägerei mit Hacke und Beil sind in der Tragfläche aufeinander.
Genau da gab es diesen Monat eine Schlägerei. Richtig. Also die sind so ganz archaisch.
Ganz ehrlich Ich gebe keine Videos. Man kann es nur aus Erzählungen.
Es gibt keine Videos Man kann es nur aus Erzählungen. Aber es gab 20 Tote und das muss man sich mal vorstellen dass sich diese Länder darauf einigen erklärt wird damit es nicht eskaliert greifen wir nicht zu Waffen.
Aber es gab 20 Tote. Ja das muss man sich mal vorstellen dass sich diese Länder darauf einigen Bakelit nur damit es nicht eskaliert greifen wir nicht zu Waffen Wir schießen hier nicht an. Wir fordern auch keine Luftunterstützung sondern wir gehen jetzt einfach aufeinander zu und schlagen uns die Köpfe ein.
Also Wir schießen hier nicht und wir fordern auch keine Luftunterstützung sondern wir gehen jetzt einfach aufeinander zu und schlagen uns die Köpfe ein.
Und das haben die Soldaten mitgemacht wohl wissend wie das eigentlich ist und es gab tatsächlich 20 21 Tote dabei.
Das haben die Soldaten mitgemacht wohl wissen wie irre das eigentlich ist und es gab tatsächlich 20 oder 21 Tote da war ja wirklich,
keine Ahnung wie die Wissenschaft heißt die sich mit sowas befasst was daraus erwachsen kann.
Keine Ahnung,
was daraus erwachsen ist.
Aber da ist ganz schön was los. Ehrlich gesagt bei der Frage Krieg und Frieden.
Wir nochmal weiter Berling was er zu sagen hat über diese Konstellation da mehr.
Natürlich können Sie argumentieren der amerikanische Anteil an den Rüstungsausgaben weltweit ist noch größer.
Aber Amerika ist natürlich eine Weltmacht. Die haben auch Rüstungs Interessen und Verteidigungs Interessen in Europa gegenüber Russland.
Sie haben Verteidigungs Interessen zu Hause im Mittleren Osten während die chinesischen Ausgaben wirklich auf die Peripherie konzentriert sind auf das nahe Umfeld und dort können sie den Amerikanern mittlerweile schon Paroli bieten.
Hier sehen Sie diese berühmte Nein.
Nein. Vielleicht haben Sie mal davon gehört die neuen Bindestrich Linie. Warum.
China hat vor mittlerweile 15 Jahren auf seinen Karten zu zeichnen begonnen.
Diese neuen Paschas auf Englisch oder Bindestriche die den Anspruch Chinas auf die Südchinesische See zementieren sollen.
Sie sehen schon auf den ersten Blick ist diese Nein.
Unglaublich expansiv. Die geht sehr nahe an die Küste von Vietnam. Die geht sehr nahe an die Küste von Malaysia und Brunei Iran.
Die trifft hier fast auf die Philippinen mehrmals mehrfach.
Und China beansprucht alles hier innerhalb dieser Nein. Bächlein als ausschließliche Hools Zone das heißt alle Inseln erklärt es zu seinem Eigentum.
Alle Fischfang Rechte erklärt es zu seinem exklusiven Eigentum.
Und alle im Grunde Mineral Vorkommen in der Südchinesischen See erklärt China zu seinem Eigentum.
Die Philippinen haben dagegen geklagt vor dem Internationalen Gerichtshof haben die Klage gewonnen.
China hat das Urteil abgelehnt und fährt damit fort Rüstung zu verlegen.
Auf diese Inseln manche dieser Atolle wirklich zu Startrampe und Landebahnen auszubauen und zu planieren für seine Flugzeuge Militär dort zu stationieren.
Die einzige Macht die versucht China hier entgegenzutreten sind die Vereinigten Staaten die nach dem Prinzip der Offenheit der Seewege immer stärker versuchen hier Kontroll und patroullieren Fahrten zu machen.
Also hier sehen Sie schon den ersten Fall wo diese Thukydides Falle wirklich zu massiven direkten Rivalitäten zwischen diesen beiden Nationen führt.
Offenheit der Seewege das wir uns jetzt mal in Erinnerung weil das ein bisschen so geschildert wird dass die USA einfach so ein bisschen was tun damit der Welthandel jetzt nicht unter die Räder gerät.
Das hat selbstverständlich auch eine geopolitische überlegungen das Ganze da kommen wir aber gleich.
Übrigens kennen wir das auch hier vor der Haustür. Auch jetzt im Juli gehabt mit Zypern.
Stimmt.
Dass sich tatsächlich Griechenland und die Türkei die beide irgendwie Anspruch wo die Frage ist Ist Zypern so nah an der türkischen Küste dass der Boden dort zum türkischen Platow gehört.
Oder hat nicht eine Insel auch ein unter Wasser Theiler.
Da muss ja dann irgendwie Merkel kurz anrufen damit sich die Sache wieder beruhigen.
Keineswegs.
Man kriegt das ist irgendwie Geschichte von gestern aber nee das ist alles ganz schön nah.
Er weist auch darauf hin dass der Etat der USA wesentlich höher ist als der Chinas aber es sind zwei sehr verschiedene Strategien.
Die USA sagt Ja die sind Weltmacht China will ja auch Weltmacht werden und man kann ja auch einfach mal ganz neutral geopolitisch sagen Ja können Sie ja auch machen. Sie können das ja auch versuchen.
So funktionieren diese Konflikte in der Regel das ist ja nicht mit Moral oder so. begründbar.
Die USA sind ja auch nicht deshalb Weltmacht weil sie immer so freundlich auftreten.
Es gibt aber zwei Strategien. USA setzt auf sehr sehr viele Stützpunkte innerhalb der Welt und China sagt jetzt erst mal wir sind ja schon ein riesengroßes Land wir wollen aber jetzt über die Handelswege das Ganze erreichen und da,
wir jetzt unser militärisches Aufgebot und versuchen dann eben mit diesen Scharmützeln auch ganz klar unsere Macht zu demonstrieren.
Kommen wir da überhaupt raus.
Jetzt eine Antwort die uns sicherlich überraschen wird. Vielleicht auch nicht.
Und dann sehen wir uns noch mal eine ganz andere Perspektive an.
Das muss man glaub ich kaum dazusagen ist eine sehr transatlantische Sichtweise auf diesen Konflikt.
Wenn es nicht einen Faktor gebe dem wir nicht besonders mögen wollen den wir nicht besonders lieben zu lieben haben,
der aber garantiert hat dass auch andere Supermacht Konflikte nicht wirklich eskaliert sind nämlich die Nuklearwaffen.
Frieden auf der heutigen Welt wird auch durch Nuklearwaffen sichergestellt und mit den USA und mit China haben sich zwei Nationen hochgerüstet mit Nuklearwaffen mit gesicherter,
Schlags Fähigkeit mit Interkontinentalraketen mit auf U-Booten stationierten Raketen die sich gegenüberstehen,
und im letzten kann man sagen was die Situation dieser Thukydides fãlle,
von früheren Thukydides fallen unterscheidet ist das in diesem Fall bei einem militärischen Konflikt beide Seiten schwerste Schäden wenn nicht völlige Vernichtung wirklich gewärtig sein müssten.
Und das ist sozusagen die letzte Hoffnung die wir haben. Die größte Hoffnung die wir haben dass diese Thukydides fãlle nicht zu einem militärischen Konflikt ausarten wird.
So eine paradoxe Sache.
Ja so viel aufrüsten dass es zu gefährlich wird überhaupt noch was zu machen und dann können wir uns so zähmen.
Man verweist auf den Kalten Krieg wo das so funktioniert hat. Allerdings muss man sagen es hat auch durch glückliche Zufälle funktioniert.
Wenn man dann nochmal so ein bisschen die Historie geht die die Hamburger Edition hat ja fünf Bände,
zum Kalten Krieg herausgegeben mit wirklich großartigen Experten Aufsätzen da kann man dann nachvollziehen ja es war da doch oft sehr sehr brenzlig und es waren dann doch auch zwischenmenschliche.
Atomexperten aufsetzen. Da kann man dann aber doch,
noch das Zwischenmenschliche menschliche Entscheidungen die dazu geführt haben dass es dann wirklich geknallt ist das wirkliche Spiel mit dem Feuer.
Menschliche Entscheidungen die dazu geführt haben dass es dann nicht wirklich geknallt hat.
Insofern ist das ein wirkliches Spiel mit dem Feuer.
Also da kommen ja ganz viele Dimensions rein.
Da kommen ja ganz viele Dimensionen ein Gleichgewicht des Schreckens da ist ja der Schrecken erst mal auch die Dimension des Schadens im Schadensfall ausgerichtet.
Gleichgewicht des Schreckens. Da ist ja der Begriff schrecken wirklich erst mal auf die Dimension des Schadens im Schadensfall ausgerichtet dann gibt es diese technische Dimension.
Dann gibt's natürlich diese technische Dimension.
Man weiß gar nicht wo die alle installiert sind und dann fallen sie noch unter Wasser und fliegen in der Luft.
Man weiß gar nicht wo die alle installiert sind und was sie noch unter Wasser und liegen.
Und dann gibt es noch diese soziale dass man nicht genau weiß wie weit es in einer anderen reinzugehen bis hin zu diesen Automatismen die man dann einbaute.
Und dann gibt es noch diese soziale dass man nicht genau weiß wie weit ist denn eine andere bereit zu gehen bis hin zu diesen Automatismen die man dann einbaute im Sinne von.
Das geht dann automatisch los. Die Technik ist schon eingestellt. Doch das ist gar nicht seltsam.
Das geht dann automatisch los. Die Technik ist schon eingestellt da entscheiden wir gar nicht mehr drüber.
Der Film kam ja auch nicht. Ein Ehrenpräsidenten vorzustellen ist ja so ein Trump bei dem man nicht genau weiß wann es seine rote Linie eigentlich überschritten.
Wir sehen ihn ja in Amerika selbst völlig über die Stränge schlagen. Wann macht er das auch außenpolitisch.
Wobei außenpolitisch mit dem Militär ja doch immer noch mal so eine Vernunft institutions Schranke eingebaut ist. Mein Eindruck zumindest.
Auch wenn jetzt in Afghanistan alles völlig aus dem Ruder läuft was das gerade angeht.
Aber dieses Argument grundsätzlich zu sagen Atomwaffen machen die Welt ein bisschen sicherer.
Wir haben keine Vergleichswerte ohne Atomwaffen und es ist eine ganz schwierige Argumentation das zu machen aber sie ist auch nicht von der Hand zu weisen.
Irgendwie so ganz schwierig.
Zugleich haben wir ja auch Debatten darüber ob man abrüsten kann ob man eben nicht mehr amerikanische Atomwaffen auf deutschem Boden haben möchte.
Da gibt's auch Ausgearbeitete Ideen wie man so machen kann wie man auch den Konflikt mit Russland minimieren kann bzw. wie man Russland auch wenn man das machen würde für Deutschland.
Wenn man sagt wir wollen hier keine Atomwaffen haben das auch quasi als Signalwirkung an Russland spielen kann und die damit unter Druck setzen dann müsst ihr jetzt aber auch mal abrüsten.
Da gab es einen Vorschlag in der internationalen Politik in der Juli August-Ausgabe Wir haben viel über Handelskrieg gesprochen schon im vergangenen Jahr.
Ja das ist ja eine ganz entscheidende Diskussion einen Handelskrieg es in Russland Amerika damals nicht Handel oder Handelskrieg.
Und man muss sich eben,
genau das muss man sich einfach mal vergegenwärtigen was das eigentlich für Zahlen sind Mikrochips wie wichtig die,
sind für die Welt von Sophie Charlotte Fischer einen Aufsatz dazu in internationale Politik und da sagt sie dann einfach das Ships,
China gibt für den Import von Mikrochips mehr Geld aus als für den Import von Erdöl.
Deshalb sind sie extrem abhängig davon dass sie an diese Chips rankommen weshalb das wirklich für China ein extremes Problem ist wenn Donald Trump dort immer wieder neue,
Zölle einführt sondern eben Barrieren baut die die Grenzen zwischen Lieferanten die mit diesen Chips zusammenhängen sich verpflichten sollen dies und das nicht an China zu liefern.
Und damit wird ein enormer Druck ausgeübt denn China ist einfach das große Problem so steht es zumindest in diesem Text hängt mit der Produktion noch mit der Qualität der Chips etwa so zwei drei Generationen zurück,
müssen das jetzt irgendwie versuchen aufzuholen.
Aber ganz ganz schlecht gemanagt Man muss auch bei der Produktion zwischen drei Dingen unterscheiden habe ich auch gelernt schreibt sie einmal das Design dann Fertigung sowie das zusammensetzen.
Und dann gibt es nochmal das Testen und verpacken.
Und oftmals ist das voneinander getrennt oder wenn es zusammen stattfindet wie bei Intel oder Samsung dann heißt das nicht dass das an einem Ort stattfindet sondern das kann dann in verschiedenen Ländern sein.
Und das wird auch sehr entscheidend sein wie sich China auf dem Weltmarkt behaupten kann wenn sie das schaffen wirklich sich da Autonomie zu verschaffen in der Produktion.
Dann kann das gelingen aber da hängen sie irgendwie. Sie haben das offenbar lange schleifen lassen und jetzt sind Sie gerade in einer heiklen Situation.
Genau die haben mir dieses grundsätzliche große politische Ziel irgendwie diese zwei Schlüsseltechnologien auf sich zu vereinen in den nächsten zehn Jahren bei dieser Chip Produktion.
Das hat mir Frank Rieger erklärt wie das funktioniert weil das Chip.de sein kann man entwerfen. Ja das kann man einfach modellieren.
Der Prototyp ist wie beim Auto schnell hergestellt Die Frage ist aber wie kriegt man 100 Millionen Chips raus.
Man kann ja nicht an jedem so mit der Hand schnitzen bis er dann irgendwie Hinault sondern man will ja 100 Millionen Handys herstellen.
Und man baut dann eine Fabrik als Test Fabrik.
Und da liegen dann irgendwo die Wasserrohre drinnen und die Zuleitung der Stoffe und die Temperatur hat keine Ahnung.
Und am Ende hat man so eine Serienfertigung die in dieser Fabrik gut funktioniert,
und dann versucht man gar nicht mehr zu ergründen warum das jetzt funktioniert hat sondern man versucht diese Fabrik zu duplizieren mit jeder Neigung im Wasserrohr für die Zulieferungen von irgendwelchen und dann,
nimmt man einfach so wie es funktioniert.
Mir ging es diese fünf Millimeter da irgendwie gebacken auf das große Ding und dann schnell etwas auseinander und dann versucht man diese Fabrik so wie sie ist im Detail zu verstehen aber ankommt und die dann einfach zu duplizieren und man macht dann gar keine großen.
Engineering Anstalten mehr nachzuvollziehen warum das jetzt in diesem Setting so gut funktioniert sondern man macht es dann einfach.
Da kommt so ganz viel Erfahrungsraum dazu wo dir dieses reine tüfteln gar nicht weiterhilft sondern echte Erfahrung und auch viel Investition.
Wobei die Chinesen und es ist ein Nachteil für die Amerikaner da recht viele Vorteile haben was Fertigung angeht.
Klar Tim Cook war berühmt dafür dass Steve Jobs das Handy entworfen hat und Tim Cook hat dann organisiert wie man weltweit die ganzen Rohstoffe und die Fabriken und die Menschen bekommt dass dann eine Million Menschen da irgendwie iPhones herstellen.
Aber das gelang immer nur in China also Amerika ist extrem abhängig davon dass die ganzen tollen Ideen Design in California dann auch tatsächlich gebaut werden in China bei Foxconn und so weiter weil es einfach deren Expertise.
Und da können die Amerikaner gar nicht mithalten. Apple hat es ja mal versucht auch auf politischen Willen hin zumindest die großen Meck Computer bei denen man so ein bisschen Spielraum hat wo man welches Bauteil unterbringt.
Das ist dann mal in Texas und so zu machen es hat auch so ein bisschen funktioniert aber dieses ganz raffinierte zehn Millionen Handys in drei Monaten herzustellen das ist absolut chinesische Domäne.
Da kommen die Amerikaner gar nicht mehr hinterher.
Auch was die Seltenen Erden anbelangt. Die werden zwar gar nicht so stark in China abgebaut da versuchte China ein bisschen mehr zu machen aber das ist ja auch immer ein großes ökologisches Risiko.
Die verarbeiten eben diese begehrten Metalle Es gibt einen Artikel dazu in der Juli-Ausgabe von Le Monde von Kamil Bortoluzzi.
Die Macht der Seltenen Erden. China nutzt seine Spitzenposition bei der Förderung und Verarbeitung der begehrten Metalle im Handelskrieg gegen die USA.
Die USA sind da genau so abhängig ist China gemacht wird.
Das heißt Es wird dann auch mal so ganz kurz angesprochen dieses Szenario naja wenn Trump jetzt sagen Wir brechen das jetzt ab dann wäre die eigene Industrie in einer solch katastrophalen Situation und dies beiderseits.
Aber die Abhängigkeit ist beiderseits. China könnte genauso wenig ohne Amerika.
Aber das ist eigentlich der Stellvertreter Konflikt den wir da gerade erleben. Wir müssen uns immer vergegenwärtigen wenn wir ein Smartphone in der Hand haben und so da ist die ganze Geopolitik eigentlich gerade drin.
Es beginnt in China mit den Sojabohnen.
Das ist tatsächlich Sojabohnen ist eins der Megathema weil in China die rechnen aus wie viel Kalorien brauchen wir für unsere Volkswirtschaft.
Und die sehen dass sie es aus eigener Kraft trotz dieser riesigen Fläche nicht schaffen.
Das hatten wir auch einmal gelesen zwischendurch die Bemühungen gab ein Prozent der australischen Grund und Bodens zu kaufen um dort Ersatz für Sojabohnen Produktion zu schaffen den man in Amerika als Lieferanten nicht mehr findet.
Als Trump meinte.
Wir machen jetzt hier eine Trumps Wirtschaftskrieg führte er dann dazu dass die chinesischen dass die amerikanischen Bauern ihre Sojabohnen nicht mehr nach China verkaufen durften.
Es gab also eine riesige Delle eine ganz große Kalorien Lücke zwischen den Produzenten.
Amerika da muss ja Trump irgendwie 30 Milliarden oder so Subventionen nachschießen damit das überhaupt mal wieder funktioniert hat die Bauern es nicht so merken dass der Absatz fehlt und gleichzeitig hatten die Chinesen,
in diesen Handelsweg einfach nicht mehr gehabt sich dazu Versorgung mit Kalorien.
Und dann stellte sich aber drei Monate später raus.
Der Strom ist immer noch derselbe. Die chinesischen.
Kunden kaufen immer noch am Ende amerikanische Sojabohnen obwohl die Chinesen extrem viel staatliches Geld nachschießen müssen damit sie diesen Sojabohnen kommt und Trump seinen Bauern der irgendwie 30 Milliarden Dollar zahlen muss.
Nur haben diese Sojabohnen dann unglaubliche Wege durch den Welthandel genommen bis sie dann eben in China ankamen. Es gab gar keine Alternative.
Die Chinesen mussten die amerikanischen kaufen und die Amerikaner mussten nach China verkaufen auch wenn Trump das verboten hat.
Gab es denn 30000 Zwischenhändler und es war die größte Geldverschwendung aller Zeiten die man da auch eine große Dummheit einfach die größte Geldverschwendung.
Und da hat man auch gesehen wie abhängig die eigentlich voneinander sind. Dass es da gar keine Alternativen gibt weil die haben dann in Australien auch festgestellt Ach so Die wollen hier ein Prozent von unserem Land kaufen und dann haben sie es auch versucht zu verhindern und dann gab es da wieder Streitereien und,
es hat ganz viel durcheinandergebracht gebracht was es im Kalten Krieg nicht gab da gab es nur eine rote Telefonleitung irgendwie um mal miteinander zu sprechen aber sonst keine großen.
Diese kleinen Devisengeschäfte die Westdeutschen dann mal bei den Ostdeutschen Möbel gekauft haben oder sowas für ein paar D-Mark aber das ist wirklich neu in diesem Kalten Krieg das Diese Interdependenzen da jetzt auch auf Jahrzehnte angelegt sind.
Wir haben mal Modern Talking rüber geschickt damit wir sie mal loswerden.
Das gab es natürlich schon ein sehr gutes Stichwort.
Wenn ich nur auf einen Aspekt noch hinweisen und auf zwei kleine Aspekte hinweisen in den Blättern in der August-Ausgabe erschienen von Uwe Hering einen Artikel über Machtpolitik mit Maske über China.
Und da geht es darum dass wir ja über Afrika auch sprechen müssen mit der Seidenstraße.
Und das könnte jetzt aber durch Corona auch für China nochmal eine neue schwierige Situation mit sich bringen denn immer mehr Stimmen werden ja laut.
Müsste man nicht damals Schuldenerleichterung schaffen.
Auch ein Schuldenschnitt Wir hatten ja das Thema Schulden schon mehrmals angesprochen Das wird uns wahrscheinlich die zehn Jahre auch verfolgen.
Und China gilt ja sowieso da als sehr mag ich auftretend und die geben dann tolle Kredite aber dann extrem diese Länder an sich und sorgen dann auch.
Gewisse Repressionen aus. Und hier gibt diese Idee.
Entscheidend aber dürfte sein ob es China gelingt seine Welt and Road Initiative erfolgreich weiterzuführen.
Zu einer Nagelprobe wird dabei die neue überschuldung die sich bereits zuvor aufgebaut hat und nun für viele Länder untragbar zu werden droht weltweit werden Forderungen nach Schuldenerleichterungen laut.
Dem kann sich auch China nicht entziehen.
In den vergangenen Jahren zum größten bilateralen Gläubiger der Länder des globalen Südens geworden ist.
Geschätzt haben chinesische Banken allein seit 2013 den Beginn von der Initiative 461 Milliarden US-Dollar für Projekte in 138 Ländern zugesagt.
Das könnte also nochmal fraglich sein was sie davon zurückfordern müssen können dürfen.
Das ist doch auch eine tolle Ironie der Geschichte dass wir Afrika 50 Jahre lang ausbeuten mit dieser Schuldenlast und das jetzt den Chinesen die Schuldenlast bei denen kommt jetzt das Problem an dass die Schuldenlast so hoch ist.
Also müssen die sich jetzt darum kümmern wie sie auch die durch Europa angehäuften Schulden wieder loswerden. Bei ihren Neukunden.
Es gab in dem Magazin zu internationale Politik wenn man,
das außenpolitische Journal der transatlantisch sind es dann auch diese überlegungen ob man nicht sagen könnte Na ja Afrika,
und Europa und China müssen irgendwie auch zusammenarbeiten und ein gemeinsames Konzept entwickeln.
Auch das ist eine Idee. Entschuldigung ich habe mich gerade nicht in.
Erschienenen Welten sondern in internationale Politik gab es diesen Vorschlag von einem Diplomaten dass man jetzt sagen kann Eigentlich muss man Afrika helfen aber das kriegt Europa nicht alleine hin China nicht allein hin.
Eigentlich könnte doch diese Kooperation wirtschaftlich für beide gut sein aber auch diplomatisch für beide sehr sinnvoll dass China und Europa da so einen gemeinsamen Modus vivendi spielt.
Ich habe auch so ein bisschen den Eindruck wir probieren das mal in einem anderen auf einem anderen Kontinent aus bevor wir das hier vor der eigenen Haustür haben ist auch ein bisschen problematisch sicherlich diese,
auch wieder fast kolonialistische sich da auf Afrika.
Aber gut wir gehen jetzt mal noch zu einer anderen Perspektive über und zwar,
in der Roosen Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung und zwar der Text der kommende Krieg der USA China Konflikt und seine Industrie und klimapolitischen Konsequenzen.
Von Inga Solti Das ist eine Analyse 38 Seiten kann man sich auch bestellen oder online bekommen die wirklich jedem ans Herz sieht man bekommt diesen ganzen Konflikt nochmal,
großartig aufgefächert und man bekommt eine andere Perspektive darauf Wir hören jetzt erst mal rein ich habe da etwas eingelesen.
Trump sprach schon im Wahlkampf permanent von China und seinen unfairen Handelspraktiken und meinte damit den chinesischen Staatsinterventionismus.
Nach seinem Amtsantritt vollzog er eine Inversion der Nixons Politik von 1971.
Aus der Erkenntnis heraus mit geringer werdenden Ressourcen nicht mit der Sowjetunion und China gleichzeitig aufnehmen zu können und aufgrund der Befürchtung diese noch stärker zur Kooperation miteinander zu treiben,
hatte Nixon damals das Bündnis mit China gesucht um die Sowjetunion niederringen zu können.
In umgekehrter Richtung hat nun Trump den Konflikt mit Russland eingefroren beziehungsweise an die europäischen Nato-Staaten delegiert um sich so stärker auf den Hauptfeind China konzentrieren zu können.
Die Drohung Sollten die anderen Nato-Staaten nicht das Ziel erfüllen zwei Prozent ihres Bruttoinlandsproduktes,
in die Aufrüstung zu stecken würden die USA unter Trump notfalls Artikel 5 des Nato-Vertrags Missachten der im Falle eines Angriffs,
von Russland oder einem anderen Staat auf ein Nato-Mitglied den kollektiven Verteidigungsfall nach sich zieht.
Ist in diesem Kontext zu sehen.
Hier geht es erstens darum die Europäerinnen dazu zu bekommen,
sich nun vermehrt um ihre eigene Sicherheit zu kümmern und von Sicherheits Konsumenten unter dem Schutzschild der USA zu Sicherheits Produzenten zu werden.
Zweitens steckt hinter dieser Drohung und Forderung der USA der Wunsch die europäischen Nato-Staaten mögen den USA den Rücken für den Kampf mit China freihalten.
Denn dieser erfordert den Einsatz aller zur Verfügung stehenden Ressourcen einer weltgeschichtliche schwächer werdenden Hegemonialmacht.
Das zweiProzent sieht ein bisschen anders Kontextualisierung,
Wir sollten jetzt hier mal die Aufgaben vor Ort übernehmen Russland im Zaum halten und die USA konzentrieren sich mal auf den eigentlichen großen Konflikt des 21. Jahrhunderts.
Aber das ist so Wahnsinn weil die Geschichte der Nato nach dem Kalten Krieg seit sagen wir mal so 91 als auch die OSZE im Raum stand mit der Idee Wir können ja auch für europäische Sicherheit sorgen.
Diese Geschichte ist ja geprägt von der Vormachtstellung Amerikas die man sich auch bewusst gesucht hat um eine Nähe aus Europa und Russland zu verhindern.
Ja Putin 2001 bei Gerhard Schröder zu Besuch im Bundestag und hat diese große Rede gehalten.
Direkt nach dem 11. September Wir müssen jetzt hier mal gegen Terror und so weiter wir haben ein gemeinsames Ziel sollten wir nicht so eine eurasische Sicherheits Allianz und so weiter bilden.
So viel das auf so wie wir von Gerd Schröder wissen ein positives Gemüt wurde dann allerdings aus Amerika kurz und klein geschlagen.
Das haben die Amerikaner sehr erfolgreich gemacht. Bis Trump gewählt wurde.
Und wenn Sie jetzt diesen Begriff der Sicherheits Produktion plötzlich in den Blick nimmt.
Es ist gegen Amerikas Interesse bisher gewesen dass Europa in eine Rolle der Sicherheits Herstellung kommt weil das ja zum Beispiel eine aktive Zusammenarbeit mit Russland bedeuten könnte,
weil ganz klar ist dass ein europäischer Ansatz für internationale Sicherheit zu sorgen nicht darin besteht dass man überall Militärbasen aufbaut sondern dass man dann doch mal diesen militärischen Wandel durch Annäherung und so weiter.
Diesen diplomatischen Weg eigentlich geht es also diese Idee dass Trump.
Trump mehr Europa in eine Selbstbehauptung Rolle militärisch diplomatisch der Sicherheits Produktion bringen möchte.
Es liegt auf der Hand.
Unter Washingtons Prämissen soll das dann alles sein.
Sozusagen angelegt ist alles damit es nicht mehr Amerika machen muss. Diese Ermächtigung steht ja genau.
Angelegt ist als nicht mehr Amerika machen muss. In dieser Ermächtigung steht ja genau so eine.
Wir haben jetzt wieder zur Verfügung. Dieses Verhältnis mit Russland neu zu sortieren uns nicht zu unterwerfen nur weil die Sanktionen wollen dass wir dann mitmachen.
Wir haben jetzt wieder zur Verfügung. Dieses Verhältnis mit Russland neu zu sortieren uns nicht zu unterwerfen. Wobei die Sanktionen wollen dass wir nicht mitmachen.
Und das ist wirklich verrückt weil das konterkariert alle amerikanischen Präsidentschaften Clinton und Obama so komplett anders ist.
Und das ist wirklich verrückt weil das konterkariert alle amerikanischen Präsidentschaften Clinton und Obama so eigentlich komplett ist.
Bush auch alle drei eigentlich. Man muss es wirklich als Kontinuität sehen.
Aber es gibt doch Kontinuitäten die mit diesen Handelswegen auf sich hat jetzt bei Stefan Widerling gehört China die,
kommen mit großem militärischem Aufgebot daher aber USA sorgen sich ja darum die Handelswege die,
ja eigentlich von einer gewissen Kontinuität und selbstverständlich Gründe eigentlich am Laufen ist.
Die militärische Einkreisung Chinas soll dem US-Start den macht Hebel einer möglichen Seeblockade verschaffen.
Chinas Entwicklungsmodell basiert auf dem Export von Waren Chinas immens wachstumsstarke Wirtschaft bedarf für das stabile funktionieren wiederum des Imports von Unmengen an Rohstoffen.
Weil China summa summarum ein rohstoff armes Land ist die große Abhängigkeit von wahren Exporten und Rohstoffe Importen macht das chinesische Modell verletzlich.
Diese Schwäche versuchen die USA auszunutzen. Der Irak-Krieg hat die USA gelehrt dass sie mit ihrer militärischen überlegenheit problemlos die ersten Schlachten gewinnen und ein Land besetzen.
Aber Kriege mit Bodentruppen kaum siegreich zu Ende führen können.
Die USA waren nach dem Desaster des Irak-Kriegs schon unter Obama nicht nur zu Drohnenkrieg und extra legalen Tötungen sowie zur Vorbereitung von Roboter kriegen übergegangen.
Um weitere Bilder von Zink Särgen mit toten GIs zu vermeiden.
Sie hatten einen Schwerpunkt der Außenpolitik was unter Demokraten ohnehin eine stärkere Tradition hat.
Bereits auf dem Seeweg Kontrolle gelegt. Diese Tradition geht auf Alfred Peya Meierhans zurück und einer ihrer führenden Vertreter jener auf Minsky war lange Zeit wichtiger Berater,
demokratischer Präsidenten gewesen.
Trumps ehemaliger Verteidigungsminister James Mattis ist ebenfalls Anhänger dieser Tradition und brachte sie in die neue Regierung ein.
Zudem heißt es in der sicherheitspolitischen Doktrin der Trump Administration die 2018 veröffentlicht wurde,
Die Grossmacht Rivalität nicht der Terrorismus sei Hauptfokus der nationalen Sicherheitspolitik der USA also der Konflikt mit China.
Mit dieser Fokussierung auf die sey Herrschaft im Westpazifik und im Südchinesischen Meer senden die USA dem eingekreist China in etwa folgende Botschaft Wir wissen.
Jetzt haben wir mal diesen geopolitischen Konflikt ein bisschen anders beleuchtet. Was hat eigentlich die USA davor wenn sie so agiert.
Und da macht er doch eine Kontinuität aus von der ich wusste dass die Demokraten diese Handelswege als militärische Doktrin sehr stark hatten.
Finde ich ganz erstaunlich.
Das hat er aber Clinton schon als dieses neue Jahrhundert amerikanische Jahrhundert das wir uns da jetzt mal investieren sozusagen offen angekündigt.
Diesen Schwenk nach Asien nannte sie das ja,
investieren. sozusagen.
Auf der Bühne das war hart für Amerika zunichtegemacht weil Trump da gar nichts hören wollte.
Und er denkt auch immer im Modus des Handels. Aber jetzt geht mal so in die Rolle der amerikanischen geostrategischen und malt jetzt mal so aus.
Was sagen die denn eigentlich mit dem was sie.
Wir wissen euer Entwicklungsmodell ist stark abhängig vom Außenhandel.
Wir wissen auch dass ihr etwa 80 prozent eures Außenhandels über die Seewege über das Südchinesische Meer die Straße von Malakka und den Persischen Golf abwickelt.
Unsere Militärpräsenz kann eure gesamte Entwicklung in einer Weise abschneiden so wie das napoleonische Frankreich beispielsweise 1800 Großbritannien vom Außenhandel mit Kontinentaleuropa abschnitt.
Ihr sollt euch im Klaren darüber sein was das innenpolitisch für euch bedeutet.
Ihr wisst so gut wie wir dass ihr die 250 bis 300 Millionen Wanderarbeiter in eurem Landesinnern nur durch ein sehr hohes und stetiges Wirtschaftswachstum davon abhalten könnt Unruhen zu stiften.
Dafür braucht es in etwa Wachstumsraten von acht bis zehn Prozent.
Wenn wir also euer Wachstum durch eine kontinental Blockade abwürgen dann könnt ihr euch auf massive Verteilungskonflikte im Innern gefasst machen die sich wie überall sonst auf der Welt rasch Ethnisierung,
und auch Konfessionalismus führen dürften denkt an eure muslimischen und uigurischen Minderheiten denkt an Tibet und an achtseitigen in Ladas.
Damit droht euch womöglich ein Zerfall des Staates wie 1991 bereits die von uns Tod. gerüstete Sowjetunion erlebte.
Entsprechend solltet ihr um das zu verhindern unsere Forderungen nach Finanz Marktliberalisierung Boden Privatisierung und geistiger Eigentumsrechte erfüllen.
Haben sie eine große Klappe im Westen.
Wir wissen ja aus China dass der Binnenmarkt ja auch rasant gewachsen ist.
Die Abhängigkeit vom Export ist gar nicht mehr so gigantisch wie sie mal war.
Da gibt es auch eine Entwicklung und da muss man sagen Dieser Seeweg der Markt war sehr bedeutend sein und auch ein bisschen tückisch weil man damit einem Flugzeugträger aus Amerika einfach hinfahren kann ohne dass irgendwas auffällt Auf dem Weg,
aber die Seidenstraße über den Landweg da durch,
die eigenen Untiefen nahe vorbei durch dieses afghanische Tal was es da noch gibt und so weiter muss man erst mal befrieden musste. Das führte dann bis nach Duisburg.
Da haben die ja schon im Blick. Auch als die große Antwort,
weil dann der Zug einfach schneller fährt als ein Schiff braucht er sieben Wochen und Zug fährt da schon mal in sieben Tagen einfach durch und steht dann in Düsseldorf am innereuropäischen Verlader Bahnhof um sozusagen alles innerhalb von zwei Wochen hin und her,
zu transportieren. Also.
Das ist aber auch nicht konfliktfrei diese ganze Region verweise ich mal auf diese aussenpolitische.
Da gab es einen Artikel von Bulat Sultan NOV Integrationsprozesse in Eurasien und dort erzählt er wie problematisch diese ganze Grenze da ist.
Er schreibt dann die außenpolitischen Prioritäten der Länder Zentralasiens unterscheiden sich stark voneinander.
Nur Kasachstan hat Grenzen mit Russland und China.
Kein Wunder also dass beide Länder für Kasachstan die wichtigsten außenpolitischen Richtungen darstellen.
Eine ähnliche Position vertritt Kirgisistan das sich vor allem in ökonomisch finanzieller Hinsicht in Richtung China orientiert und in Militär politischer Hinsicht nach Russland Usbekistan,
das bisher die Priorität der bilateralen Beziehungen hat,
öffnet sich unter dem neuen Präsidenten,
sie.
Zunehmend der multilateralen Zusammenarbeit intern wird derzeit etwa eine Neubewertung der Beziehungen zur Eurasischen Wirtschaftsunion diskutiert.
Infolge geografischer ethnischer und sprachlicher Faktoren ist Tadschikistan interessiert an einer Vertiefung der Zusammenarbeit mit Iran und Afghanistan gerät aber immer mehr in finanzielle Abhängigkeit von China.
Eine besondere Position nimmt Turkmenistan ein das sich mit seiner Politik der Neutralität faktisch isoliert und was er dann da diagnostiziert ist generell für diese Region eine Zunahme der sozialen Polarisierung.
Eine Senkung des Lebensniveau der Masse der Bevölkerung und ein Anwachsen sozialpolitischer Spannungen.
Das ist ein ganz ganz großes Problem was dann dazu führt dass man ja beim Islamischen Staat auch schon tausend Tadschiken hatte die damit kämpften und andere aus,
Kasachen und Kirgisen die gekämpft haben.
Auch so eine radikale Islamisierung da stand in dieser ganzen Gemengelage spielt das auch noch.
Ich glaube dass deswegen diese Handelsweg nach wie vor sehr sehr wichtig ist.
Auch muss man sagen Die starke Binnensee ökonomie aber ist es immer noch so dass China auch sehr darauf aus ist dass wir die Produkte dann auch exportieren dass sie die Produkte exportieren können.
Es gibt ja auch solche Digitalstrategie von Alibaba das die sagen Na ja wartet mal ab.
Irgendwann ist Amazon in Europa nicht mehr so wichtig. Das wird man alles sehen.
Na ja ich meine sobald du so einen Lieferwege hast du heute schon Sachen bei Amazon in wurde völlig egal wo das herkommt. Weil du weißt es ist ja das Tolle.
Jeff Bezos möchte dieses Kunden serviceorientierte Unternehmen und sichert damit das europäische vertrauen dass irgendeine kleine Taschenlampe die man in Shenzhen bestellt auch wirklich ankommt.
Es ist ja eine amerikanische unternehmerische Leistung dass dieses Vertrauen jetzt da ist womit er tatsächlich untergräbt das er eigentlich auch den Auftrag bekommen könnte die amerikanische Taschenlampe zu verkaufen.
Der amerikanische Weg ist mir im Flugzeug dem Schiff alles sehr teuer.
Diese Eisenbahnstrecke diese 3000 Kilometer da diese alten Seidenstraße von Chinesen bis Duisburg die ist fertig die kann man einfach sieben Tage abfahren da wurden auch alle Zollschranken mittlerweile beseitigt und so weiter und die Krisenregion an Afghanistan fährt man einfach durch.
Und da gibt es ja schon grandiose Vorteile die sich dann wirklich auszahlen weil man dann wirklich überlegen muss,
macht es noch einen Unterschied wo das Zeug herkommt und es geht ja so weit dass man weiß dass der deutsche Zoll schon die Sorgen hat.
Wenn Sachen aus China geliefert werden die man hier kauft und es gibt nochmal ein Zwischenhändler bei irgendeinem Großhändler erst einmal sagte Ich kaufe erst mal 10000 Taschenlampen und Praktika die dann einzeln dann fällt Umsatzsteuer an.
Die Welt Aber nicht an wenn man die direkt in China bestellt und dann gab es ja erste Razzien auch bei Amazon wo man dann mal gucken wollte lagern hier eigentlich zwischen Taschenlampen.
Also ich hier zwischengelagert wodurch auch Umsatzsteuer anfällt oder nicht.
Und das große Ziel ist ja auch dass die Chinesen dann ohne solche Tricks,
tatsächlich einfach eine Bestellung direkt aus China liefern die dann innerhalb von drei vier fünf Tagen da ist wodurch dann auch nochmal so ein finanzieller Anreiz da ist weniger Umsatzsteuer 15 19 Prozent weniger.
Das macht natürlich auch nochmal ein großen Unterschied Die Produktionskosten sind für sich ein Unterschied Transportkosten fallen nicht an wenn man irgendwie so einen Güterzug.
Also wenn er einfach alle drei Stunden den Güterzug losfährt und da hängt dann noch ein Container dran.
So macht es auch keinen großen Unterschied mehr in der Hinsicht haben sie sich schon in so eine Position gebracht wo auch dieses Druckmittel von vorhin wir schneiden euch die Seewege ab und dann habt da keinen Export mehr und so sehr schwächelt.
Ob das aufgehen kann ist sehr fraglich. Die Massen bräuchten massenweise Eigenproduktionen Wir haben ja.
Er und man hat ja auch die Masken. Wir haben ja im März gedacht Wir bräuchten Massenmords der eigenen Produktion damit wir nicht abhängig sind vom Weltmarkt weil eine Pandemie Es wäre gut eine Maske zu haben.
Diese Produktion ist komplett wieder nach China gewandert. Man hatte so ein kurzes Aufblühen Deutschland ja hier die ganzen Textilunternehmen machen für 100 Euro das Stück eine Maske.
Diese Produktion jetzt komplett wieder nach China.
Hier am Frankfurter Flughafen wurden jetzt vier Milliarden Masken seit März importiert.
Importiert werden müssen das heißt.
So viele Milliarden Masken das heißt bei 80 Millionen Bundesbürgern für jeden ausreichend eigentlich über einen Flughafen.
Ausreichend ja eigentlich alles importiert.
Alles fliegend transportiert.
Und da sieht man mal selbst solche Sachen wie Corona die nun wirklich rein schlagen wo alle meinen aber da müssen wir aber mal drüber nachdenken und da bräuchten wir eigentlich eine Selbstversorgung und so weiter.
Die nun wirklich einschlagen. Mal drüber nachdenken.
Selbstversorgung per se China das ist wirklich ökonomisch zu groß.
Selbst das ist nach acht Wochen einfach per se. Und dann bestellt man das Zeug wieder in China.
Das ist wirklich beeindruckend auch wenn man es sieht wie viel ökonomische Zugkraft da drin ist und wie groß die Argumente die China da eigentlich hat sind.
Wir hatten im Salon einen Artikel aus der Zeitschrift Sozialismus in dem schon genau das gesagt wurde Naja dass jetzt der Freihandel dass das alles zurückgebaut wird das plötzlich wieder die Wege ganz kurz werden ist sehr sehr fraglich.
Und das bestätigt dass hier gerade und schon so schnell wir hätten jetzt gedacht Gut in einem halben Jahr können wir das sagen.
Aber wir können es schon ein paar Wochen später exakt so sagen.
Ein Aspekt der ganz wichtig ist in diesem Text von Inga Solti der wirklich sensationell ist dieser Text ist das ökologische und beschäftigt sich damit wie weit China da eigentlich ist.
Wir wissen Die haben 2008 mit der Finanzkrise sehr viel investiert aber nicht in große Blasen sondern sie haben vor allem investiert in Infrastruktur die schnellen Züge Busse all diese Dinge. Das geht immer noch sehr viel weiter.
Er zeigt dass man das so betrachten muss dass selbstverständlich auch ganz viel Umweltverschmutzung da stattfindet.
Stichwort Seltene Erden. Wir müssen auch erkennen wenn wir über China reden was da Menschenrechte Kloses überwachung Losers.
Er zeigt doch dass wir sicherlich auch damit fremdeln mit diesem Bild aber er sagt dann dass es diese sensationelle Wendung die dann stattfindet mit den USA.
Also nehmen wir mal an die würden jetzt diesen Kalten Krieg wenn er ein kalter bleibt gewinnen.
Wird es auch katastrophal werden und er malt jetzt hier etwas aus was wir uns schon mal vergegenwärtigen sollten für die nächsten zehn Jahre.
Im US Pentagon rechnet man längst damit dass ein großer Krieg mit China unvermeidlich sein wird selbst wenn damit ein dritter Weltkrieg mit Atomwaffen und die völlige Auslöschung der Menschheit drohen.
Auch aus diesem Grund arbeiten die USA nach ihrer Aufkündigung des Washingtoner Vertrags über nukleare Mittelstrecken Systeme an der Modernisierung ihrer Atomwaffen die auch in Deutschland stationiert sind.
Es geht ihnen um den Ausbau von Erstschlag Kapazitäten und Schlag Verhinderung.
Möglichkeiten hierfür entwickeln sie sogenannte Mini Onyx.
Die haben die Sprengkraft von Atombomben von Hiroshima und Nagasaki.
Auch führen sie Verhandlungen mit West pazifischen Staaten um dort gegen China gerichtet entsprechende Mittelstrecken Trägerraketen zu stationieren.
Weil Australien sich bislang geweigert hat scheinen die USA das Ziel zu verfolgen diese Raketen auf japanischen Inseln zu stationieren.
Der mittlerweile pensionierte US-General Ben Hodges machte damit auf sich aufmerksam dass er über diese Planspiele und überzeugungen in aller öffentlichkeit sprach.
Beim Warschauer Sicherheits Forum 2018 sagte er den Anwesenden Er gehe davon aus dass die USA innerhalb der nächsten 15 Jahre einen großen Krieg gegen China führen werden.
Der Konflikt spitzt sich also zu. Er hat nicht nur das Potenzial die menschliche Zivilisation mit Atomwaffen auszulöschen,
selbst wenn es nur beim Handelskrieg bleiben sollte könnte dies enorme Zerstörungen und Katastrophen nach sich ziehen.
Die bittere Erkenntnis der Analyse des Konflikts zwischen den Staaten des US dominierten Westens einerseits und China andererseits ist siegt der Westen stirbt der Planet,
setzen sich die USA mit ihrem Ziel der Unterordnung Chinas und seiner Einordnung in die herrschende Weltwirtschaftsordnung durch.
Dann ist die Klimakatastrophe unvermeidlich.
Fröhliche Aussichten. Ich finde es sehr schön dass er dann nochmal deutlich macht worum es hier geht wenn wir China integrieren in den Weltmarkt.
Dann bedeutet das dass die Umweltverschmutzung in einer Weise zunehmen wird dass das für den Planeten einen Kollaps bedeuten würde.
Dieser Staatsinterventionismus Ansatz von der Kommunistischen Partei,
hat in den letzten Jahren schon ganz erheblich dafür gesorgt dass man dort klimapolitisch dem Westen vorausgeht und wenn dieser Weg jetzt nicht so weiter beschritten werden könnte.
Und gerade der chinesische Mittelstand sich jetzt auch einer öffnung hingibt zum Westen in der Lebensweise dass wir dann eigentlich eine Konstellation auf der Welt haben die nur dazu führt dass wir,
den Klimawandel noch stärker beschleunigen und dann in der Katastrophe enden.
Mal abgesehen von der möglichen Katastrophe die einfach dadurch kommen kann dass es zu einem heißen Krieg wird diese.
Diese Szenarien sind wahrscheinlich die realistischeren dieses Szenario.
Da muss man sich am Ende wirklich mal fragen wer soll den Krieg befehlen Wer macht den ersten. Wie sieht das aus.
Sieht das aus. Wer Soliman ausführt kennt.
Wer soll ihn denn ausführen. Wer kämpft und,
welche politische Begleiterscheinungen gibt es denn da.
Welche politische Begleiterscheinungen gibt es da bei Dr. Seltsam sagen Na ja wir ziehen uns mal zurück in den Bunker vor hundert Jahren im Zweiten Weltkrieg hatte man sehr viel Vorlauf mit so einer Idee man Heimatfreunde man auch nicht vergessen.
Beim Zweiten Weltkrieg hatte man sehr viel Vorlauf mit einer Idee von Heimatfront der letzte Krieg war noch nicht vergessen.
Jeder Stoß ein Franzose da hatte das noch so eine da war das Abenteuer noch da es war ja so absurd dass man später InsO Versöhnung treffen Menschen gefragt hat.
Jeder Stoß ein Franzose hatte das noch so da war das Abenteuer schon noch da es war ja so absurd dass man,
später in so Versöhnungskirche Menschen fragte was nicht zur Zeit seines Lebens sondern erzählen die so aus Frankreich stellt man später fest also als alles Nazis Frankreich besetzt. Das war die Polizei.
Was war denn die schönste Zeit meines Lebens die so aus Frankreich.
Und dann stellt man fest als ja als Nazis Frankreich besetzt habe. Das war die tolle Zeit.
Ja stimmt eigentlich sollte man nicht aber es war eine tolle Zeit als wir alle in Frankreich waren.
Ja stimmt eigentlich Nee das kann man so heute gar nicht mehr sagen sollte man nicht. Es war eine tolle Zeit.
Als wir alle in Frankreich waren diese Szenarien sind ja alle ausgeschlossen. Und was noch hinzukommt ist.
Diese Szenarien sind ja alle ausgeschlossen. Und was noch hinzukommt.
Ja aber das benötigt ja auch einen Atomkrieg. Ja aber ein Atomkrieg muss ja dann doch irgendwie losgehen.
Ein Atomkrieg muss ja dann doch irgendwie losgehen.
Du brauchst dann nur noch ein paar Leutchen die bereit sind.
Ja. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es große Argumente wenn man dann wirklich mal die Demografie als hauptsächlichen politischen Akteur in Beschlag nimmt dass sowohl Amerika als auch.
China und China insbesondere so alte stagnierende Gesellschaften sind.
China fängt ja jetzt nun wirklich rasant an zu schrumpfen die werden ja von Indien innerhalb der nächsten fünf Jahre so eingeholt und während es in Indien immer weitergeht geht's in China wirklich zurück.
Was nicht heißt dass China an sich schrumpft sondern dass es da auch sehr viel alte Menschen gibt um die man sich kümmern muss weil es bisher kein Rentensystem darauf noch gar keine Antwort. Also muss da sehr die Familie einspringen.
Dann hat man dieses deutsche Modell. Menschen werden sehr alt und wer kümmert sich zu 80 Prozent für die Pflege einer Familie Staat sind das dann Familien die noch jemanden übrig haben der irgendwie Kopffreiheit für den Krieg und so oder so dieses Szenario von Weltkrieg.
Das liegt schon lange zurück und es ist auch sehr historisch und ob man das nochmal so aktualisiert kriegt und ein Atomkrieg ist wie gesagt so eine eigene Sache.
Wobei die Amerikaner ja schon wieder sehr stolz darauf sind dass ihre tollen Raketen fliegen ja mit 30000 kWh oder so.
Das ist ja möglich superschnell also acht Minuten sind die überall auf der Welt die muss man gar nicht erst aus der Nähe abschießen fliegen seit zwei Minuten länger und dann schauen sie auch noch den Atlantik zu überqueren in der Zeit und die kann man ja jetzt auch Steuern.
Also nach Abflug Bisher sind ja einfach nur eine ballistische Kurve geflogen und so seit fünf Jahren oder so.
War ja trampt dann auch sehr stolz darauf und Putin hat das ja auch schon vorgestellt Das System kann man so Nachsteuern sodass sie schon mal fliegen und dann gibt man das Ziel nochmal ein oder nimmt es halt auch wieder raus.
Also das Drohpotenzial ist nochmal unglaublich größer.
Und wie vorhin schon angemerkt dieses Drohpotenzial hat auch recht viel verhindert da das Klima Ding scheint das zu sein wo man sich mehr drum kümmern muss weil das scheint unausweichlich zu sein.
Genau solch ein Staatsinterventionismus den wir ja jetzt auch gerade von der EU gut finden der ja viel geringer Masse stattfindet dann doch etwas sehr Schönes zu sein weil man auch sagt naja was nutzt,
der Wettbewerb wenn es am Ende doch wieder Monopol Strukturen sind die sich durchsetzen.
Und wenn es auch nicht besonders demokratisch ist wenn jetzt gerade die Generation die Welt zerstört für die nachfolgende Generation deutlich wird das wenn man sich diese verschiedenen Perspektiven ansieht ist das nicht. Das war ja der Ausgangspunkt.
China ist der Aggressor und die wollen halt hier die Herrschaft haben alle wollen in einem geopolitischen in einer geopolitischen Gemengelage die Herrschaft haben jeder möchte am liebsten Weltmacht sein.
Es ist jetzt nicht mehr nur die USA sondern China ist auf dem Weg dorthin.
Und das muss man sehr relativieren ohne irgendwie zu,
glorifizieren wie China mit seiner Bevölkerung umgeht und dass man das Modell für sich ablehnt muss man aber das in einer anderen Weise nochmal betrachten auch,
mit Blick auf diesen Imperialismus der da stattfindet.
Auch jemand wie Elon Musk der ganz unverhohlen bei Twitter nochmal gesagt hat Ja.
Wir wollen in Bolivien wenn wir Lithium haben wollen ja da gar keine Scheu hat das so auszusprechen also Vorsicht wenn man jetzt sagt der Imperialismus der Chinesen gibts ja vom Westen schon sehr sehr lange.
Jetzt können wir aber eigentlich mit diesem Aufschlag das Thema,
über die nächsten Jahre weiter verfolgen Es wird auf jeden Fall spannend und am Ende trifft immer der Satz von Paul Valéry zu den Peter Scholl-Latour gerne zitiert am Ende seiner Vorträge im Abgrund der Geschichte ist für viele.
Ja ja das stimmt.
Wir beobachten ja auch aufmerksam den amerikanischen Wahlkampf und es wird auffallen denn es war die letzten zwei Wahlkämpfe schon so dass die großen amerikanischen außenpolitischen Reden Europa gar nicht mehr thematisieren.
Beobachten ja auch aufmerksam in Afrika und ja es wird glaube ich auch fallen denn es war die letzten zwei Wahlkämpfe schon so dass die großen amerikanischen außenpolitischen Reden Europa gar nicht mehr thematisieren.
Und Asien zu 80 Prozent.
Und Asien zu 80.
Der Rest ist Afrika weil es da auch irgendwie droht aber,
dieses pazifische Jahrhundert ist ja schon da.
Aber Amerika ist ein gutes Stichwort gerne auf eines hinweisen Wir sprechen in den nächsten Monaten viel über Amerika.
Was man aber schon mal tun kann ist wenn man auf Twitter ist Jörg Sena ist der Korrespondent der ZEIT der in ganz andere Perspektiven einbringt was man sonst zum Beispiel auch in der Zeit nicht so liest.
Und der sehr schöne Texte geschrieben hat über Bernie Sanders der aber jetzt auch mal in Las Vegas waren für eine Reportage da eigentlich mit Coruna wie verhalten die Leute sich da und der,
Perspektive die jetzt nicht nur sagt Wir machen jetzt hier wo Culcha und machen dieses ganze Identitäts politische Spektrum sondern auch noch fragt Wie sähe denn eigentlich eine linke Wirtschaftspolitik aus.
Also Jörg wie Mala Sena lesen bei ZEIT ONLINE Und folgen bei Twitter. Das empfehle ich jedem.
Intro/Outro
Ich komme nachher nochmal auf China zurück mit einem Clip vorher aber die Lebenswirklichkeit unsere Lebenswelt Wir haben ja jetzt mit corona das eine oder andere soziale Problem festgestellt auch in Deutschland.
Stichworte sind Erntehelfer Schlachtbetrieb Corona nun gezeigt wie es da zugeht.
Und das war natürlich für die Unternehmer Tönnies nicht besonders toll vor allem da jetzt auch diese Ausweitung US-Studien fertig sind,
beispielsweise vom Helmholtz-Zentrum hat man sich ja diese 1600 Tunes Infektion mal ganz genau angeschaut und hat gesehen an den Unterbringungen,
Wohnungs Bedingungen lag es nicht.
Die hätten durchaus auch geheim bleiben können. Es war dann doch mehr die Arbeitssituation vor Ort dass da einfach eine Frühschicht,
in diesem kalten vaterlosen umgewälzt gekühlten luftdichten,
zehn Stunden lang gearbeitet hat und da die Aerosole dann doch eine große Rolle gespielt haben woraufhin 1600 Leute die da Schulter an Schulter arbeiten und sich auch anschreien weils einfach lauter ist sich infiziert haben.
Tönnies kommt dann nicht umhin erbaut jetzt 75 Häuser mit 1500 Wohnungen.
Das soll eine positive Nachricht sein man fragt sich so ist das nicht das ist das nicht eigentlich der Feudalismus.
Dass der Arbeitgeber noch der die Wohnung hinstellt anstatt dich so zu bezahlen dass du dich auf dem freien Wohnungsmarkt einfach selber eine Wohnung kümmerst Es ist absurd wie das diskutiert wird.
Wir sehen aber auch wie stark so Lobbygruppen sind bei solchen Sachen.
Und jetzt fragen wir uns Wo gehts eigentlich noch so irre zu also auf dem Felde der Landwirtschaft.
Bei Tönnies sind ja schon so Sachen die sind uns wichtig weil wir essen jeden Tag dreimal so viel da kommt das Zeug her das Gemüse und das Fleisch.
Es gibt natürlich verschiedene berufliche Lebenswelten in denen noch viel mehr Menschen arbeiten als über die die wir jetzt sprachen und die auch zu gruseligen Arbeitsbedingungen arbeiten aber die wir so gar nicht richtig mitbekommen.
Und ich musste mich diesen Monat dran erinnern dass der.
Interpret Andrew Yang den wir auch schon mit seiner Wir brauchen mal was anderes als das BIP und ein bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen ja vielleicht nicht falsch aber das Argument gemacht,
in 30 amerikanischen Staaten ist der Lkw-Fahrer der Haupt ökonomische Treiber.
Wenn man die Berufe einteilt in Was machen denn die Leute dann ist die Branche die am größten ist in 30 amerikanischen Staaten.
Die Spedition die Logistik weil alles was produziert wird muss hin und her transportiert werden.
Und wie sieht es eigentlich bei der Logistik aus in Deutschland haben wir da ein Rentner republikanisches Drama Wir haben nämlich 560 000 angestellte Fahrer die in Deutschland mehr als 1000 Kilometer am Tag fahren.
Also ist es nicht so dieses kleine innerstädtischer hin und her sondern die großen Autobahnen Touren und so.
Und von denen gehen jedes Jahr 30 000 in Rente und 2018 sind 3600 Lehrlinge in den Beruf eingestiegen. Da klappt einfach nicht.
Da kann man mal den Taschenrechner rausholen und.
Genau da kann man mal über zu viel Spedition schlägt dann doch so ein bisschen durch und dann wie bei 2008 müssen die Schiffe erstmal rumstehen und keiner bucht jetzt die Container.
Diese LKW Fahrer Branche.
Die kennen wir eigentlich gar nicht obwohl da auch mein Fokus darauf gelegt werden müsste weil da Menschen arbeiten Menschen in ihren eigenen LKW.
Damit der Arbeitgeber keine Verpflichtungen übernehmen muss sind das alles so organisierte Leute die auf der Landstraße herumfahren und ein Paar sind dann doch noch angestellt und werden dabei ausgebeutet und wir gucken uns das mal ein bisschen an weil da gab es am 8.
Juli eine ganz große Entscheidung in Europa Man hat nämlich sich die Arbeitsbedingungen mal angeschaut ich will es aber von hinten aufzeigen und fangen mal 2018 an bei einem ganz typischen,
die Branche begutachtet sich selbst.
Sie hat ein politisches Ziel Sie braucht ein neues Gesetz. Was es damit auf sich hat.
Reden wir gleich und so beginnen dann beispielsweise so kleine Werbefilmchen die dann auf YouTube hochgeladen werden händeringend wird gesucht dass sich das jemand anschaut.
Das ist jetzt ein Clip mit 2000 Fuß oder so. Innerhalb von zweieinhalb Jahren aber recht aussagekräftig inhaltlich.
Logistik ist das Nervensystem einer Volkswirtschaft wenn waren nicht schnell und präzise ihren Bestimmungsort erreichen fällt ein Wirtschaftsstandort im internationalen Ranking schnell zurück.
Wenn sie ihren Bestimmungsort.
Ist. So wenn er sagt ist das Herzstück der Volkswirtschaft weil damit kommt es auf das Ranking insgesamt anwenden die Logistik nicht richtig funktioniert das ist ja schon so eine Argumentation wie wir sie kennen,
wenn Tönnies sagt Wenn ich kein Fleisch herstelle dann fehlen ja den Deutschen die Kalorien und dann sterben die ja alle.
Also man nimmt sich selbst zu wichtig dass es dieses ohne uns geht ja gar nichts.
Und wir hoffen dass auch unsere Mitarbeiter das mit sehr viel Leidenschaft machen weil dann müssen wir weniger Geld zahlen.
Also Pflegeberuf und so weiter. Wir sind hier in diesem Metier wo die wodie Lobbygruppen und die Verbandschefs dann solche Videos produzieren.
Die haben aber jetzt ein Problem festgestellt Nämlich die Lage der Arbeiter und das soll doch mal verbessert werden.
Seit vielen Jahren versuchen Deutschlands Logistiker faire Wettbewerbsbedingungen auf EU-Ebene zu erreichen.
Die Europäische Kommission hat nun ein sogenanntes Mobilitäts Paket initiiert das in gebündelter Form 13 Maßnahmen vorschlägt.
Dazu gehören in erster Linie Neuregelungen und Präzisierungen beim grenzüberschreitenden Verkehr und sogenannten Cabo Tage Fahrten,
bei der Entlohnung der Gebietsschutz Fremden Lkw-Fahrer Einhaltung der Sozialstandards sowie ein Verbot die gesetzlich vorgeschriebene Wochen Ruhezeit von 45 Stunden in der Fahrerkabine zu verbringen.
Das ist doch alles toll oder. Also wenn du dir als Kunde wünscht dass deine Güter gut transportiert werden dann wünschte,
es wäre schon schön wenn die Fahrer ihre Pflicht nicht im Auto verbringen müssten sondern wenn der Arbeitgeber beispielsweise dafür Sorge tragen muss dass man ein ordentliches Zimmer bekommt mit Dusche und einem Fernseher vielleicht.
Und die sich noch in Europa dafür stark machen.
Ja. Die müssen sich dafür stark machen. Es gibt ein Anliegen das aus der Branche heraus auf Verbesserung drängt.
Klingt natürlich gleich alle Glocken aber gut ist seit 2018 angelegt und das zielt schon darauf ab Wir haben zum Beispiel das Wort kaputtgespart gehört hast es schon mal gehört.
Also bekommt aus der Bedeutung zwischen Häfen hin und herfahren einfach früher Schiff und so Sabotage ist heute die kleine und die große die große Kapitale ist,
wenn du dein eigenes Land verlässt seinen eigenen Hoheitsbereich Zoll und so was alles dazu kommt.
Und die kleine oder umgedreht war jedenfalls. Und das meinte er hiermit.
Wenn du ein bulgarischer Unternehmer bist der aber nun mal nur zwischen Düsseldorf und Duisburg hin und her und keinen Auftrag gibt,
weil ein Schicksal deinen bulgarischen Typ und er hat dann quasi auf Montage für 5 Monate ist quasi nie zuhause ist halt so ein lukrativer Auftrag für dich und das Gute ist,
ist ja Bulgare da muss ich nicht mit deutschen Sozialversicherungspflicht oder mit deutschem Lohnniveau rumschlagen sondern er fährt zwischen Düsseldorf und Duisburg und Fleischverarbeiter er kriegt ja auch nur seine drei Euro fünfzig pro Tag.
Na ja das wollen sie halt alles beseitigen.
Fragt man sich ein bisschen was das mit seidigen die profitieren doch davon nein sie haben einen Feind ausgemacht und zwar aus dem gleichen Film von 2018 der diese große diesen großen Mobilitäts packt in Europa Anleihen sollte.
Zwar sind die Bemühungen der Kommission einheitliche Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen erkennbar.
Allerdings gelten bei Fahrten die jeweils nationalen Sozialstandards der Herkunftsländer ausbeuterische Unternehmer vornehmlich aus Osteuropa nutzen diese Lücken auf Kosten der Lkw-Fahrer aus.
Allerdings gelten bei Karuna die jeweils.
Ausbeuterische.
Ein Nomadenleben im Führerhaus eines Sattelschleppern. Das ist purer Manchester-Kapitalismus. Auch auf Kosten der heimischen Fuhrunternehmen.
Nomadenleben.
Ja das ist ja der pure Manchester-Kapitalismus wenn die ausbeuterischen vornehmlich osteuropäischen Unternehmer vornehmlich So was hat es damit auf sich.
Das Szenario kann man sich einfach vorstellen so ein Düsseldorfer Spediteur findet es natürlich blöd wenn ein bulgarischer Spediteur mit bulgarischen Lohnniveau und bulgarischen Sozialstandards zwischen Düsseldorf und München hin und her fährt die ganze Zeit,
will er was gegen den tun ein Gesetz an das den Bulgaren so ein bisschen aus dem Markt rausnimmt.
Oder wenn er hier ist soll er zumindest Deutsche Wohnen Lohnniveau einhalten damit der deutsche Spediteur auch eine Chance hat.
Dieses Gesetz wurde also 2018 aus dieser Branche heraus gestartet.
2019 springen wir mal in so einen kleinen Bericht rein der nur darstellt.
Ist hier so Euronews jetzt schon im Journalismus das war jetzt eben noch die branchenspezifische Lobhudelei und was man alles besser machen will.
2019 ist das Gesetzespaket dann schon so ein bisschen in Europa angekommen und wird dann auch diskutiert.
In den Diskussionen über den ersten europäischen Mobilitäts Pakt bleiben die Fronten zwischen Ost und West verhärtet.
Lkw-Fahrer aus Osteuropa demonstrierten gegen das Gesetzesvorhaben das gleiche Arbeitsbedingungen in der EU bringen soll.
Strittig ist etwa die Pflicht zur Rückkehr in das Herkunftsland der Fahrer wenn diese sich von einer Tour erholen soll. Im Europaparlament kritisieren westliche Abgeordnete ungleiche Startbedingungen.
Der französische Abgeordnete Dominique Ricki sagt die osteuropäischen Fahrer hätten öffentliche Gehälter und Arbeitsbedingungen mit denen westliche Unternehmen nicht konkurrieren könnten.
Auf diese Weise gebe es keine Wettbewerbsgleichheit.
So würden im französischen Abgeordneten sagt wenn man das grundsätzliche Problem nämlich übernommen von dem was die Spediteure selbst schon sagten Das ist doch irgendwie unfair.
Wenn wie gesagt der Bulgare oder der Ungar die ganze Zeit hier auf unserem Hoheitsgebiet rum fährt und die Löhne drückt.
Wieder ins eigene Land zurück kommt das Wort.
Genau das ist dieser Punkt eingebaut in dieses Gesetz wurde dann relativ früh ein Rückkehrrecht für die Fahrer dann ergibt sich irgendwie von alleine da kommt mir einer durch Nachdenken drauf Der Weg nach Bulgarien ist ja ganz schön weit.
Lohnt sich das denn noch zwischen Düsseldorf und Duisburg hin und her zu fahren wenn der Fahrer das Recht hat alle zwei Wochen zu Hause zu sein weil dann kommen ja noch die Fahrt von,
Deutschland nach Bulgarien dazu und die muss man ja auch organisieren wenn man einen tollen Auftrag hat zwischen Düsseldorf und Duisburg muss man dann lernen Lkw bis nach Bulgarien nach Hause fahren lohnt sich das denn kriegt man das irgendwie hin dass es sich vielleicht,
doch noch lohnt und man hat dann bringt dann was mit nach Bulgarien aber was eigentlich.
Da sieht man schon okay das klingt ja nach einer vernünftigen Schranke Man bindet jetzt die Unternehmen so ein bisschen an ihren Heimatort damit die Fahrer den Benefit haben Sie kommen dann auch mal nach Hause.
Also dieses Gesetz ist jetzt fertig geworden im Juli und Wir springen in den Ende Juni 2020.
Zwei Wochen bevor das Gesetz. Es war schon fertig dann den letzten die letzte Abstimmung am 8.
Juli im Europäischen Parlament bekommt. Und da gab es.
Da gab es eine Jubiläumsausgabe von Fernfahrer live.
Das ist ein Podcast der WHO wo alle Video-Podcast sind alle tatsächlich zugeschaltet aus ihrem Fahrerhaus sind.
Wir beide sehen das gleich aber wenn ihr das hört können sich das vorstellen wie das aussieht und die diskutieren jetzt das Gesetz das im Journalismus kaum niedergeschlagen.
Ich habe es nirgendwo gefunden es war totaler Zufall dass ich den Text bei Heise oder so gestoßen bin wo das mal zusammengefasst wurde.
Also Das Gesetz ist fertig und jetzt heißt es Lkw-Fahrer dürfen nicht mehr in ihren Lkw schlafen. Okay das ist positiv für die Lkw-Fahrer.
Der Arbeitgeber muss eine Unterkunft bezahlen.
Die sind ja viel auf Basis unterwegs. Das ließ sich nicht herausfinden was das bedeutet müssen sie sich dann selber eine Unterkunft verpflichtend Dienstfahrten müssen regelmäßig nach Hause führen.
Spätestens alle vier Wochen der Lkw muss spätestens alle acht Wochen nach Hause längere Auslandsaufenthalte.
Gehen weiterhin aber dann gelten die sozialrechtlichen Bestimmungen des Aufenthaltsort selbst wenn in Bulgarien nicht mit nach Hause fahren muss er dann nach Deutschland bezahlt werden.
Davon profitieren dann geschrieben 3,6 Millionen Lkw-Fahrer in Deutschland und es gab hunderte änderungsanträge aus Osteuropa und den Versuch Coruña noch einmal zu instrumentalisieren um das hinauszuzögern aber jetzt ist das Gesetz fertig und es geht eine 18 monatige übergangsfrist.
So wurde es zusammengefasst und man fragt sich ein bisschen das ist doch eigentlich gut.
Man hat sich so gegen die osteuropäischen Lohndumping durchgesetzt.
Jetzt dürfen die Lkw-Fahrer nach Hause fahren und niemand muss mehr hunderte Kilometer von seinem Wohnort weg arbeiten.
Lkw-Fahrer haben natürlich ein spezifisches Interesse die wollen jetzt wissen was steht wirklich in dem Text drin und hier ein kurzer Ausschnitt nur wie die darüber diskutieren und vornehmlich über diese heimkehrte.
Problematik dahinter ist dass wir jetzt einfach sehr oberflächliche Begrifflichkeiten da drin haben oder eben Begrifflichkeiten die ausgelegt werden müssen die auf die entsprechende rechtliche Ausgestaltung die beim einzelnen Fahrer letztlich dahintersteckt,
abgeglichen werden müssen.
Man kann halt nicht behaupten dass der Fahrer das Recht hat nach Hause zu gehen alle vier Wochen,
sondern er hat nur das Recht dass er von seinem Arbeitgeber in einer angemessenen Unterkunft untergebracht wird an einem Standort dem er zugeordnet ist.
Dem widerspricht auch dem Ganzen.
Da war der Hintergedanke doch Wochenende oder die Uhrzeit darf nicht mehr im AKW verbracht werden damit man die Fahrer an ihrem Wohnort oder Lebensmittelpunkt kriegt.
Aber damals war die Rede von damals,
und heute. Wenn die am Firmenstandort man noch immer nach Hause.
Andreas du wolltest vorhin schon mal sagen Ich wollte mal fragen genau wegen dieser schwammigen Formulierungen.
Was ist denn eigentlich genau eine geeignete Unterkunft.
Wer bestimmt so was ist eine geeignete Unterkunft ein Zelt mit einem Dixi-Klo. Oder ist es dann schon ein Dach oder.
Es beginnt also 2018 mit diesem Lobbies Filmchen Wir wollen jedem Fahrer das Recht geben einmal im Monat nach Hause zu fahren.
Dann geht das Gesetz in seinen Gang und kommt dann raus als für die Fahrer ist völlig unklar heißt es jetzt nach Hause oder einfach nur zum Unternehmensstandort.
Und der kann ja nun mal wirklich ganz woanders sein als zuhause wo die Familie vielleicht wartet und dann die Nachfrage und was ist eigentlich eine geeignete Unterkunft weil wenn es nicht zu Hause ist reicht es dann Dixi-Klo neben dem Zelt eine eigene eigene Unterkunft.
Und jetzt am 8. Juli also zwei Wochen nachdem die da miteinander sprachen am 8.
Juli gab es dann wie gesagt die endgültige Abstimmung über Reformen des Straßentransport zur Verbesserung der Arbeitsbedingungen der Fahrer für mehr Klarheit bei der Entsendung und zur Bekämpfung illegaler Praktiken,
der EU mit Mobilitäts Pakt wie gesagt betrifft 3,6 Millionen Menschen,
besteht aus zwei Verordnungen zum Thema Berufszweigen Marktzugang Lenkzeiten Ruhezeiten Fahrtenschreiber Pflicht.
Und da gibt es noch eine Richtlinie zur Entsendung von Kraftfahrern.
Wir kommen jetzt mal in diese Pressekonferenz rein wir hören zuerst den deutschen SPD-Abgeordneten Ismail Northug der hier mal das Problem beschreibt und,
ich will noch mal am Anfang sagen am Anfang hieß es osteuropäische Unternehmer kommen ja hier mit mancher sagt kapitalistischen Methoden und so weiter.
Und jetzt beschreibt der SPD-Mann mit welchen Problemen sich die herumgeschlagen hat und dann klären wir mal ob wir das eigentlich lösen konnte oder nicht.
Zertifikate der International Transport,
European Rhoades.
Heising.
Die BIC Logistik Companies McKinley,
out letter box Company member states Standards.
Center Markets.
Wir haben es also gar nicht mit osteuropäischen Manchester kapitalistischen Unternehmern zu tun sondern mit nord und westdeutschen europäischen,
die allerdings eine Briefkastenfirma in Bulgarien haben um dort die Fahrer anzustellen und nach bulgarischen Maßstäben dann wieder am Heimatort zwischen Duisburg und Düsseldorf oder wo auch immer einzusetzen.
Und dann kann man ja nach Hause fahren. Das Recht auf nach Hause fahren wurde ja diskutiert und dann wurde es aber wieder raus gestrichen.
Es reicht auch am Heimatort Wir haben jetzt die Lage das osteuropäische Unternehmen,
die nun mal ihren Standort in Ungarn oder wo auch immer haben ihre Fahrer tatsächlich alle 4 Wochen zu sich holen müssen während deutsche Unternehmer,
die Briefkastenfirmen Ungarn haben also ungarische Angestellte haben die allerdings in Deutschland fahren die nicht nach Hause schicken müssen sondern da reicht es die in Duisburg für eine Nacht Wochen,
pro Woche Pflicht mäßig in einer Unterkunft.
Da kann man ja wie Thönnes einfach so ein Containerdorf aufbauen und so weiter wo die dann eine Woche außerhalb ein Tag pro Woche außerhalb ihres Fahrzeugs übernachten also allein über diese kleine Nuance dass aus dem Recht nach Hause zurückzukehren.
Die Pflicht wurde einfach nur außerhalb des Fahrzeugs kann aber auch am Standort des Unternehmers sein und der ist nun mal in Duisburg.
Man hat sich hier einen unglaublichen Vorteil gegenüber der osteuropäischen Konkurrenz erarbeitet.
Man hat jetzt Pflichten die man in Deutschland ganz einfach erfüllen kann weil die Leute steigen aus dem Auto und Container.
Während die Bulgaren jetzt organisieren müssen dass ihre Fahrer die hier zu den gleichen Dumpinglöhnen reisen wie die Deutschen über die Briefkasten Umwege angestellt sind immer bis nach Hause müssen was natürlich einen unglaublichen ökonomischen Nachteil bedeutet.
Das ist wieder so ganz bezeichnend dass man nochmal mit einem rassistischen stereotyp arbeitet ja die Osteuropäer mit den Dumpinglöhnen und dort werden die Menschen schlecht behandelt und die kommen hier und wir machen hier doch die ehrliche Arbeit.
Wir haben ja diesen tollen Werbefilm am Anfang gesehen dass man es mit dieser Rhetorik schafft auch mal sofort ein Einverständnis herzustellen.
Man sagt ja klar ist aber sinnvoll dass man das mal irgendwie tut und allgemeine Standards und man ist dann immer nur im Kleingedruckten irgendwo findet was du da,
dass das eigentlich nur eine Möglichkeit ist dass man Briefkastenfirmen Regime noch effizienter gestalten kann und dann wirklich keine Konkurrenten mehr in diesen Ländern hat.
Es wird natürlich jetzt für die west und nordeuropäischen Spediteure ein bisschen teuer aber dafür ist die ganze Konkurrenz aus Osteuropa von heute auf morgen also 18 Monate übergangsfrist einfach ausgemerzt.
Das ist wirklich beachtlich und jetzt sieht man mal diesen Lobby Erfolg denn so wie die Fahrer sich eben schon fragten aber was heißt das jetzt.
Wohin hab ich denn das recht geschickt zu werden wenn ich außerhalb meiner Fahrerkabine meine Pause verbringen muss.
Und hier kommt jetzt eine Nachfrage per Skype zugeschaltet aus einem Auto funktioniert schon digital ganz gut.
Die Frage kommt glaube ich aus Bulgarien oder Ungarn aus Osteuropa und sie fragt mal genau die Frage die wir uns jetzt auch stellen.
Das eigentlich bescheuerte kommt doch auf deutsche Spediteure zu sprechen und die Antwort ist dann die typische europäische Antwort Wenn sich Lobby-Organisation mal so richtig durchgesetzt haben.
Rumänien.
European Companies.
Company Drives.
European Company Company Thank you for.
Standing,
Import.
Its not Obligation,
Freedom to you.
Really,
not for the Company,
of the.
European Companies,
German Company.
Employer.
Just want.
To.
Das ist sowas von verlogen auch dass man diese so klar brillant gestellte Frage erst einmal komplett missverstehen will und dann sagt Nein das Obligation reißt,
Recht der Fahrer das ist ja eine rhetorische.
Das ist eigentlich schon was. Trump würde wahrscheinlich ähnlich agieren.
Das ist ganz perfide. Sie fragt völlig zurecht.
Wenn der Angestellte also über eine Briefkastenfirma in Ungarn angestellt aber gehörig zu einem deutschen Unternehmen sagt Ich möchte gern nach Hause.
Wenn.
Er nach Hause sagt sie.
Dann sagt sie als Politikerin die das mitverhandelt hat. Nee das ist ja ein Recht des Fahrers.
Aber.
Die ergibt dann eine Pflicht des Spediteuren aber wir wissen alle wie es ist Man wird beim Einstellungsgespräch gefragt Wie haben Sie denn vorher an mich immer die Frage zu stellen wann sie nach Hause dürfen oder würde es ihnen auch reichen einfach hier in Duisburg untergebracht zu werden.
Haben mich.
Untergebracht zu werden nicht. Genau.
Und da entscheidet sich ob man den Typ einstellt oder nicht.
Das ist ja nun völlig Banane diese Konstellation zu finden und auf die Nachfrage hin sagt sie dann.
Diese Konstellation zu.
Sehr gute Frage und diese Details muss dann die EU-Kommission noch machen.
Machen dabei wäre das der Kern der zu klären ist.
Das ist genau das.
Das sind nicht Details 3,6 Millionen Menschen.
Hier 3,6 Millionen Menschen jetzt im Juli einfach komplett übers Ohr gehauen weil Kuroda mal nicht richtig hingeschaut hat. Würde ich so sagen.
Man kann sich genau diese rumänische Journalisten hat es verstanden.
Man kann sich schlecht in einem Lkw.
Die anderen haben es nicht verstanden oder haben es überhaupt nicht thematisiert.
Es liegt auch daran dass wir es mit einer Branche zu tun hat die von Vereinzelung geprägt ist also nicht nur sitzen alle in ihren Fahrerkabine sind.
Da ist Organisation Es gibt dann mal den einen oder anderen Lkw Protest aber mehr kommt da nicht und diese sind dann auch nicht so gut organisiert.
Die haben nicht die Möglichkeit dass sie das Ganze so bündeln können diese Aufmerksamkeit und das ist eben für solche Gesetze immer das Beste was passieren kann wenn Angestellte nicht gut genug organisiert sind,
die dann nicht gemeinsam auf die Pauke hauen können.
Auch da haben wir jetzt gesehen selbst da ist bei der Pflege relativ wenig passiert obwohl da der Fokus der Aufmerksamkeit da war.
Aber das ist vollkommen unter dem Radar.
Du hast mir das vorgestern geschrieben dass du das machst. Ich musste erst mal googlen was.
Habe ich nichts dazu gefunden und der Text war reingefallen.
Die dürfen nach Hause fahren und Pausen außerhalb nicht Pausen sondern die Pausen werden dann außerhalb des Hauses verbracht. Aber,
hier hat man mal richtig schön Vest nordeuropäischen lukrativen Markt abgeriegelt von der Konkurrenz. Und.
Die Lobbyarbeit macht. Der guckt angestrengt so als hätte er so ein schlechtes Gewissen wenn er da mal nach Google.
Da gibt's noch einiges zu finden zu diesem perfiden Streich den der hier gespielt wurde nicht gut.
Wollen wir mal was Heiteres machen wir uns ein bisschen amüsieren und zwar hab ich in die Charts geguckt. Wir sind in den Charts.
Stefan sieht es wirklich schlecht aus Platz 88 Platz 190.
Nicht ganz schlecht finde ich.
Wovon reden wir hier eigentlich. Und zwar gibt es eine neue Seite die heißt Nintendo.
Die wurde unter anderem von Rizzo kreiert er ist nicht der Geschäftsführer DJ das ist sein Kumpane und es sind noch ein paar andere Freunde Mitarbeiter von Rizzo daran beteiligt.
Ein kleines Projekt steht jetzt kein großer Konzern im Hintergrund und die haben eine Seite gemacht bei der kann man jetzt eben schauen wie man in den sozialen Medien aufgestellt ist.
Wir kommen da bei Twitter vor weil wir mehr als 10 000 Follower haben.
Und dort wird dann die Performance sich angesehen wie viel man da macht bzw.
Wie interagiert wird also Likes von Tweets Follower Anzahl und daraus wird dann so eine Summe die dann die Charts ergeben.
Dann kann sein dass du vielleicht hundert Tweets gesendet haben. Aber wenn ich dann mit einem ganz viele Likes bekommen habe dann wird das.
Erzählt Likes insgesamt auf meine Gewichtung.
Doch es gibt dann Likes und Verschiedenes wird miteinander berechnet wie kommentiert wurde was man gemacht hat.
Es geht wirklich darum dass man irgendwie messen will wie es die Interaktion und das gibt es aber nicht nur für Twitter nachvollziehen kann sondern man kann es auch nachvollziehen.
Für Instagram Twitter YouTube natürlich tektonisch ist noch drin aber da kommen wir nicht vor weil wir nicht genügend Aufrufe haben.
Bei YouTube geht es darum dass man dann 100 000 Abonnenten hat. Das haben wir jetzt nicht.
Und was soll das eigentlich bedeuten.
So erklärt das selbst hat das dann in einem Video beschrieben was sie da Tolles erfunden haben.
Ich bin Jubels weil ich kann euch endlich erzählen von einem großen großen Projekt was Tete und ich noch ein paar andere auf die Beine gestellt haben nämlich haben wir eine eigene Social Media Statistik Seite gebaut die nicht nur übelst,
geil aussieht um das einfach mal so zu sagen sondern auch eine Menge geile Features hat die es bisher weltweit noch gar nicht gibt da gibt's alle großen Plattformen also YouTube Instagram,
Twitter sogar tiptop und alles völlig umsonst und frei ohne Werbung. Einfach einfach cool.
Fallen mir persönlich an den bisherigen Statistics Social Seiten drei Features gefehlt.
Erstens Wenn ich zum Beispiel den YouTube-Kanal von irgendwem angeguckt habe und danach den Instagram Kanal von derselben Person sehen wollte dann muss ich halt wieder zurückgehen und neu Suche nach einem neuen Kanal nämlich diesem Instagram Kanal.
Und das ist ja klar denn man kann nicht mal eben so Menschen welche Kanäle zu welchem Künstler gehören.
Da muss man sehr viel per Hand da noch nach fummeln und das ist sehr sehr viel Aufwand.
Ja und den Harmos gemacht deswegen gibts bei uns also bei Nando eine Seite für jeden Künstler und da sind dann alle Kanäle drauf.
Ja und dann gibt's den zweiten Punkt in dem er beschreibt was noch gefehlt hat bei den anderen Vergleichsportalen also die zweite Sache die mich bei bisherigen statistischen Breitseiten immer genährt hat.
Die zweite Sache die mich bei bisherigen Social Statistik Webseiten immer genervt hat war das die nie wirklich sagen konnten wie guten Kanal gerade läuft.
War das nie wirklich sagen konnten wie guten Kameraden.
Ja klar da steht z.B. dann wieviel Follower Instagram Kanal hat aber zum Einen sehe ich das auch auf der Instagram Seite die Information brauch ich nicht.
Ja klar Da steht zum Beispiel ein Kamerad aber Zum einen sehe ich das auch auf der einen Seite brauche ich nicht.
Und zum Mahnern sagt das nichts darüber aus wie gut diese Kanal gerade läuft.
Und zum anderen sagt das nichts darüber aus wie gut das ist.
Es gibt ja super viele Subscriber machen keine Views machen keine leisten es gibt kein Yemen.
Es gibt keine Handlungsmacht. Es gibt keinen Nine.
Vielmehr will ich verstehen was ich meine. Viel spannender wären doch so Aussagen wie wieviel Likes macht die Person eigentlich durchschnittlich auf einem Bild oder wieviel Virus macht die Person auf einem Youtube-Video oder auf einem Tick Tock durchschnittlich. Das wären spannende Sachen.
Main. Viel spannender werden doch so Aussagen wie wie wir nix macht die Person eigentlich durchschnittlich um ein Bild oder wie viel Wirkungsmacht die Person auf einem Youtube-Video hat.
Ein tiptop durchschnittlich umspannende Tja Stefan das hat uns doch auch immer interessiert.
Aber es gibt noch etwas Drittes was diese Seite kann die dritte Sache die mir immer gefehlt hat bei diesem Social Statistin sonst sieben Seiten gute Chats gibt es nicht.
Die dritte Sache die mir immer gefehlt hat bei diesem Social Status die sonstigen Seiten gute Chats gibts nicht.
Weißt du was es gibt. Es gibt so Ja du kannst sie für Deutschland anzeigen lassen wer wieviel Subscriber hat.
Es gibt so Ja du kannst sie für Deutschland anzeigen lassen.
Wer wieviel Subscriber hat sagt nichts aus da sind tote Kanäle drin.
Haben wir schon sagt nichts aus. Da sind tote Kanäle drin.
Viel besser werden irgendwelche Charts wo jemand wer gerade im Hype ist wirklich so nach oben steigt und wenn er dann nicht mehr im Hype ist dann sinkt er wieder oder es wirklich Sachen wo sich etwas verändert.
Die User werden in welchen Charts wo jemand wer kann im halbwegs wirklich nach oben.
Und wenn wir dann nicht mehr weit ist dann sind wir wirklich Sachen wo sich was verändert.
Mir fehlt da noch ein Feature nämlich das Shitstorm. Weil das ja das Einzige was mich interessiert wäre es gerade dem Shitstorm.
Nämlich das Shitstorm und Meta Ja weil es ja eigentlich nicht einzusehen wäre es gerade einem Shitstorm stimmt.
Aber das wäre ja schon wieder inhaltlich gedacht und das ist ja etwas was wir da beobachten können ist überhaupt nicht gefragt.
Es geht wirklich nur darum Zahlen anzuhäufen zu schauen wer hat am meisten Likes der steht dann eben oben das ist dann vollkommen egal womit man das Ganze erreicht hat.
Ich möchte mal ganz kleinen Exkurs machen nur dazu dass in der Zeitungslandschaft ja auch ulkigen passiert ist in diesem Monat also einmal durfte der nur durch Twitter bekannte Julie Benedict,
einen Essay schreiben in der Welt.
Der hat ja da immer Rabatts extremistische äußerungen in schlimmster Weise wo man auch mal sagen muss Vielleicht ist das dann doch mal was auch schon für den Verfassungsschutz würde ich mal tippen.
Der durfte aber weil er ebenso laut war und weil er eben,
so viel Traffic generiert dann schon ein Essay schreiben in der Welt und der Spiegel hat sich dann auch noch dazu hinreißen lassen einen Waldspaziergang mit Attila Hildmann zu machen weil der Film auch gut klingt.
Da sieht man schon wenn inhaltliche Orientierungen keine Rolle mehr spielen und ich möchte das Wort dann doch in diesem Zusammenhang nennen wenn Werte gar keine Rolle mehr spielen dann macht man eben so etwas.
Und nach einem solchen Prinzip ist selbstverständlich dann auch so etwas aufgebaut dass man sagt Ich will jetzt hier gucken wer steigt dann hier in den Charts auf wer geht dann wieder runter.
Wer generiert dann am meisten Likes. Und das ist eine Radikalisierung dessen kann man eigentlich sagen was man ohnehin schon die ganze Zeit hat denn dort aufgelistet sind.
Ich hab das jetzt mal in Vorbereitung hier verfolgt in den letzten Tagen wenn man dann eben diese Charts aufruft es sind immer die üblichen Verdächtigen selbstverständlich ist immer ganz oben und dann kommen auch vielleicht mal zwei drei Hip-Hopper,
mit irgendetwas raus und dann gibt es auch mal die eine oder andere Person des öffentlichen Lebens die in irgendeiner Weise auch schon mal etwas,
geleistet hat im künstlerischen Sinne oder so.
Und sonst ist das wirklich ein Mehr der Schwachsinns Influencer die da jetzt nochmal weiter gepusht werden dadurch dass man ganz oben den Charts das ist ja immer nach dem Prinzip Wer hat dem wird gegeben.
So funktioniert das auch in der Aufmerksamkeits Verteilung.
Also dass es das jetzt gibt das so vor zwei Jahren feststellte oder ja eine Lücke.
Da kann man sich ja auch drüber. Warum gibt es eine Lücke. Diese Daten sind ja nun nicht geheim oder so. Diese Unternehmen haben ja selber und veröffentlichen die auch.
Klar kann man daraus dann solche Listen stricken nur wenn man jetzt streng nach Kundenwunsch geht,
sieht man ja wie das Silicon Valley das macht die haben ihre Algorithmen intern um Nutzer spezifisch aufzuschlüsseln was dir gefallen könnte und so weiter.
Also sehr viel Raffinesse auf der Soft Seite nicht so sehr auf diese harten Zahlen sondern eher auf Verhaltens Beobachtungs,
Resultate daraus herausrechnen und das dann ja so servieren als dass es aus allen Abonnements die du gemacht hast das Angebot was wir hier machen als Programm irgendwie lasse.
Die Frage ist wirklich klar man geht es auf den Listen und die Liste ist die erste die kann man sich so darüber informieren was der aktuelle Hip-Hop so bringt.
Dieser Freestyle ist doch mehr indie Hip-Hop würde ich mal sagen oder so. Leute die es auf eigene Kappe irgendwie machen oder keine Ahnung.
Nicht so ganz. Da sind schon große Namen dabei. Ein Netz prominenter halt hipper.
Also wir sehen bei Youtube genau wie bei YouTube Hip-Hop und dann sehen wir bei Instagram oh Wunder Models und Fußballer.
Models Fußballer.
Dieses typische Durcheinander und bei Twitter. Christian Drosten Rizzo Montana Bleek also auch die üblichen Verdächtigen Mario Götze.
Durcheinander bei Twitter. Christian Rossen Montana bleibt also auch die üblichen Verdächtigen Mario Götze die Frage Wozu braucht man das. Das Anliegen ist natürlich klar.
Nun ist ja wirklich die Frage Wozu braucht man das. Das Anliegen ist natürlich klar Da will ja einfach für Unternehmen die Werbe Umfelder suchen denen das Aufdröseln.
Für Unternehmen die Berge und Felder suchen denen es einmal aufdröseln.
Hören wir doch mal rein das sagt dann nämlich nur ganz am Rande die Sonne so heiteren Videos zeigen auch eine Unterseite wo wir aus Social Media Postings.
Letztes Feature was ich jetzt zeige. Wir haben auch noch eine Unterseite wo wir aus Social Media Postings Coupon Coates ziehen und die Wahrheit darstellen. Wir dachten uns Es werden jeden Tag in Social Media Postings so viele Coupon Kohtes und Rabatt kurz und so gepostet.
Sehen und die aussehen wie wir jeden Tag deswegen so viele.
Wäre doch mal gut wenn jemand sammeln würde ja bis jetzt gesammelt.
Wenn jemand.
Aber klar kostet so ein großes Projekt auch Geld und wir hoffen dass wir das auf Dauer irgendwie rein kriegen indem wir nicht ausführlichere Auswertungen Unternehmen anbieten.
Da würden sie mal gucken und mehr kommt aber eigentlich dazu nicht was aber ganz bezeichnend ist.
Das ist ja eine wichtige Plattform für Marketingleute wohl schon 14 Tage vorher Einblick gegeben dass ein großer Artikel zu Nando erschienen.
Und da geht es dann eben ganz klar darum wie wichtig das für die Branche werden könnte wenn sie dort mehr Einblicke geben.
Denn oftmals ist es ja so dass diese Seiten die es schon gibt nicht so gut sind auch wenn es einige Anbieter auf dem Markt bereits gibt und dann heißt es dann mal beim Preis liegen wir in dem Rahmen.
Die andere Statistik Plattformen anbieten für einen monatlichen Grundpreis gibt's vollen Zugang zu den Statistiken und ein Kontingent an Freischaltung.
Um auf Demographie und Kooperation einzelner Kanäle zugreifen zu können.
Es stellt sich ernsthaft die Frage Ich würde mal sagen dass hier nur Unternehmenskunden im Blick hat.
Stellt sich die Frage.
Ja aber er lanciert das so schön also eine lustige Seite wo wir uns jetzt mal alle informieren können.
Aber da fragt man sich ein bisschen genauer da fragt man sich ein bisschen warum.
Ja es gibt ja dutzende von diesen Social Media aus die auch überall integriert sind.
Also du kannst ja schon mit integrierten. Das ist ja dann auch gleich. Wer sind denn deine Leser auf deiner Seite und wie kannst du denn das Werbekunden schmackhaft machen auf deiner Seite zu werben und so weiter.
Das ist ja alles schon da nur diese Unternehmen haben natürlich aus völlig nachvollziehbaren Gründen sich auch die Frage gestellt.
Wir das noch einem allgemeinen Publikum zur Verfügung stellen und dann war die Antwort immer Nein warum denn eigentlich.
Und dieser Stand ist hier über so ein Video zu machen ist einfach nur Marketing.
Aber sonst nichts weil man kann das nützt einem gar nichts.
Die Charts ich irgendwie auf einen anklicken und dann bauen sich da irgendwelche Craven auf.
Was sagen die eigentlich Engagement 3% Blitz.
Du kannst jetzt mal alle kurz dir zu eigen machen jetzt mal richtig Geld sparen und Influencer Performance für 16 Euro kaufen literweise.
Das ist ja das Schlimmste was man tun kann.
Die ummehr schreibt dann entscheidend wird sein dass das so ist schafft auch für Unternehmen die bisher wenig oder gar keine Influenza Marketing betreiben eine Brücke zu schlagen.
Es dürfte deutlich schwieriger werden Trends von ihrem gelernten Tools abzubringen.
Das ist dann eben die Frage dass er durch seine Prominenz und durch ein Video das eine Million Mal geklickt wurde so eine Aufmerksamkeit erhält.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen gewundert dass tatsächlich die Influenza kaum darauf reagiert haben wahrscheinlich ist es ihnen dann doch ein bisschen zu transparent.
Das ist ja eigentlich genau nur darum geht eben diese Clicks anzuhäufen und für die Werbekunden dann relevant zu sein und um noch mehr Geld einzuheimsen.
Es gibt aber so zwei Reaktionen die habe ich dann doch gefunden.
In der Bunten YouTube Welt von Marius streamt der lobt das mal ganz krass.
Das kann echt sehr viel auch in der Szene ändern weil da kann sich jeder informieren wie was Turandot gerade wirklich so dass es,
einen heftigen Impakt hat auch wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Kunden sag ich mal bis Toolkit Kunden eine Firma Ich bin eine Firma.
Ich möchte jetzt Werbung machen mit einem Youtuber zusammen.
Da kann ich auf die Seite Nando und was ich sonst noch. Das gab es vorher noch nicht.
Kann einfach an einer Liste sehen welche Leute gerade relevant sind da an der Liste auch Leute raussuchen.
Aber das wär ja problematisch wenn ich einfach nur in die Liste gehe. Ich muss mir ja irgendeinen Mehrwert liefern als Kunde.
Genau.
Genau der hat es nicht so ganz verstanden. Wer aber ein kritisches Wort dazu verliert ist Trash der Macht ohne sein Gesicht zu zeigen. Let's Play Geschichten.
Viel besser werden irgendwelche Charts wo jemand der gerade im Hype ist wirklich nach oben steigt und wenn er dann nicht mehr im Hype ist dann sinkt er wieder oder es wird Sachen wo sich etwas verändert.
Ich will kein Benzin ins Feuer oder sowas. Aber alleine schon der Satz reicht mir fast schon Gänsehaut zu wissen die wenigsten haben zwei Peak und so weiter angeht.
Wie.
Es heißt allein schon zu wissen Du steigst auf ganz genau zu sehen 1 Slot bergab geht immer so sagen Lass lass das einfach Leute nicht wissen dass er versuchen mit ihrem Leben weiterzumachen.
Ich verstehe ich genau für wen das Nutzen sein soll. Momentan ja gedacht dass er jemand ist,
der auf einen Artikel antwortet der sowas schreibt wie Social Blade ist momentan so der ist so erfolgreich sowas wie Leute hört auf Statistiken. Scheiß drauf wer erfolgreich ist.
Guck mal wie geil findet dann bin ich erfolgreich wenn sie nicht erfolgreich ist scheiß drauf.
Ein bisschen enttäuscht dass da jetzt so viel Wert auf diese Klicks legt die jetzt so transparent wird dass er gedacht hat weil er sagt.
Wieso da jetzt so viel Wert auf diese Pflichtsieg sodass das jetzt so transparent wird dass er mehr da macht das jetzt auch wirklich weil er sagt dass er Videos macht die den Gefallen.
Dass er Videos macht ja wem sie gefallen dem sie gefallen dem gefallen sie doch auch anderes Kalkül dahinter ist.
Aber das sei doch das Kalkül dahinter. Und ja sicherlich wird der Druck jetzt auch nochmal auf diese Influenza und auf die YouTuber und sonstige Prominente Prominente.
Und sicherlich wird der Druck jetzt auch nochmal auf diese Influenza und auf die YouTuber und sonstige Prominente Prominente erhöht da hat er glaube ich recht.
Erhöht da hat er glaub ich recht die dann doch sich gebleicht.
Dann doch vielleicht anfangen zu gucken zu verfolgen und zu sehen wo steigen sie wo steigen sie ab.
Aber man unterschätzt da die Raffinesse der Werbebranche die Werbebranche hat ja das mit den Zahlen Das war vielleicht vor zehn Jahren oder so.
Dass es so bedeutend war das war ja auch der große Geburtsfehler des Journalismus im Netz vor 20 Jahren mit Spiegel Online dass man irgendwie dachte Na gut wir haben wir verkaufen zwar nur eine Million also vergleichsweise eine Million,
Papier Zeitung wo die Werbezeit Seite irgendwie 100 000 Euro kostet.
Aber wir haben ja online 1000 Mal so großes Publikum.
So und jetzt in Corona spätestens haben alle festgestellt Das funktioniert gar nicht beim Handelsblatt Manager-Magazin.
Diese ganze Spielgruppe ist komplett abgerückt überhaupt noch Werbung als Finanzierungsgrundlage.
Die wollen jetzt alle Paywall machen und das darüber machen und Paywall heißt eben auch.
Das heißt ja nicht dass die Werbung dann verschwindet sondern man braucht eine raffiniertere Werbung Werbung die diejenigen die eine Paywall mitnehmen also bezahlen den auch wirklich was weiterhilft.
Und dann kommt auch was für das Unternehmen das da wirbt zurück.
Man ist eigentlich bei der Werbung in den letzten zehn Jahren die Politik wie immer Vorreiter.
Wen wollen wir mit unserer Werbung so nah kommen Sie mit diesen Zahlen werden überhaupt gar nicht weit mit den Charts schon mal gar nicht.
Und wenn du dann was ich dir fällt jemand auf Instagram irgendwie,
gefällt und längst Textfeld bestimmt auch anderen die so sind wie ich will ich die Wärmemarkt haben und dann steht dann da ist Platz 783 und der Trend geht irgendwie 100 Prozent nach oben. Im letzten Monat oder sowas.
Das ist ja keine Masse mit der du arbeiten kannst sondern du musst es dann tatsächlich entweder Kontakt zu demjenigen aufnehmen auf dessen Plattform haben wir das Publikum kennenlernen und sowas das.
Nur ist die Frage ob die die die Werbebudgets vergeben auch so klug darüber nachdenken wie du dann tatsächlich sich von diesen Zahlen so fixen lassen denn wenn man mal schaut wer so was alles gerade mal irgendwo bewirbt.
Da denkt man auch nicht gerade dass da viel nachgedacht wurde ob das wirklich etwas bringt.
Zudem Auch diese Zahlen Masse gar nicht so viel aussagt.
Um ein Beispiel zu wählen was ich ganz nett und schön fand.
Samira das Twitter-Profil von Ralph Ruthe übernehmen konnte dem Comic-Zeichner der 550 000 Follower hat und sie empfahl dort dann auch den Podcast Wohlstand für alle.
Da kann man sagen eine halbe Million Menschen das war Wahnsinn aber der den das gegeben hat ist minimal. Selbstverständlich kommen dann ein paar Leute ein paar Hundert Die klicken dann mal und schauen mal was das ist.
Aber es kommen nicht eine halbe Million auch nicht hunderttausend.
Das heißt die großen Massen wo jeder irgendwie bei Twitter Jan Böhmermann oder so.
Das ist dann doch auch was folgt man so nebenbei wie man irgendwie auch nebenbei Fernseh schaut oder so.
Oft sind es kleinere Kanäle die man bewusst zeigt.
Mir fällt eher auf wenn du jetzt einen speziellen Artikel erwähnt dass ich darauf klicke und dem folge was so generell bei den üblichen Profilen so durch rauscht die so ganz groß sind bekomme ich das gar nicht so mit.
Es gibt eher so ein gezieltes folgen das da stattfindet.
Genau diese Erfahrung machen die amerikanischen Wahlkämpfers seit 2008.
Seit Obama das Haustier Wahlkampf mit der echten Gespräch unter Nachbarn mündet,
alle Ressourcen wurden eigentlich da reingesteckt sich den Gesamtmarkt der Wähler anzuschauen,
und dann zu differenzieren zwischen diejenigen lohnt sich anzusprechen und die nicht mehr und die nicht mehr komplett außen vor zu lassen keine großen Meedia Budgets irgendwie,
einen ganzen Staat wie Bloomberg das gemacht hat die komplette Fernsehwerbung zu übernehmen. Da hat man gesehen wohin das führt zu gar nichts.
Eine Stunde auf der Bühne und zack war die Kandidatur vorbei.
Trotz so viel Geld das er einfach investiert wurde und Obama hat es tatsächlich und Trump ja dann auch über seine Haustür Wahlkampf gemacht.
Man sucht sich einen schon überzeugten und stehen dann mit ein paar Nachbarschaften Wechselwähler und schickt denen dann tatsächlich rüber und es kostet unglaublich viel Geld.
So ein Gespräch um einen Wähler zu überzeugen kann durchaus mal hundert Dollar kosten oder so einer Kampagne.
Aber das ist halt Geld investiert wo man weiß Okay die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist dann dass alles ausgerechnet 87 Prozent dass diese Wählerstimmen dann auch wirklich erhalten ist während man dieses 1000 Kontakt weiß abgerechnet irgendwie,
politisch überhaupt gar keine Rolle mehr gespielt.
Da stellt man jetzt auch so in der Warenwelt oder auch jetzt wenn wir so langsam in diese Wahlen guckt man eigentlich Hamilton wenn überall der bana ist bei Spiegel Online oder so..
Da macht man es nicht. Das muss wirklich eine persönliche Empfehlung sein und die kann man hier einfach nicht rausziehen.
Und die ganzen Tools die man braucht um sich mal einzukaufen spezifisch dann geht man einfach direkt zu Twitter und Facebook und bucht dort einfach ganz regulär.
Da nützt einem dann gar nicht so eine Auswertung mit irgendwie. Klar kann man ja nur mal gucken jemand aber das.
Also ich glaube das ist zehn Jahre zu spät hatte man das vor zehn Jahren gemacht da gab es auch sowas klaut z.B.
Jeder Social Media Nutzer zum Klout Score mit k geschrieben bekommen und hat sich dann auch richtig damit könne man Gaiman sozusagen ja richtig damit spielen weil man genau wusste nach welchen Kriterien das so gemacht wird.
Aber dieses Ding ich meine.
Phänomen das Phänomen das du gerade angesprochen hast hat ja auch schon ein Buchautor geschrieben Die Granulate Gesellschaft fängt an diese Vereinzelung.
Dass diese Vereinzelung diese Entwicklung von Tür zu Tür an der Haustür wirklich irgendwas.
Von Tür zu Tür an der Haustür irgendetwas zu empfehlen.
Womit beginnt er mit dem Obama Wahlkampf und erklärt dass da sehr schön aber trotzdem nochmal diese Idee der Quote die hier nochmal so deutlich wird ist.
Womit beginnt.
Sehr schön aber trotzdem nochmal diese Quote wie hier nochmal so deutlich wird ist Fernsehen.
Die ist wirklich Fernsehen und deswegen habe ich jetzt um das Elend abzuschließen,
eine Seite eingelesen aus einem Text von Pierre Bourdieu und zwar gibt es da einen sehr schönen Band über das Fernsehen.
Und der endet wie folgt.
Man kann und muss im Namen der Demokratie gegen die Einschaltquote kämpfen.
Das scheint sehr paradox denn die Parteigänger der Einschaltquote behaupten dass es nichts Demokratisches gäbe.
Das Lieblings Argument der Zynismen unter den Anzeigenkunden und Werbeagenturen dass einige Soziologen übernehmen ganz zu schweigen von Gedanken Armen Essayisten,
die die Kritik an Umfragen und an Einschaltquoten mit der Kritik am allgemeinen Stimmrecht gleichsetzen.
Dass man den Leuten die Freiheit lassen müsse zu urteilen zu wählen bloß eure elitär intellektuellen Vorurteile Lasten euch all das als verächtlich erscheinen.
Die Einschaltquote ist die Sanktion des Marktes der Wirtschaft das heißt einer externen und rein kommerziellen Legalität und die Unterwerfung unter die Anforderungen dieses Marketing Instruments,
ist im Bereich der Kultur genau dasselbe wie die von Meinungsumfragen geleitete Demagogie in der Politik das unter der Herrschaft der Einschaltquote stehende Fernsehen trägt dazu bei,
den als frei und aufgeklärt unterstellten Konsumenten,
Markt Zwängen auszusetzen die anders als zynische Demagogen glauben machen wollen,
mit dem demokratischen Ausdruck einer aufgeklärten vernünftigen öffentlichen Meinung einer öffentlichen Vernunft nichts zu tun haben.
Und das ist kein Text von gestern sondern aus seiner Zeit. Und da gehört eigentlich auch hin.
Ich will auch noch mal ein Buch empfehlen dazu Zahlenwerke heißt das. Das kommt als ich in Bielefeld studiert habe wurde das damals von Hendrik Vollmer einen sehr guten Soziologen.
Damals noch so Nachwuchskraft heute auch irgendwo Professor und so.
Und das ist ein Sammelband wo einfach mal die Bedeutung von Zahlen im soziologischen Kontext also auch im gesellschaftlichen so eine Rolle spielt.
Da geht es um alles Mögliche das Controlling im Management Entwicklungshilfe heruntergebrochen auf die Zahlen die man so bezahlt aber was kriegt man dafür eigentlich.
Und dann eben auch ein paar theoretische Herleitung Soziologie des Sports.
Statistik kommt ja aus dem Sport wie fühlt man eigentlich ein Wettkampf bei dem man sich nie selbst begegnet und am Ende gibt's aber ein Meister.
Man spielt eine ganze Saison gegen sich nur zweimal und trotzdem weiß man es auf Platz zwei und erst auf Platz acht gelandet und das wird auch von allen akzeptiert. Also solche Sachen.
Da geht's doch ganz schön verdreht zu. So was kann ich empfehlen. Das ist ein ganz zeitloses Buch wenn auch wahrscheinlich schon zehn Jahre alt.
Aber was ja auch eine Pointe bei Bourdieus ist dass dieser Wettbewerbs Gedanke überhaupt nicht funktioniert sondern wenn man eben dieser Quote folgt und diesem Wettbewerb folgt dann hat man eigentlich eine große Vereinheitlichung.
Und das ist auch meine Erfahrung jetzt nachdem ich mir einige Tage immer mal wieder diese Seite geöffnet habe wenn man in die Charts guckt ist es eine große Vereinheitlichung da du hast es ja vorgelesen.
Also divers wird es dann schon wenn auch noch ein Fußballer drunter ist oder man Schauspieler.
Aber in der Regel sind es wirklich diese doch ziemlich austauschbaren Persönlichkeiten die irgendwas andrehen.
Intro/Outro
Apropos Zahlen.
Apropos Zahlen Ich komme zurück auf die Lebenswelt.
Zurück auf die Lebenswelt klar Das ist natürlich auch überlegenswert ist natürlich toll wenn die wie ich schon in den Top Ten sind nochmal 20 Prozent mehr.
Also klar Das ist ja natürlich auch super Lebenswelt so ist natürlich vor allem toll für die die schon in den Top Ten sind weil die jetzt alle nochmal 20 Prozent mehr damit.
Damit kann man wahrscheinlich auch Steuern in dieser übersichtsseite.
Kommt es wirklich sehr darauf an zeigen Sie die ersten 100 oder die ersten 15 Startplätze zum Beispiel oder 20 je nachdem.
Da ist dann der Bruch und dann Bruch klickt keiner.
Die ersten sieht auch bei YouTube ganz schön viel Hip-Hop. Naja andere Lebenswelt unsere Coruna Lebenswelt Wir kommen nächsten Monat da am Donnerstag Quartalszahlen des Quartals im Silicon Valley veröffentlicht werden,
und wir ungefähr wissen wie reich,
jetzt geworden sind und alle Anteilseigner nur ein kleiner Teaser,
wenn man Milliardär sein möchte.
Du kannst jetzt grob schätzen wie viel Anteil in Coma stellen bräuchte man von Amazon um schon Milliardär zu sein.
Wieviel Anteil des Unternehmens müsste einem gehören grob über den Daumen gepeilt.
Sind es dreieinhalb Prozent. Das kann ja gar nicht sein es muss ja sehr viel weniger sein.
Auf null komma null sieben.
Nur 0,8 0,3,
vollkommen okay. Ja du bist mit 0,1 Prozent sicher null komma null sieben übersteigende.
Null komma null sieben des Unternehmens also 1,7 Billionen werden und du bist mit 0,1 Prozent schon sicherer Milliardär mit null komma null sieben überschreitet die Schwelle zum Milliardär sein.
Man könnte das ganze Unternehmen Amazon in Millionen Häppchen aufteilen und dann hätte man mehr Millionäre geschaffen als Deutschland gerade Millionäre hat und unglaubliche Zahlen und es stellt sich raus.
Man könnte das ganze Unternehmen Amazon in Millionen Häppchen aufteilen und dann hätte man mehr Millionäre geschaffen als Deutschland-Plan Millionäre.
Und diese unglaubliche Zahl und stellt sich raus Amerikas Milliardäre sind zwischen dem 18. März und dem 25. Juni.
Amerikas Milliardäre sind zwischen dem 18.
März und dem 25. Juni. Nehmen wir das mal die erste Corona Hochzeit folgt ja dann für die nächste um sechs hundert acht und zwanzig Milliarden Dollar reicher geworden.
Nehmen wir das mal als erste Hauptzeit folgt ja dann für die nächste um sechs hundert acht und zwanzig Milliarden Dollar reicher geworden.
Während die ganze Wirtschaft dort zusammenbrach und die Arbeitslosigkeit irgendwie auf 20 30 Millionen Arbeitslosen Anträge,
auf mehr Frau Personenwahl arme Menschen mehr Arbeitsplätze.
Die Aktie war stellenweise bei 2800 Euro.
Ist.
Wir hatten die vorher lag die bei etwa 2000 dann ging sie als die Krise begann mal kurz runter auf 1500.
Ich weiß nicht welche verrückten da die Aktie verkauft haben damit das überhaupt passieren konnte so wie verrückt man sein muss aber ich kenne sogar eine.
Naja man will dann mitnehmen was aber dann geht es weiter.
Und,
ja und dann geht es halt immer weiter nach oben.
Es ist unglaublich. Also zum Thema Hören wir kurz Chuck Collins ist jemand der sich auskennt.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es gleich eine Bauchbinde die wir nochmal vorlesen kann. Bei Yahoo.
Das ist ja immer noch ein großes Medienhaus zugeschaltet um mal kurz zu vergleichen diese 628 Milliarden Wertzuwachs allein bei Amerikas Milliardären ist das eigentlich Geld das woanders jetzt fehlt stellt sich raus Ja.
Babyjahr.
5 Millionen Arbeitslose oder 30 Millionen wodurch plötzlich die Staaten einspringen müssen um da ein bisschen Arbeitslosengeld zu bezahlen.
Amerika selbst als Bundesstaat auf Bundesebene nochmal 600 Dollar drauf.
Und dieser Betrag der da als DLF Kona Delle kommt ist noch kleiner als der Wertzuwachs der Milliardäre.
Man könnte hier 1:1 ausgleichen und die Frage ist ein bisschen sollte man nicht.
Was hat denn der Milliardär von seinem Geld wenn um ihn herum alles auseinanderfällt. Diese Frage stellen wir uns ja schon lange beim Silicon Valley wo man mit diesen weißen Bussen die Millionäre zur Arbeit fährt und die durch die Slums fahren wo die Leute rechts und links da zelten.
Und er hat jetzt hier und deswegen euch diesen Clip mitgebracht die Ungleichheit als Vorerkrankung soziale Vorerkrankung die bei Corona dann nochmal richtig zur Krankheit auswuchs.
Und da gabs in der New York Times einen ganz wunderbaren kurzen Text zwar nicht ein bisschen länger aber wunderbar in Hinsicht.
Da kann man echt mal drauf schauen einfach Der beginnt mit einem kurzen Porträt von Flavius Todor denn der ist Krankenpflegern England aber Gastarbeiter aus Rumänien.
Und war selbst Ancona erkrankt konnte also nicht zur Arbeit.
Dem helfen anderer Menschen die erkrankt sind,
und konnte daraufhin seine Miete nicht mehr zahlen woraufhin erstmals seine Mutter Geld aus Rumänien nach England geschickt hat statt dass er auch von seinem Gehalt Geld nach Rumänien schickt zu seiner Familie hat sich sozusagen ein Geldstrom verkehrt.
Da fragt man sich ein bisschen was hat es mit diesem Geldstrom auf sich denn eigentlich fließt das Geld umgekehrt eigentlich arbeitet man ja in England und schickt dann das Geld nach Polen und Ungarn und so weiter und so fort.
Und aus diesen reichen Ländern fließt in die armen Länder eigentlich und die Weltbank Zahlen von 2019 550 Milliarden Dollar.
Also ungefähr so in dieser Dimension wie die Milliardäre die reicher geworden sind.
Das fließt üblicherweise aus den westlichen Ländern in die Entwicklungsländer 550 Milliarden Dollar durch sagen wir mal Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge die diesen regulären Weg gehen.
Das ist dreimal mehr Geld als die Entwicklungshilfe zahlt.
Man kann sehr viel mit. Das war ja auch witzig dass Merkel jetzt nachdem 2015 die Flüchtlingskrise Kamer ist ihr erstmals auch nach Afrika gereist nachdem sie schon zehn Jahre Kanzler war.
Es gibt ja auch noch Afrika da haben sich ja die Staatschefs ein bisschen komisch angeguckt weil sie mit dieser Idee dahin reiste.
Wir machen jetzt mal bessere Entwicklungshilfe und dann klappt das auch mit den Lebensbedingungen hier wollen die nicht alle flüchten und die afrikanischen Staatschefs haben sich so anguckt und meinten Entwicklungshilfe. Das ist jetzt nicht so.
Uns ist wichtiger dass unsere Leute die Flucht gelingt weil die schicken dann so viel Geld. Da könnt ihr eure Flüchtlingshilfe fünfmal abrechnen. Das wiegt das nicht auf.
Da mal ein Geldstrom der sehr viel soziale regionale Mobilität erwürgte und auch stabilisierte weil wir auch sagen müssen dass wir jetzt auch durch Coruña gelernt Wir brauchen diese billigen Arbeiter,
in England im Gesundheitssystem wie in der Fleischindustrie in der Logistik und überall Ja das ist sozusagen,
ein Status quo System das da eigentlich funktionieren sollte und jetzt durch Kona und solche Schicksale wie Flavius Tudors wurde im Juli mal ausgerechnet von der Weltbank.
Diese Beträge die nach Afrika wandern in den Mittleren Osten nach Afrika nach Asien sind um ein Viertel zusammengeschmolzen.
Also wir haben ja jetzt eine extreme soziale Notlage in diesen Herkunftsländern Es geht um 40 bis 60 Millionen Menschen die plötzlich von Armut bedroht sind weil sie in Westeuropa nicht mehr so richtig läuft.
Insgesamt sind 164 Millionen migrant workers betroffen die insgesamt 800 Millionen Menschen in diesen Regionen versorgen.
Die müssen jetzt alle mit solchen Rückschlägen um 25 30 prozent bis hin zu das aus Rumänien jetzt Geld nach England fließen.
Und da muss man sich jetzt wirklich die Frage stellen nützt es einem englischen Milliardär der in London sitzt wenn der Typ der ihn im Zweifel,
geht ja auch im Privatleben eine der ihn im Zweifel durch seine covert Erkrankung hilft,
wenn er seine Miete nicht bezahlen kann und seine Brille kaputt ist. Er kann sich keine neue leisten.
Nützt Ihnen das irgendwas oder sollte man hier nicht einfach mal einen Schalter umlegen und sagen Wir müssen jetzt einfach mal eine Umverteilung finden beispielsweise indem man sagt alle Milliardärs Gewinne und alle Dividenden die von Banken abfallen werden jetzt einfach einkassiert.
Und wir kennen diese Geldströme werden die aufrecht erhalten,
weil wir ungefähr die Konsequenzen sehen können was das bedeutet Wenn sich dann noch mehr Menschen aus diesen Familien wenn man denn auch den zweiten Sohn und vielleicht die Tochter noch losschicken muss weil das eine das Gehalt dann nicht mehr funktionieren.
Wurden im Juli Juli war jetzt mal aufgedröselt Von der Weltbank von der New York Times rapportiert was mal so als Grundstein für die nächsten zehn Jahre internationale Politik noch zu bewältigen ist.
An Zahlen. Das ist wirklich erschreckend wenn man sich das mal im Detail so anschaut.
Von den Milliardären selbst wird diese Erkenntnis nicht kommen.
Ich habe jetzt nochmal Sergio Leones Spiel mir das Lied vom Tod geguckt. Der wunderbaren Musik von Ennio Morricone und Du erinnerst Dich vielleicht.
Es gibt da ja eine Eisenbahn eine Strecke die gebaut werden soll und der Boss dieser ganzen Geschichte der,
hat so eine Art Muskelschwund Krankheit und ist kurz vor dem Tode stehend in seiner Eisenbahn sitzend dort und hat nichts anderes als Fantasie vor Augen. Es noch zu schaffen.
Ein weiteres Stück Eisenbahnschienen zu verlegen Er sitzt auf seinem Geld.
Er ist zum Mord zu allem bereit nur um noch ein bisschen mehr Schienen zu verlegen um noch ein bisschen mehr zu expandieren.
Er hat überhaupt nichts davon. Er lebt ein total unglückliches Leben weil er einsam in diesem Waggon immer nur drin sitzt.
Und dennoch lässt er nicht davon ab dass es ein sehr sehr schönes Bild dafür.
Ja und ich habe gestern noch im Deutschlandfunk.
Hat. Ich habe gestern im Deutschlandfunk. Weil sich die ARD ja selbst zerlegt mit diesem Calvins ausschlossen.
Weil sich die AfD ja selbst zerlegt mit diesem Calvins ausschloss und dann wurde auch die Frage unter den Korrespondenten hin und her gereicht.
Spalten Sie sich jetzt wurde auch die Frage unter den Korrespondenten hin und her gereicht.
Geschafft die Flüchtlingspolitik oder das Flüchtlingsthema noch zum nächsten Thema wieder zum Thema zu werden.
Schafft die Flüchtlingspolitik oder das Flüchtlingsthema nochmal zum nächsten Thema wieder zum Thema der AfD zu werden.
Wenn man dann solche Zahlen sieht dann denkt man sich uiuiui vielleicht doch jetzt schon mal ein bisschen vorarbeiten und nicht nur sich in Europa dafür feiern dass man es Kurzarbeitergeld hatte sondern nochmal so eine globale Dimension irgendwie mitdenken.
Wenn man dann solche Zahlen sieht dann denkt man nicht so wie jetzt schon mal ein bisschen Vorarbeit.
Und nicht nur sich in Europa dafür feiern dass man es Kurzarbeitergeld hatte sondern nochmal genau über alle Dimensionen irgendwie denken.
Aber wie gesagt im August kann man darauf zurück.
Aber wie gesagt im August kann man darauf zurück. Es wird ja eine große Diskussion um die Gewinne aus dem Silicon Valley geben die da am Donnerstag Jetzt vermeldet werden es ist ja morgen.
Es wird ja eine große Diskussion um die Gewinne aus dem Silicon Valley geben die jetzt verwendet werden.
Das ist ja wirklich grandios.
Die Jobs sind bedrückendes Thema. Ja ich habe nichts Freundliches.
Ich hätte als nächstes Thema ein bisschen bedrückendes Thema also wenn da noch irgendwas völlig.
Okay ein kleines bedrückendes Thema das uns im Juli auch betrifft.
Die Rechtsradikalen sind ja umtriebig Wir haben zwei Prozeßbeginn den Mord an Walter Lüpke und zum hãlle Attentat und auch im Juli am 23.
Gabs das Schulhoff Urteil das vielleicht das letzte N.s Urteil ist es gibt noch ein paar laufende Verfahren aber die Menschen sind mittlerweile so alt dass man nicht mehr genau weiß ob es noch zu einem Ende kommt oder zu dem Urteil.
Bei dem Urteil geht es um Bruno D der damals in diesem Lager der Beihilfe zum Mord an 1232 Menschen jetzt verurteilt wurde zu zwei Jahren,
auf Bewährung und zu Jugendstrafe weil er damals 17 Jahre alt war.
Hier wurde so eine juristische Geschichte vielleicht abgeschlossen.
Man weiß nicht genau aber es gilt so als das letzte Urteil das jetzt zu erwarten war.
Und neu sind eben diese Urteile von Verbrechen begangen worden.
Da ist zum Beispiel der Mord an Walter Lüpke und da müssen wir es mal kurz mit den zwei Tätern.
Aber wir haben es ja auch immer mal wieder behandelt.
Diese ganzen Sachen die aus dem Silicon Valley kommen das Capitol YouTube selbst Radikalisierung und so weiter.
Das heißt dann doch so eine Lebenswelt ist die die Menschen mehr prägt als das was sie auf der Straße so erleben.
Und es ist wirklich schlimm das zu lesen. Im Tagesspiegel heißt zum Mord an Walter Lybke der mutmaßliche Täter hat sein Geständnis auf Video aufgezeichnet noch einmal vorgeführt bekommen.
Im Gerichtssaal sagt er danach wohl rapportieren als Zitat Es tut mir unendlich leid was ich getan habe dass ein Mensch sterben musste weil er die falschen Worte gesagt hatte.
Das suggeriert ja Walter Lübke stand vor diesem Publikum hat gesagt Wer das nicht mag kann ja Auswandern.
Und daraufhin das wäre sozusagen der Anlass gewesen weshalb Stefan Ey oder Stefan Ernst Nein ernst jedenfalls.
Der mutmaßliche Täter zu dieser Tat schritt er meinte Nee gegen solche Leute muss man jetzt mal Erbs Ernst behauptet nämlich jetzt einen neuen Tathergang.
Beide Ernst und der Typ der ihm die Waffe besorgt hat sie hätten sich ihm genähert.
H. habe die Waffe gezogen den Hahn gespannt und gerufen so Lübke Zeit zum Auswandern.
Also wieder ein Bezug auf diesen Spruch den man aus dem Video kennt er Ernst habe einen Lüpke gerichtet hinzugefügt wie so was für so wie dich gehe ich jeden Tag arbeiten.
Es wirkt ja so als wäre der Beschuldigte der Ernst Dingsbums sozusagen angestachelt durch diesen Spruch von Walter Lübke und motiviert durch.
Ich arbeite hier doch nicht für dich. Also nicht so sehr.
Ich bin überzeugter Nazi sondern mir geht es um mein Geld oder was aus eigenen Motiven statt aus politischer Ideologie als hätte er so gehandelt.
Und das ist tatsächlich eine perfide Verdrehung der Tatsachen für den Fall dass es gelogen ist dass er jetzt einfach vor Gericht ist und verstecken möchte dass er aus Ideologie und politischem Antrieb gehandelt hat.
Und dann gibt's eine zweite Dimension in dem Fall. Der hatte nämlich zwei Pflichtverteidiger bekommen und der eine davon überdehnen schreibt ja das neue Deutschland.
Grandios. Beängstigend. Hanning heißt er Zitat Hanning hatte einerseits einen Einbruch ins Regierungspräsidium Kassel kurz vor dem Mord an Walter Lybke mit der Arbeit von dessen Söhnen in Verbindung gebracht.
Der Typ steht vor Gericht und sagt Ich möchte hier behaupten ich hätte aus persönlichen finanziellen Motiven im Sinne von Ich will nicht dass die Ausländer hier. Aber ich bin gar kein ideologisch.
Ich habe sozusagen aus niederen Beweggründen in der Hinsicht.
So hat er einen Anwalt der ihn vor Gericht noch konterkariert mit dem mit einem Antrag den er stellt man solle sich doch mal angucken was die Söhne von Walter Lübke gemacht haben vielleicht gibt es da einen Zusammenhang,
weil die beiden führen zusammen eine Photovoltaik Firma und bei diesem Einbruch im Regierungspräsidium,
könnten Akten über diese Firma gestohlen worden sein meinte Hanning der Anwalt.
Er vermute hier ein mögliches Motiv für den Mord an Lübke.
Die Verteidigungsstrategie des Anwalts war plötzlich abgesprochen mit dem mutmaßlichen Täter es könnten doch auch die Söhne sein.
Da gibt doch auch so eine Motivlage die man mal ausarbeiten müsste. Daraufhin hat Kaplan Mustafa Kaplan der zweite Pflichtverteidiger interveniert.
Kaplan intervenierte Hanning wolle den Söhnen Lübkes krumme Machenschaften nachsagen Ernst liege es fern den Toten oder seine Angehörigen mit Dreck zu bewerfen.
Im Namen von Ernst distanzierte er sich von den Anträgen.
Der mutmaßliche Täter von Walter Lübke hat einen Anwalt zur Seite bekommen der sich vor Gericht so krass verhalten hat dass er selbst die mutmaßlichen Täter des Mordes an Walter Lüdke nicht über die Stränge schlug woraufhin er ein Entbindungen Antrag stellte und der Richter meinte Ja,
ich kann das nachvollziehen dieser Anwalt muss sich nicht weiter verteidigen.
Er hat dann auf Twitter kursierte dann so der Spruch im Sinne von Wenn er als Nazi Mörder selbst ein Anwalt so krass ist irgendwas schief in Deutschland. Und das muss man hier mal.
Diese Art und Weise. Der Typ hat dann diese Hanning hat jeden Tag ein Prozess Video gemacht.
Er hat sich selber nach dem Prozess vor sein Handy gehangen und hat ein YouTube-Video aufgenommen um davon zu berichten.
Und hier sieht man dann auch mal ich habe mal einen Ausschnitt aus dem allerersten Video des,
das erste Video was der Typ am ersten Prozesstag macht also jeden Tag eins gemacht aber es ist das erste Video von diesen fünf Prozesstagen die er als Anwalt tätig war.
Und wir hören die allererste Idee die ihm wichtig war per Video an die öffentlichkeit zu geben.
Mein erster Eindruck von dem Verfahren ist um ehrlich zu sein eher erschütternd gewesen.
Es ist ein Verfahren das eine hohe Medienöffentlichkeit erreichen wird das ist ein Verfahren das politisch wichtig ist dass einer aufgeheizten Stimmung stattfindet Es ist ein Verfahren so wirft man es meinen Mandanten ja zumindest vor,
dass das erste Mal ist dass aus rechtsradikalen rechts motivierten politischen Gründen ein Politiker ermordet worden sein soll.
Ob das so ist wird das Verfahren zeigen aber es ist ein Verfahren das einen hohen Stellenwert für unsere Entwicklung als Gesellschaft und auch für die Rechts Fortbildung haben wird.
Und dieses Verfahren beginnt mit frierenden Journalisten die unter Regenschirmen und in Schlafsäcken die Nacht auf dem Fußboden liegen vor dem Gerichtsgebäude verbringen und so alle Ironie unter dem in Stein gemeißelten Schriftsatz am Gerichtsgebäude die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar.
Das hat mich erschreckt und das ist eines Rechtsstaates in meinen Augen unwürdig.
Ein schlechter Auftakt für ein Verfahren das eine große öffentliche Bedeutung haben wird.
Man kennt das Phänomen dass Angeklagte das Verfahren diskreditieren um den Schuldspruch am Ende ein bisschen abzuschwächen.
Aber dass ein Anwalt selbst händeringend nach Themen sucht mit denen man jetzt so ein Verfahren diskreditieren kann indem man selbst beteiligt ist das ist schon neu.
Ehrlich gesagt war sehr ungewöhnlich und sehr erschreckend diese YouTube-Videos die er hier produziert hat indem er selber sagt Das wird ein Verfahren das sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit vielleicht auch für mich bedeuten.
1500 bis 2000 Views also jetzt nichts was irgendwie.
Aber dass er selber mit diesen Anträgen kam um die Familie in Misskredit zu bringen die Familie,
hat dann eben tatsächlich dafür dass Mustafa Kaplan dann meint YouTube-Videos hat der Typ nichts beigetragen und er hat auch keine Strategie für den Angeklagten entwickelt sondern ist tatsächlich auf einer Bühne.
Ist er ein unbeschriebenes Blatt Papier oder kannte man den schon vorher.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe auch nichts lesen können dazu was mich ein bisschen wundert ist dieser Verweis auf die Journalisten das hat man ja immer wieder bei großen Prozessen das dort lange Warteschlangen sind irgendwie versuchen da reinzukommen.
Er weiß gar nicht richtig was er machen will aber man sieht er hat wirklich diese Idee.
Kommen sie damit richtig was sie machen will aber man sieht er hat wirklich diese Idee.
Eine Prominenz zu bekommen und dann wahrscheinlich dass sich so viele am Ende nicht für diesen Prozess interessieren werden und dass er wahrscheinlich auch nicht der charismatische Anwalt gewesen wäre das hätte funktionieren können. Youtube-Star.
Diese Videos da gibt es dann fünf muss man echt nicht angucken ist nichts Interessantes dabei.
Ich wollte nur mal darstellen diese Prozesse werden immer so als Bühne genutzt und üblicherweise sind das immer das können wir so dass,
die Täter selber das so als Bühne nutzen und dann immer mit Zeichen und Gesten im Gerichtssaal agieren und so weiter.
Das haben wir hier beim Fall Walter Lüpke zumindest nicht. Er wollte es wahrscheinlich so in die Richtung drehen den Prozess zu einer großen Sache zu machen.
Allerdings muss man hier auch nochmal die Mediengeschichte von diesen ganzen ist wirklich nicht ohne und ich meine ist nicht die Mediengeschichte.
Was haben die großen Massenmedien so gemacht sondern Wie kam es dazu.
Wie haben sich die radikalisiert. Und wie kam es zu diesem Videoclip der online so bekannt wurde,
dass dann alle die hörten Walter Lückerath Das war doch der mit diesem Video war meinte die sollen doch ausreisen und da es noch eine Geschichte die jemand vor Ort erzählt hat nämlich ein Fotograf von dieser Veranstaltung,
der dieses ganze beteuern im Nachhinein er hätte das nicht sagen sollen dann wäre ich auch nicht so ausgerastet oder so. Denn da noch einmal die Luft rausnehmen.
Nee das ist nicht nur große politische Ideologie sondern eben auch Strategie dahinter.
Weiter Lübke informiert über eine geplante Flüchtlingsunterkunft im Publikum Stephan und Markus H..
Zwei Neonazis Film und Lübkes Rede verkürzt ins Netz.
Wie mittlerweile bekannt ist waren die folgenden Buh-Rufe. Stefan Ey und Marcus H.
Und Marcus H. filmte die Szene mit seinem Handy. Diese Fotos von der Veranstaltung hat der Fotograf Kurt Heldmann gemacht. Er meint es sei eine geplante Aktion von Neonazis und Rechtspopulisten aus Kassel gewesen die sich unter das Publikum gemischt hätten.
Eine größere Gruppe sagt genau gegenüber dem Rednerpult andere darunter Stefan Ernst und Margot H.
Weiter hinten im Saal und wieder andere in der Mitte so dass aus unterschiedlichen Stellen immer wieder diese Rufe kamen.
Das war so als würde darauf gewartet dass Walter Lübke gegen ihn verwenden kann.
Diesem Mord geht eine Eskalation eine mediale Eskalation voraus provoziert für diejenigen die tatsächlich ihn ermordet haben.
Und man sollte sich diese Fotos von Kurt hält man mal ansehen. Das sieht auch wirklich nach einem sehr heterogen geeinten Publikum aus nur um das mal so zu sagen. Es sieht tatsächlich so aus.
Jetzt wo man gerade mal so einen Ausschnitt gesehen hat als hätte man da absolut recht dass da sich im Saal verteilt haben die sie nämlich nicht so aus wie die anderen.
Das ist so dass man wirklich ein bisschen sieht ach guck mal was machen hier eigentlich bei dieser Veranstaltung da.
Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt wie das Verfahren da weitergeht nachdem die Anwaltskammer geklärt sind und die Befangenheitsanträge an die Richter auch soweit erledigt sind scheint es da doch einiges aufzuarbeiten zu geben.
Denn klar die Rolle des Täters ja immer.
Aber wir wissen spätestens seit Christ Church dieser Inselstadt Bewegung und so weiter dass es da eine gewisse Motivations Struktur medial und einfach gibt und die zeigt sich zum Beispiel bei diesem Attentat ganz deutlich.
Da gibts Medien Meldung vom Prozess nach Haller Attentat Doppelpunkt Angeklagter gesteht Opfer erschossen zu haben. Anders als bei dem Mann.
Ich habe es gestanden aber es war doch der andere und Stefan B. will den Prozess als Bühne nutzen es ganz klar wo man sich den ersten Prozesstag anguckt und sich fragt Was können wir drüber schreiben. Oder wird das als Bühne nutzen.
Er kommt da rein und macht seine Zeichen und macht dann halt den ganzen Kram und man tut sich tatsächlich sehr schwer die Sache in Halle dann vor Gericht ordentlich aufzuarbeiten denn es gibt sehr viele Nebenkläger im Grunde.
Diese Sache habe ich auch noch nicht ganz durchschaut wann man Nebenkläger wird weil bei Mord ist ja immer der Staat als Staatsanwalt tätig wird aber als beispielsweise,
Angehörige von Mordopfern oder bei Zeugen oder sonst irgendwie kann man in Rolle des Klägers kommen der dann auch.
Berechtigt ist da in den Prozess einzugreifen beispielsweise mit Fragen oder so. Und das scheint doch das eine oder andere Hindernis da anzugeben.
Insgesamt zeige die Verhandlungen dass sich nicht nur die Nebenkläger mit dem Angeklagten schwertun sagt Nebenklage Anwalt Erkan Gergely.
Nebenklägern.
Die Verteidigung hat aber das Pech dass der Angeklagte das als seine Bühne nutzt und als sein Kampf nutzt. Und deshalb tun sich viele Nebenkläger Vertreter auch schwer Fragen zu stellen weil das dazu führt dass man den Angeklagten Stefan B.
Schwer Fragen zu stellen weil das dazu führt dass man die.
In gewisser Weise befriedigt denn er würde seine Brüder ausgeweidet.
Das scheint ja so zu sein als ob diese Leute in dem Falle der Angeklagte hier die Tat selber in so einem langen Prozess hegt.
Einfach für sich und sagt Der gehört halt dann die Gerichtsverhandlung und meine anschließende Haft dazu.
Und trotzdem geht meine Mission hier natürlich weiter.
Nur weil die sagen es ist jetzt ein Mordprozess Für mich ist das natürlich jetzt politische Bühne.
Diese Typen werden ja auch immer hin und her geflogen steigen aus dem Hubschrauber aus werden dann dahin Scotia dann geht es Gerichtsverhandlung los.
Die Angehörigen sind irgendwie da und sah gar keine Reue oder sowas sondern es wird komplett genutzt die Situation und diese Gemengelage wurde hier bei Frontal 21 wirklich nochmal wunderbar kurz zusammengefasst.
Das ist im Grunde so ein Fernsehberichte also ein bisschen wie so ein Fernsehbericht daherkommt aber es fallen sozusagen alle Schlagworte die an die ganzen Silicon Valley und Capitol Aufarbeitung bisher anschließen.
Die Ermittler entdecken den Ball jetzt Stadtauto auch einen USB-Stick mit Videos des US Radiomoderator Alex Jones ein bekannter Rassist und Verschwörungstheoretiker.
Jones gilt als Vertreter der sogenannten Insel Bewegung im Internet.
Das sind unfreiwillig enthaltsam Männer die Frauen hassen.
Das sind Gruppierungen die letztlich aus radikalisierten frustrierten jungen Männern bestehen die,
zur Gewalt gegen Frauen aufrufen weil sie sich von ihnen um Sex betrogen und verraten fühlen.
Laut Anklage sind in dieser Internet Subkultur Gleichgesinnte deren Hass richtet sich auch gegen Moslems und Juden gegen Männer die von Frauen angeblich bevorzugt werden. Das Resultat Mord Fantasien.
Diese Bewegung sieht der Verfassungsschutz auch für Deutschland als Gefahr.
In einer internen Einschätzung heißt es der politische Charakter dieser Bedrohung wird darin deutlich dass die Attentate nicht nur Ausdruck einer individuellen Störung sind die in Amok Taten mündet,
sondern explizit darauf zielen Nachahmer zu inspirieren und die auf verschiedenen rechtsextremistischen Plattformen herbeigesehnte,
Rebellion loszutreten.
Jahrelang radikalisiert sich bald im Internet ohne direkten Kontakt zu Gleichgesinnten.
Jetzt braucht es nur noch einen Funken oder ein Vorbild um ihn zur Bluttat zu bewegen.
Der Attentäter von Christ Church in Neuseeland im März 2019 ist laut Anklage für ihn der Täter streamt seine Morde in zwei Moscheen live ins Netz.
Der mutmaßliche Attentäter von Halle stellt sich in eine Tradition von Terrorakten die seit 2018 ungefähr,
schwerpunktmäßig 2009/10 von Rechtsextremen international verübt worden sind.
Und was eine neue Dimension dieser Tat ist ist natürlich dass er sich auf Englisch an ein internationales Publikum,
gewandt hat und dass er seine Tat live übertragen hat im Internet zurück zum Prozess.
Über fünf Stunden wurde Baird heute befragt. Stundenlang hat er seine wirren Theorien dargelegt.
Selbst für einen den Ballette am 9. Oktober 2019 ermorden wollte klingt vieles davon lächerlich.
Er hat muslimische Einwanderer in Deutschland und Juden für alles verantwortlich gemacht was in seinem kleinen Dorf so passiert ist.
Aber als er gefragt wurde was die ihm denn getan haben da fällt ihm nur ein drei Tage vor dem Anschlag hat mich jemand im Zug angerempelt.
Wie soll man sagen.
Da haben wir wieder diesen Kontrast Wirklichkeit auf die er angesprochen wird da ist er mal angerempelt worden.
Mediale Wirklichkeit eine vollkommen andere.
Und diese Radikalisierung im Netz die dann stattgefunden hat die.
Auch nochmal deutlich dass wir in einem medialen Zeitalter leben was nicht einfach meint Wir haben viele Medien.
Auch noch einmal deutlich macht dass wir in einem medialen Zeitalter leben was nicht einfach meint Wir haben viel Medien sondern da ist das eigentliche Geschehen auch und dort findet auch das Leben wenn man so will statt.
Da ist das eigentliche Geschehen auch dort findet auch das Leben wenn man so will statt dass es für sie dann tatsächlich nicht so entscheidend dass er jetzt hinter schwedische Gardinen wandert dass er dort.
Deswegen ist für ihn dann tatsächlich nicht so entscheidend dass er jetzt hinter schwedische Gardinen wandert dass er dort in einem Prozess involviert ist sondern er ist.
In einen Prozess involviert ist sondern ist.
Da er ist medial permanent präsent und damit das genügt quasi.
Das ist mehr wert als einfach so präsent zu sein.
Er hatte vor vom Gericht vor allem durch zwei Sachen aufgefallen an diesem Eröffnungstag nämlich zum einen,
weil die Richterin immer zu den Waffen gefragt und er hat die Frage gar nicht hinsichtlich verwendet sondern er hat immer das Werturteil wie es ja das ist eine besonders gute Waffe.
Also kann man richtig gut ja das war richtig gut dass sich die dabeihatte die Aufklärungsarbeit was hast du denn dabeigehabt war immer gleich.
Eigentlich wollte das am liebsten ins Forum schreiben womit die anderen jetzt losziehen sollen. So war das ja auch bei dem Attentäter.
Und das andere ist er war die eigene Tat peinlich weil sie so misslungen ist.
Er kam nicht durch diese Tür durch hat dann frustriert zwei andere Menschen erschossen und es sah dass er da sozusagen nicht verwandeln konnte und deswegen schämt er sich auch so ein bisschen vor der Community.
Aber nicht ausweichen kann nur diesen harten Hund irgendwie gibt dieser dieser Fall in Halle der jetzt in Magdeburg verhandelt wird.
Und was der Experte von der Stiftung Antonio Amadeo Stiftung noch sagte ist ja auch etwas das auf Englisch stattgefunden hat.
Wir haben es wirklich mit einem globalen Netzwerk von Rechtsextremismus zu tun und Rechtsextremismus meint zum einen selbstverständlich Blut Boden Ideologie die in,
einen radikalen Nationalismus,
sich ausdrückt oder Regionalismus zum Teil auch.
Aber man ist auch global miteinander vernetzt was in gewisser Weise eigentlich gegen diese Blut und Boden Ideologie steht.
Man baut sich so ein Geflecht auf wie sie in ihren Verschwörungstheorien ja immer von anderen solchen einflechten ausgehen wo sie dann sagen Ja da gibt es so arabische.
Ligen die haben eigentlich die Welt unter Kontrolle.
Oder die antisemitische Variante Das haben Juden alles unter Kontrolle.
Sie bauen tatsächlich Netzwerke auf und agieren dann,
mit US amerikanischen radikalisierten zusammen mit der Australian ja auch das ist ja auch immer bei der sogenannten Identitären Bewegung zu sehen woher dann Gelder geflossen sind.
Und da zeigt sich auch dass wir da auch eine Globalisierung erleben.
Nur wirklich von der finstersten Seite Man kann das ja bei der sogenannten Identitären Bewegung sehr schön nachvollziehen wie gut sie verteilt ist auch alleine in Europa dass sie erst mal von Frankreich aus kam dann nach österreich Deutschland ging obwohl sie ja,
inzwischen ja ziemlich marginalisiert ist oder sich selbst auch marginalisiert hat.
Aber das ist echt ganz ganz extrem. Welche Querverbindungen sind und wie.
Das wundert mich dann auch immer als jemand der von linker Theorie geprägt ist wie Eklektizismus.
Diese Leute sind das die sich das sind zunehmend auch Inseln noch dabei und das ist ja höchst widersprüchlich diese einzelnen Verschwörungstheorien auch und die einzelnen ideologischen Ansätze.
Aber irgendwie passt es dann doch zusammen.
Es geht nicht darum dass man sagt Na ja ist denn dieser marxistische Ansatz wirklich in sich ganz schlüssig wie das jetzt ein linker Theoretiker denken würde.
Sondern hier geht es dazu das nehmen wir auch noch hinzu das für mich ja nach wie vor Verrückteste war ja weil ich da auch erst jetzt aufmerksam wurde durch Coruna ist diese,
Verschwörungstheorie noch gehalten und die Reichen nehmen deren Blut.
Das ist für mich alles so absurd aber auch das geht dann auch noch irgendwie mit rein denn das ganze.
Kühnen hat es ja auch schwer getroffen jetzt im Juli. Die können auf Twitter nicht mehr verlinkt werden und mehrere Tausend Accounts die damit zu tun haben wurden einfach mal gelöscht das ist natürlich,
erst mal so eine Notfall lock down Maßnahme aber da muss jetzt auch qualitativ mal nachgearbeitet werden. Im Silicon Valley.
Wie gesagt Das stimmt. Augusttagen Großthema denn die Nachwirkungen sind da da und der Wahlkampf beginnt da.
Und deswegen kommen wir am Ende nochmal nach Amerika und Vergleichen mal wir gucken wieder nach China und auch nach Amerika.
Wir vergleichen mal Portland und Hongkong.
Es waren ja zwei Städte in denen es im Juli mal richtig zur Sache ging.
Das eine ist in Portland in Portland sind plötzlich Soldaten Polizisten oder sowas aufgetaucht.
Die Demonstrationen in der Hinsicht aufgestockt haben dass sie einfach Menschen entführt haben.
Da ist so ein Lieferwagen oder so ein kleiner werden vorgefahren dann sprangen drei Menschen in T-Shirt oder Uniform raus man wusste gar nicht was das für welche Polizeistation jedenfalls nicht drauf hat.
Eine Waffengattung Militärmaschine auch nicht zugeordnet und die haben einfach Menschen aufgegriffen haben Die eingepackte sind davongefahren.
Fragte man sich ein bisschen was ist los in Amerika. Eine Entführung auf offener Straße.
Stellt sich heraus Nee das sind von Trump beauftragte Beamte von Homeland Security vom Department of Homeland Security.
Da hat man irgendwie Paragrafen gefunden der sich taugt präsidiale Bürgermeister Rechte die man eigentlich nur in Washington D.C.
Hat auch in anderen Städten zum Zwecke der Terrorbekämpfung. Es geht zurück auf den Patriot Act und es ist völlig hanebüchen was da vor sich gefallen ist und wir hören hier mal kurz wie das Weiße Haus.
Argumentiert warum man das jetzt machen kann als Weißes Haus.
Tja man hat einfach mal geguckt in den Paragrafen und dann stand da drin.
Jaja die vom Department of Homeland Security können ja in jeder andere Polizeibehörde einfach mal Leute schicken die dann im Bauauftrag aus Washington aber mit der Zuständigkeit der lokalen Behörden einfach tätig werden können.
Und wenn die sehen da ist irgendwas dann fahren die halt hin.
Man fragt sich Wie geht das nicht doch ein bisschen weiter und es ist natürlich alles Wahlkampf weil Trump möchte diese demokratischen Städte in Misskredit bringen.
Portland Chicago überall wo die widerspenstigen Demokraten regieren zeigen Wenn ihr ein Demokrat ins Weiße Haus wählt dann sieht es überall aus wie in diesen Ländern.
Und noch bevor er jetzt in die Tat umgesetzt hat im Juli hat er am Ende Juni Klapse 26. Juni.
Trump selbst hat da Town Hall mäßig erzählt blablabla wie sein Wahlkampf aussehen soll und das ist natürlich noch die große Gesundheits Revolution kommt noch bis zur Wahl.
Und da hat er dieses kleine Snippets drin gehabt. Trump vergleicht hier mal demokratische Städte mit Ausländern mit Ländern auf der Welt in denen es nicht gut ausgeht.
Chicago ölzweig Afghanistan.
Honduras Guatemala.
Honduras,
Fahrpreises.
Auckland Baltimore.
Es ist unglaublich. Er entschuldigt sich noch bei Honduras dass er jetzt diesen Vergleich zu der amerikanischen Stadt zieht.
Das ist aber eine Rhetorik die wir ja weil wir über rechtsextreme sprachen dort genauso finden können dass man immer imaginiert.
Wir haben eigentlich den Bürgerkrieg und jetzt müssen wir uns auch selbst befragen wie wir diese Bürgerkriegs Szenarien ausgemalt werden.
Jede Regionalzeitung gab es in den vergangenen Jahren jetzt mehr Sicherheit damit nicht so viele Einbrüche da sind weniger Kriminalität. Die Statistiken sagen ja ganz deutlich Die Kriminalität ist zurückgegangen.
Und dennoch verkaufen sich diese Geschichten und das weiß jedes Verlagshaus unglaublich gut wenn man so Thema Sicherheit. Alles wird immer ungewisser.
Kann ich mich überhaupt noch raus trauen dann gibt es auch mal hin und wieder Vorfälle.
Wir sind 83 Millionen da passiert mitunter was dann wird aber gleich das als Anlass genommen.
Wir fühlen uns aber auch schon lange nicht mehr sicher.
Wir leben in einer katastrophalen Welt. Draußen ist es dann wirklich so dass man dann sagen kann Ja stimmt da bin ich mal angerempelt worden.
Der mutmaßliche Täter sagte aber die Wirklichkeit im Netz sieht dann so aus dass man in gebündelter Form die ganze Zeit den Ausnahmezustand präsentiert bekommt.
Es gab von der Sprecherin tatsächlich eine Pressekonferenz am 26. Juni. Da hat sie hinter sich zwei Bildschirme stehen gehabt und dann haben sie einen Zusammenschnitt der Riads mit dem Weißen Haus Logo oben und so gesendet.
Gesendet wurde von den Journalisten gezeigt und es hat sich kein Sender bereiterklärt das Video zu übernehmen weil es einfach zu blöde war weil die genau gesehen haben.
Wenn man das kleine Feuer von unten so filmt und der Polizist dahinter Volkhard dann sieht das aus wie der Mega Ride und so weiter.
Aber es war quasi allen Sendern zu blöd das zu senden so die haben. Man sieht ja schon.
Man hat sich in hanebüchener des Gesetzes Dinge nochmal so eine kleine Ecke die man irgendwo fand auf Seite 17 gesucht um es so juristisch zu legitimieren es dann zu machen.
Der Widerstand in den Städten ist natürlich da auch der juristische aus den Verwaltungen heraus dem Bürgermeister.
Das heißt wir haben es sowieso mit so einem.
Also mit einer medialen Aufarbeitung von Rytz auf der einen Seite weißes Feuer zu sehen und Polizisten werden auf der anderen Seite werden.
Ich weiß nicht genau wie groß die Dimension ist also wie viel Energie,
Personal darum ist wieviel Leute da entführt wurden und was dann mit denen passiert. Es kann ja auch wirklich nur für die Kamera gemacht sein mit Trump zu zeigen was das ist.
Das sehen wir mal wie sich das so entfaltet.
Aber wir haben es genau wie da kann man wirklich das Thema anschließend mit diesem.
Es gibt die Realität und dann gibts die Medien dazu und dieser Wahlkampf und es ist so verrückt weil in diesen Städten selber kann Trump nichts gewinnen.
Portland Oakland Chicago Das sind alles Städte die sind demokratisch regiert.
Da braucht er gar keinen Wahlkampf machen sondern er nutzt die nur als Kulisse um für die Vorstadt Menschen die aber auch schon verloren hat für den Wahlkampf zu machen.
Alle Beteiligten in Videos sind reine Kulisse für einen Wahlkampf der nur medial stattfindet da wo er ankommen soll weil die Leute nicht in die Stadt das sind tausende Kilometer weg und da wo er halt seine Siege einschränken will.
Wir haben es ja mit ganz perfide im Wahlkampf zu tun und er glaubt tatsächlich aber da liegt halt eine Strategie drin wenn er dann über seinen Kontrahenten Joe Biden in diesem Gespräch so redet.
And,
run bei,
Tax Destroy a country.
Als würde er sich die Argumentation gegen ihn die überall gängig ist nochmal zu eigen machen oder über den anderen zu sein der ist ja irre und er wird von lauter verrückten beraten.
Das ist dieser Wahlkampf ist ein bisschen schade dass sich das jetzt so auf der Straße so gewalttätig darbietet.
So jedenfalls das ist jetzt Portland und man könnte jetzt eine Klammer drum schließen und sagen Zum Glück ist Trump einfach inkompetent.
Sonst ging es da ganz anders zu in Amerika Man stelle sich mal vor der Typ mit so einer Haltung wäre auch noch intelligent und würde sozusagen die Möglichkeiten wirklich mal nutzen.
Und da hat sich doch jetzt in Hongkong einiges getan im Juli. Es gab nämlich die Annektion von Hongkong sagen wir mal.
Man hat einfach gesagt Das ist jetzt zwei Systeme ein Land das haben wir jetzt auf und ich will es zum Abschluss mal in.
Es waren ursprünglich 25 Minuten ich es mal auf 7 Minuten 5 zusammen gekürzt weil es wirklich eine ganz hervorragende journalistische Aufarbeitung von The Daily Podcaster New York Times ist.
Sie haben sich entschieden es im Gespräch zu klären. Der Typ als Korrespondent vor Ort erzählt einfach mal wie es so ist.
Ich habe mal die wichtigen Sachen rausgenommen weil klingeln auch.
Also kann man einfach abhaken was es da geht man versteht es sehr gut und es gibt keine Zwischentöne außer so ein bisschen Sound von der Straße die man so eingespielt hat aber jetzt kein großes Story Bilder irgendwas mit tausend,
Sachen herbeigewünscht da würde ich mal im Gespräch geklärt Wie geht eigentlich,
ein kluger Staatschef mit einem funktionierenden Apparat der mit dem Problem um. Ich habe da eine Stadt nicht unter Kontrolle.
Wie mache ich das eigentlich.
Aber es ist Zeit.
Duelle Frauen Hongkong really care selbes passender des National britischen Boesen.
Ist Asien einer,
Demokratie. Singapur.
Hongkong Herr Triaden verehrte Serpentine.
Hongkong Passantinnen,
wenn man überhaupt eine Siebzehnjährige Geschichte Es gab schon mal den Versuch ein bisschen zu beschleunigen was die Briten da als 50 jährige übergangsfrist geplant hatten.
Topas,
Farhang.
Und dann es hier um die folks diesen großen Parteitag in Peking auch Kona Monat verschoben werden muss,
da oben wurde das aufgehangen damit für alle klar ist dieses neue Sicherheitsgesetz das ist nicht die lokale Verwaltung die irgendwas plant sondern das ist jetzt unserer 17 Jahre alte Idee die wir sozusagen legitimiert über den Volkskongress selbst gesteuert haben.
Politiker sind.
Breve.
Mal.
Eines Tages sind deutsche Terroristen.
Also genau das Gegenteil von dem was Damp gemacht hat nicht irgendwie Wir haben noch so eine Zeile gefunden die uns irgendwie ermächtigt aber müssen die Gerichte mal überprüfen sondern es gibt jetzt ein neues Gesetz Wir sagen euch aber noch nicht worum es geht sondern wir schreiben erst mal die Themen rein und dann klingelt es bei allen gerade auch im,
Rückblick auf diese Demonstration vor Coruna die Seite in Hongkong.
Vorankommen,
war.
Klar,
dass.
Keiner.
Die.
Böning.
Das war aber eine sehr schöne suggestive Frage Wussten die in Peking was sie da machen indem sie das so undeutlich formulieren und alle im Unklaren lassen ja.
Beide sein.
Charming.
Hongkong.
Lettin Hong Kong laut.
So das Kalkül des.
Da
Ist,
ja irgendwie gesagt.
Webseiten Hacking,
PM
Salärs.
Croix.
Ist das eine oder.
Andere Mal.
In Hong Hongkong hätte es eine,
andere Meinung der Performance Empfangschef.
China Hongkongs.
Polsters,
in
der Lage sind im.
Netz Stanišić Timing.
Hongkong Hong Kong Henneberg von Bretten. Wie kann man der Protest entsagen hast.
Hast du dir.
Die.
Auch ein großes soziales Experiment. Die wussten genau erster Juli sozusagen,
Stabs übergabe von Großbritannien nach China sondern eben auch dieser sich aus Tradition ergebende Tag des Protests hat man 23 Uhr am Vortag dieses Gesetz auf das so lange,
gewartet wurde wirklich veröffentlicht.
Diese macht einfach mal wirklich ausgespielt.
Und es ist so schlimm wie befürchtet. Das ist wirklich eine extreme Einschränkung die da stattfindet.
Inhaltlich ist es dann ganz deutlicher.
Also alles was dann auch an Protest stattfand wird eigentlich kriminalisiert im höchsten Maße ist sehr sehr gefährlich sich,
da überhaupt noch in irgendeiner Weise zu äußern weil alles dann auch immer noch so Offenheit dass im Prinzip alles als Systemkritik,
anerkannt werden kann.
Vor allem all das was in den Jahren davor stattfand. Man hat es so als würde man sich das mal anschauen und sagen Genau das soll das Gesetz betreffen. Von Deutschland.
Und,
von Deutschland gibts ja auch nicht viel Protest dagegen.
Es ist wohl noch einmal gesagt dass da nochmal auch von der chinesischen Wirtschaft nochmal an Wirtschaftsbosse delegiert hier in Deutschland gesagt wurde haltet euch mal zurück denn.
Aus Europa.
Wir arbeiten doch eigentlich jetzt gerade ganz gut zusammen auf ein vorbereitet ja hinsichtlich.
Es auf allen Ebenen vorbereitet auch hinsichtlich bis zu den durch die Caplan bis dahin wo man die Chinesen in Europa so findet.
Bis dahin wo man die Chinesen in Europa so ausgenommen kam da nicht umhin.
Ausgenommen Boris Johnson der kam dann nicht umhin noch einmal diesen großen die dreieinhalb Millionen Chinesen die auch.
Die dreieinhalb Millionen Chinesen könnten auch zu uns kommen aber das ist auch sehr eigensinnig geltenden England braucht ja jetzt diese Unterstützung quasi.
Zu uns kommen aber das ist auch sehr eigensinnig gewesen denn,
England braucht auch jetzt diese Unterstützung quasi.
Potthast Das war,
so eine Fahrt.
Zensur so Anemone James Joyce.
Burlesque.
Anemone,
enger.
Sogar drei Monate ist es wo es ist chemisch trivial.
Sogar die Klassiker haben eine Wüste Es ist chemisch.
Freund.
Es
ist,
an der Zeit.
Das.
Es ist teuer. Hongkong.
Ziel.
Ziel sei es.
Ist es daher.
Dass es am Ende des Center.
Gerne.
Ist muss man sich mal vorstellen. Die haben da einfach so ein riesiges Banner wie man das aus Nordkorea oder so kennt.
So im Sinne von Willkommen in neues Sicherheitsgesetz.
Die tasmanischen.
Shoppingmall.
Powys.
Kinky.
In bayerisch,
zu halten.
Bei den.
Ersten,
Zuckerrübe aus.
Hongkong Independents Ewing.
Independents.
Und Tageslichts.
Tommy Franka. Da geht's wahrhaft Mini Pippo fahrbare Gasse vom Arrival.
Man kennt das Hey Hey.
Wer in New York London Hongkong.
Wenn man mal diesen Vergleich noch hier,
300 Menschen festgenommen und zehn ungefähr auf Basis des neuen Gesetzes in Portland hat wahrscheinlich auch die Demonstranten schafft so mit 300 Kontakten zur Polizei irgendwie Probleme gehabt und zehn davon sind auf dieses,
Zeug zurückzuführen sind in dieser Dimension ähnelt sich ein bisschen aber in diesen Hintergrund.
Was das bedeutet und wie sich ein Staat durchsetzt das muss man auch sagen.
Zum Glück ist Trump inkompetenter ja völlig außer.
Und nicht organisiert denn das ist ja alles hier. Das ist selbstverständlich auch eine gewisse kommunistische Tradition Organisation ist alles.
Und das kann man da in aller Deutlichkeit erleben.
Zumindest in Hongkong.
Ja und man hat den Eindruck dass hier ein Exempel statuiert wird und dass man weiß wenn jetzt hier schon kein Widerspruch kommt wo das so massiv und offensichtlich ist und hier wird ja nicht mehr irgendwas im Geheimen gemacht.
Wie wird es dann künftig sein bei der Seidenstraße zum Beispiel wenn sich dort widersetzen möchte.
Wenn da jemand zahlungsunfähig wird zu welchen Konzessionen muss man da dann bereit sein und wo wird da dann auch geschwiegen werden.
Das ist ja eine sehr sehr heikle Situation und das Problem für Europa ist dass wir keine richtige Alternative haben.
Wir können nicht sagen naja aber der American Way of Life verspricht doch eigentlich nur Gutes haben wir auch gesehen nicht nur bei Trump sondern auch was da für imperiale Züge auftreten mit denen wir auch nicht einverstanden sein können.
Es ist sehr sehr eigenartig Wir sind da in so einem Zangengriff eigentlich,
kam da als Europäer momentan noch wenig Chancen uns autonom hinzustellen.
Die Möglichkeit die dann besteht ist tatsächlich Europa als eigener macht zwar nicht als Weltmacht aber doch als souveräne macht sich dann etabliert.
Das ist ja schon ein Plan von Macron aber dafür zieht man auch in Europa zu wenig an einem Strang. Bislang zumindest.
Bislang zumindest gab es ja im Juli auch eine Geschichte.
Europa wird sich jetzt erstmals selbst als Europa am Finanzmarkt verschulden und zwar in der Höhe von 750 Milliarden Euro.
Das sind zwei Bundeshaushalt und noch ein bisschen mehr. Das ist unglaublich. Es brauchte dafür wieder eine Krise.
Unglaublich wie eine Krise.
Corona hat sich angeboten und das haben wir hier so ein bisschen ausgespart weil es dazu einen eigenen Podcast gibt und zwar den Nachfolger Podcast vom aufwärmt Podcast daher nun auch zu Ende ging im Juli kann man ja auch mal kurz sagen Podcast ging zu Ende.
Zu Ende ging auch eine ära zu doch muss man so sagen.
Aber mit jedem ist ja ein Neubeginn verbunden.
Gibt Hinsicht jetzt einen Fernseh Podcast und der sollte eigentlich erst Ende August losgehen um hier auch mal ein bisschen Urlaub einzuplanen.
Aber ich habe die Nachrichten dazu gehört zu diesem EU-Gipfel.
Ich habe gedacht das kann doch wohl nicht wahr sein dass wir eine Riehler an Journalisten haben man muss einfach so sagen alle außer Markus Preiß vielleicht ein bisschen aber doch viele die sich ein Schauspiel angeguckt haben in ein richtiges Kammerspiel.
Treffen sich 27 Staats und Regierungschefs Journalisten sind außen vor.
Die dürfen nicht ins Gebäude wegen Kona ist also nicht wie bisher ein Gipfel gewesen der vor Ort stattfand. Das galt nur für die Politiker nicht für die Journalisten.
Also haben die Politiker die Chance genutzt die raren Momente des Kontaktes mit dem Journalismus ein Schauspiel aufzuführen zum Beispiel zur Frage Wieviel ist jetzt Zuschuss und wieviel ist Kredit.
Wieviel Geld müssen die Länder zurückzahlen an die EU-Kommission. Ich will nicht dass im Hintergrund die EU-Kommission selbst diese Gelder zur Verfügung stellt,
und zwar nicht indem sie irgendwem nochmal eine Steuer aufbürdet sondern indem sie einfach sagt Wir können doch auch an den Kapitalmarkt gehen.
Der lang geforderte Euro sozusagen jetzt Realität ist das wurde ein bisschen ausgeblendet.
Es ist nicht ganz Euro-Bonds Ich habe bei Jens wiederkomme nochmal nachgefragt denn die Haftung ist noch nicht so geregelt dass wenn ein Land sich nicht mehr dran beteiligen will dann die anderen einspringen müssen sondern Jedes Land haftet erst mal für sich.
Wir wissen aber auch faktisch kann kein europäisches Mitgliedsland jetzt sagen Ich habe die Gelder jetzt kassiert aber ich zahle jetzt nicht zurück weil dann würden alle anderen Länder einspringen.
Es muss nur im Vorfeld. Da kann man nicht auf die Krise warten sondern es muss im Vorfeld schon mal im Kleingedruckten so geregelt werden damit am Ende das Rating der Rating-Agenturen da ist und die Zinsen niedrig sind.
Deswegen ist das noch ein bisschen heikel aber die werden die finalen Abstimmungen sind ja im September dann im Europaparlament und alle nationalen Parlamente zustimmen.
Das werden Sie beim Haushalt der EU vielleicht nur mit Zögern und nach langem Qualen bei diesen 750 Milliarden Recovery Plan den ausgegoren ist das durch.
Da werden sich die Parlamente nicht querstellen da gibt's kein Widerstand im Europaparlament aus den nationalen Parlamenten nicht weil alle Geld kriegen.
Geschenkt. Wir wissen eh keiner zurück den Anteil der Kredite ist sondern wir haben jetzt 750 Milliarden eigene Verschuldung.
Da kann man den Bogen schlagen zu. Hamilton Das ist der hemmten Moment so kann man es nennen.
So wurde es ja auch mehrmals genannt.
Genau. Und zwar aus einem einfachen Grund. Ja George Washington hat die Nation geeint und über Vertragstext und hier die Verfassung und so weiter.
Alles schön und gut aber jede Nation braucht ein finanzielles Fundament.
Und das war natürlich Alexander Hamilton zuständig.
Er dann auch singt Road Financial,
Systems into Existenz Ja das war seine Aufgabe die finanzielle Grundlage zu schaffen und wir haben jetzt das erste Mal in Europa genau so eine einheitliche eigene Europa eigene finanzielle Grundlage nämlich 750 Milliarden Euro die,
die EU-Kommission komplett verschenken wollte gerne.
Die wollten einfach dass Merkel Macron sagen Wir machen fünf Milliarden sagt Ursula von der Leyen noch 250 Milliarden drauf da haben sich die sparsamen vier geweigert sagten ein kleiner Teil muss Kredit bleiben ist egal wird eh nicht zurückgezahlt sondern die EU-Kommission.
Ihr Anliegen ist Wir verschenken das Geld an die Mitgliedsstaaten und refinanzieren das über eigene Steuern.
Wir haben also nicht nur das erste Mal eigene Verschuldung sondern wir haben auch das erste Mal einen beginnenden Gesetzgebungsprozess der eigene europäische Steuern vorsieht dass nicht nur Teile der Mehrwertsteuer in Europa aus den Mitgliedsstaaten abgegeben werden einfach eine Etage höher gereicht,
sondern dass die EU-Kommission selber und das haben wir hier groß diskutiert.
European Green Deal und so weiter. Eine Grenzsteuersatz Wir waren Stahl zum Beispiel der nicht ganz so klimafreundlich hergestellt wurde.
Eine digital Steuer kann natürlich auch im Urteil dieses Urteil dass Apple nicht 13 Milliarden an Irland nachzahlen muss,
sondern da sind gerade die Franzosen jetzt dabei ihre eigene Digitalstrategie,
haben die auch unter Beschuss ist einfach zum europäischen Projekt zu machen und zu sagen wenn ein französischer Entwickler in Belgien eine App verkauft an jemanden der sich in Estland vorher ein iPhone kaufte dann fällt die Wertschöpfung nicht im Silicon Valley an.
Nur weil das Design davon kommt sondern dann ist das Wertschöpfung die hier anfällt und hier abgeschöpft werden kann.
Also ist da einiges in Bewegung und man will eine Plastics Steuer einführen.
Also nennen sich lauter Gesetze. Sagen wir mal so Es ist ja nicht schon Hypothesen mäßig diskutiert.
Wenn die Europäische Kommission nun die nächsten sieben Jahre Finanz bis zum nächsten Haushaltsbuch nutzt um eigene Steuern einzunehmen dann werden das Steuern sein die wir alle akzeptieren.
Es wird also nicht nochmal eine Erhöhung von Mehrwertsteuer sein die dann nach Europa fließt sondern es wird eine genuine europäische Steuer sein die wir alle akzeptieren.
Und so sieht man es jetzt auch schon. Klima Steuern Plastics steuern gegen Umweltverschmutzung digital steuern weil diese wahnsinnigen Gewinne über die wir dann im August reden können auch genau hier versteuert werden wo auch fünfhundert Millionen Menschen das Zeug nutzen und überhaupt erst den Wert,
dahin bringen und so der ist.
Begleiten. Ich bin ja mal gespannt wie es überhaupt mit der Mehrwertsteuer sein wird wenn man die wieder anhebt im Januar ob man dann nicht sagt auch Wir heben jetzt mal auf 21 Prozent an.
Das ist nämlich durchaus zuzutrauen. Ich erinnere daran Wir hatten mal eine Mehrwertsteuer die lag bei 16 Prozent dann sagte die SPD auf keinen Fall gibt's eine Mehrwertsteuererhöhung um 2 Prozent und es gab auch keine 2 prozent sondern um drei Prozent.
Deswegen ist das für mich noch gar nicht gemacht Es kann sein dass wir da noch böse böse bluten müssen.
Insofern ist es vielleicht auch ganz gut wenn da aus Europa ein anderer Wind weht schlechte Tage für Peter Gauweiler sag noch Wie heißt dein Podcaster Neuer.
Man findet ihn unter Fernsehspot Karst. Er soll aber nicht dauerhaft so heißen das ist jetzt nur für die Anfangsphase.
Aber du wirst Fernsehprediger Du wirst wie der Titel Fernsehen schauen.
Ja ja ja es machen sich immer viele zerbrechen sich den Kopf mit der Frage Was soll ich in meinem Podcast behandeln.
Und dann sieht man sehr viel nochmal das Unbekannte des Täters und so einzukleiden irgendwie.
Und dann sieht man sehr viele Bemühungen nochmal das Unbekannte des Täters in True Crime irgendwie auszupacken oder hier noch mal mit Menschen zu reden mit dem man sonst nie gesprochen hat.
Oder hier nochmal mit Menschen zu reden mit dem man sonst nie gesprochen hat. Keiner macht das Offensichtliche.
Keiner macht das Offensichtliche einfach mal die Abendnachrichten zu gucken wie es jetzt Im Aufwärmprogramm.
Einfach mal die Abendnachrichten zu gucken gab es jetzt noch Amfortas Ich habe es ja über Jahre immer häufiger schneidet und Tagesthemen jetzt will ich noch ein bisschen ausbreiten heute schnell Tagesthemen und dann aber auch die Diskussionssendung in es spontan zugeht.
Ich habe es ja über Jahre immer heute journal und Tagesthemen jetzt soll ich noch ein bisschen ausbreiten heute journal tagesthemen und dann aber auch die Diskussionssendung in denen spontan zugeht also vor allem die,
Talkshows geht aber vor allem auch Markus Lanz denn da wird doch mal die eine oder andere Idee und Constellation durch geprügelt die man auch beobachten muss.
Markus Lanz.
Ich gucke ja Lahms hin und wieder ja doch ganz gerne aber ehrlich gesagt nicht wenn Politiker da sind sondern Unterhaltung.
Ich möchte eigentlich Dagmar Koller Da haben die nochmal erzählt wie war das damals mit Peter Weck und Helmut Zilk und den Ketzern Wien.
Es ist immer eine gute Mischung.
Waren eigentlich so.
Und dann warten eigentlich so aus dem gesellschaftlichen Leben Menschen für die letzte Viertelstunde und die müssen sich dann aber immer schon mal fragen.
Ich.
In diesem Sinne muss ich habe es bisher immer nur gehört aber nie etwas mitgebracht.
Großen.
Aus Zeitgründen aber jetzt im Fernseh Podcast hat man dafür mehr Zeit. Und dann wieder wöchentlich zu machen.
Wöchentlich Wir sind gespannt. Wir sind natürlich immer Bust.
Wir sind gespannt imAugust. Wer beides running mate wird das wird auch noch mal eine große Sache die wir dann.
Und hoffen dass es keine zweite Welle gibt Ich möchte nochmal an den wunderbaren Werbeslogan zum heimischen Tourismus erinnern den Markus Söder der vielleicht künftige Kanzler Deutschlands.
Wir haben da spektakuläre Bilder gesehen Politiker Journalisten langgediente fragten Ist das jetzt irgendwie Kalkül von Merkel.
Wirklich.
Nein die wollte einfach mal in Bayern eine Kutschfahrt machen oder so.
Im Schloss auftreten.
Wahnsinn. Aber er sagt ja diesen wunderbaren Satz Wer österreich erleben will der kann das auch in Bayern tun.
Das sollte man sich doch ein bisschen zu Herzen nehmen.
Sehrgut.
Aber wir sehen uns ja vorher noch im Salon. Ich werde unter anderem ein Buch vorstellen das wichtig ist weil wir uns im Hegel ja befinden wir feiern ja Hegel Jubiläum.
Und was könnte da näher liegen als ein Buch von Slavoj žižek einem der wichtigsten Hegel Experten und er hat ein Buch geschrieben Hegel in einem vertraten Gehirn.
Und er fragt sich so neuerer Link Wenn wir jetzt unser Gehirn bald vernetzen können mit dem Internet.
Was sagt das eigentlich dann noch über uns aus wie sagen wir da noch.
Was bedeutet das für unsere Subjektivität für unsere Autonomie.
Das ist ein Buch das übermorgen erscheint aber ich habe es schon gelesen.
Und darum soll es gehen und dann noch ein zweites Buch. Ich dachte jetzt ist Reisezeit jetzt kann man auch viel lesen.
Da geht es um die Angestellten von heute und dann noch drei journalistische.
Ja ich freue mich über wir beide freuen uns über 200 neue Mitglieder jetzt im Juli.
Das ist ganz gut und zehn davon sind tatsächlich Mitglieder wir haben ja im letzten Salone die Gästeliste eröffnet.
Ihr könnt direkt im Text eine Gästeliste dazu ein kleines Google Docke wo man wenn man sich bereiterklärt die sieben Euro im Monat zu bezahlen kann mir drei weitere einladen und in der Liste sammeln sich Menschen die,
aus Gründen die natürlich nachvollziehbar sind Crooner Zeiten dann vielleicht auch kostenlos teilnehmen können.
Und da hoffen wir auf eine kleine Solidargemeinschaft dass man das einfach über so ein Gästelisten Börsenplatz miteinander Auskühlung.
Und ja 100 Mitglieder und 190 neue zahlende Mitglieder haben im Juli gewonnen das natürlich sehr gut.
Das macht nämlich auch Freude wenn man hinter einer Paywall Podcast und genau weiß das trifft jetzt 700 Leute die das auch wirklich interessiert die ein bisschen nicht nur emotional investiert haben sondern so richtig dabei sind sehr gut.
Mein Top-Thema ist noch einmal Trump Wir werden es abschließen.
Noch vor Tag so Trump wird danieder liegen und keiner wird mir damit rechnen dass überhaupt noch etwas passiert.
Hast du es dir wirklich angetan.
Das Buch von Mary Trump seiner Nichte ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Wir haben ja über Bolden gesprochen und Bolden hat ja nun ein politisches Buch vorgelegt weil er so dieses Ich bin ja eigentlich der viel Galeere Außenpolitiker aller Zeiten Pipapo.
Das ist bei mir Trump natürlich ganz anders denn sie gibt klar zu erkennen warum sie das Buch schreibt nachdem Trump meine Familie vernichtet hat.
Insbesondere mein Vater ist nämlich gestorben möchte ich verhindern dass Trump auch mein Land in Mitleidenschaft zieht.
Also mein Trump mein Land zerstört und sie ist selber ausgebildete Psychologin. Sie hat dazu.
Sie hat psychiatrisch glaube ich Peak gemacht nachdem sie es im Studium nicht so dominant hatte hat sie dann nochmal psychologisch nachgelegt.
Es ist eine wirklich gruselige Abhandlung über die Familie.
Es geht vor allem viel über die Beziehung zum Vater und dann zur Großfamilie die man dann immer mal trifft.
Und sie zeichnet eben nochmal dieses ganz gefährliche Bild von Trump dass er sie nämlich beschreibt.
Trump hat seinen Lebzeiten in einem goldenen Käfig gelebt immer geschützt von seinem Vater der ihm Geld nachgeschossen hat.
Hauptsache es Familien ansehen ist irgendwie da und Trump konnte halt gut mit Politikern und so weiter.
Trump hat immer dieses als Kaufmann komplett daneben.
Aber er konnte immer so toll in den Medien mit den Politikern in New York mit der Mafia und so weiter diese Kontakte halten und deswegen war das so eine geben und nehmen Beziehung aus dem Vater und dem Sohn.
Und der zweite Sohn kam dabei unter die Räder der so Pilot geworden wollte ein normales Leben führen und sie zeichnet dieses Bild wie Trump immer im goldenen Käfig lebte und auch die ersten drei Jahre im Amt.
In so einem goldenen Käfig lebt er weil nämlich plötzlich als er ins Amt kam und meinte das Wichtigste für mich ist erst einmal dass ich euch eine Billion Steuerermäßigung schenke hat er sich viele Freunde gemacht. Und dann kam plötzlich Corona.
Und jetzt kann Trump seine Unfähigkeit nicht mehr verstecken und zwar das allererste Mal in seinem Leben kann er seine Unfähigkeit nicht mehr verstecken und davor möchte sie waren und sie beschreibt das ausführlich sie beschreibt es,
also wirklich gut es ist wirklich ein Buch das man sich mal kurz anschauen muss das darf man nicht so einfach drüber hinweggehen im Sinne von nicht beitreten oder so. Sondern Da gehts auch richtig zur Sache.
Ein paar humorige aber die Motivation macht sie glasklar und dann ist das auch sehr stringent durchgearbeitet.
Also in der Hinsicht sollte man sich darüber informieren.
Ein Grund mehr noch in den Salon hier einzusteigen gehört leider dann reingehauen bis August.
Reingehauen.
Intro/Outro